in the Contemporary digital realm the
digital marketing specialist is a
crucial asset they adaptively handle SEO
social media content strategy and data
analytics to drive online business
success through audience targeting
refined campaigns and data driven
insights these Specialists boost
engagement Elevate brand visibility and
Foster growth in the digital age so if
you are looking to become a digital
marketing specialist then look no
further than simply learn postgraduate
program in digital marketing with this
you gain all the necessity skills in
digital marketing like website creation
behavioral marketing keyword research
search engine optimization search engine
marketing campaign management social
media marketing and more with knowledge
of tools like SC ranking hoot suit chat
GPT Google ads Google Keyword Planner
Google Trends and there's much more on
the list don't miss out on this
incredible opportunity take action today
and enroll in a course to unlock the
digital marketing success accelerator
career and gain the skills you need to
thrive in the industry ready to get
started then click on the link mentioned
in the description box and embark on
your journey to professional growth and
achievement and without any further Ado
over to our tutors
meet Joey a digital marketer he works as
the head of digital marketing for Amazon
but how did Joey get here a few years
ago Joey began to see a large number of
opportunities popping up in the field of
digital marketing to begin his entry
into the field he needed to understand
what exactly digital marketing was and
what was so great about it first Joey
learned that digital marketing was a
form of marketing through which you
could advertise to people digitally
digital marketing leveraged different
channels like search engines websites
social media platforms emails and mobile
applications it would give marketers the
opportunity to interact with and
understand their audience better and to
increase the trust in their Grant
digital marketing would also show
marketers advertisements to People based
on their actions and preferences on the
internet while being less expensive than
traditional forms of advertising after
understanding the main concepts of
digital marketing Joey realized there
was more to digital marketing than he
initially thought there are also many
types of digital marketing types like
content marketing search engine
optimization pay-per-click social media
marketing email marketing and affiliate
marketing and once he understood those
types he set up a digital marketing
campaign for his uncle's e-commerce
website let's have a look at what he
came up with first Joey created content
like blogs videos infographics and case
studies so that he could generate
audience interest in the Brand's
products or services
this was content marketing next he
needed his audience to actually see his
content the first step was to create
content on specific Search keywords that
were relevant to the target audience
Joey would make optimizations on the
website and have credible websites
linking back to the content and lo and
behold the website began ranking on the
first page of the search results
by continuous optimizations Joey would
continue to improve the ranking and
ultimately make the website rank at the
first position this was SEO or search
engine optimization and Joey could do
all of this without spending a single
penny he could also Drive traffic to the
website with advertisements but for this
he would have to pay a certain fee each
time the ads were clicked he could have
text ads that show up in search engine
results image ads and video ads that
show up in websites and much more
this was possible with the help of PPC
or pay-per-click however Joey wasn't
done yet to reach a larger audience he
needed to tap into social media
platforms
he would use social media platforms like
LinkedIn YouTube Facebook and Instagram
to advertise the Brand's content he
would use these platforms to advertise
the Brand's products or services with
posts images videos and more to bring
out the Brand's story and engage with
the Brand's audience who spend a lot of
time on social media like PPC he could
use the platform to advertise the
Brand's products or services with text
image and video ads which needed to be
paid for that's social media marketing
Joey realized that a large amount of the
audience weren't visiting the Brand's
website a second time he needed to keep
them engaged nurture them to make sure
they purchased the product for this he
would send them emails that help them
better understand the products they
visited on the website and assist them
in the buying process he would also send
emails to advertisers products or
services to potential customers that is
with email marketing and finally
although Joey was able to grow the
Brand's funnel he wanted more traffic
from third-party websites this could be
achieved with affiliate marketing
Affiliates would promote the brand or
product to their audiences for a fee
with the help of email signups
registrations conversions subscriptions
Etc
after setting all of this up Joey had
the hardest part of the process to get
through the wait now let's see what
happens at the end of Joey's weight
although Joey had worked really hard on
each of these forms of digital marketing
he only had moderate success that's when
Joey realized he had to gain more
knowledge and experience so he decided
to get certified and get ahead in his
career with the help of Simply learn he
took up simplylearn's digital marketing
certification and got the skills and
training he needed to become an expert
digital marketer and now you know where
he is you too can do the same and grow
in your career by clicking on the top
right corner and with that we've given
you an introduction to all the major
concepts of digital marketing digital
marketing plays an essential role in
most businesses today this has led to an
increase in the demand for digital
marketing professionals because of this
many people are interested in learning
about digital marketing it is becoming
one of the essential skills that you can
have if you learn how to use it you can
make a difference in your marketing
capabilities hey everyone I am tusha
badiwal welcome to Simply learns YouTube
channel in this video we will discuss
the top 10 reasons to learn digital
marketing but before we begin if you
enjoy watching Tech related content
consider subscribing to our YouTube
channel and hitting that Bell icon to
stay tuned
so without any further delay let's get
started
easy to start a career a career in
digital marketing is an easy one to
start the field is growing rapidly and
there is a demand for professionals who
can care the digital assets of a company
with this in mind it is easy to find a
position even with no specific degree it
is also easy to find further training in
digital marketing as a lot of free and
paid resources are available
a technical and creative field both
Technical and creative skills are
necessary for digital marketing it has a
lot of subfield hence it requires a
unique skill set and knowledge of the
latest technology for example a social
media marketing professional should know
how to run a successful campaign digital
marketing is a perfect career option for
those who are interested in both the
creative and Technical fields
highly paid digital marketing is one of
the most popular and trending Industries
there is a vast demand for digital
marketing professionals as a result
digital marketing roles are also very
well paid your expertise could help you
gain better roles within your
organization which could improve your
salary according to Goldman sex report
digital marketing scope in the Indian
internet industry alone is expected to
reach us 160 billion by 2025 which shows
the extent of digital marketing in India
and the job demand for digital marketing
according to Glassdoor a digital
marketing manager earns around 7 lakh in
India and he she can earn roughly 1 lakh
23 000 dollars in the US
become an entrepreneur as a digital
marketer you will be familiar with wide
range of online tools and platforms you
can start a blog or website where you
can list your products or if you have
expertise in some field you can also
create your own digital products and
sell them online
also you can start your own freelancing
business where you can offer various
services to the clients all aspiring
entrepreneurs need to embrace digital
marketing and even the old ones need to
adapt in order to grow
career growth there are a lot of digital
marketing professionals around but very
few are skilled the demand for digital
marketing skills will increase in the
near future due to digital economies
rapid growth
many individuals are starting their
online businesses and almost every new
company starts with an online presence
hence it's a perfect chance for
individuals who are looking to make a
career in digital marketing
the next reason is versatility
digital marketing offers a variety of
career options and a lifetime learning
since there are so many aspects to it
for example suppose you worked in
content marketing for two years and now
you want to work in SEO
in that case there is relatively little
training you need so it won't be that
difficult to switch over if you want to
enter into some other domain your
digital marketing experience will always
be valuable therefore it is said that
digital marketers can easily change jobs
the next major reason is more number of
jobs several new jobs were created in
the digital marketing field after covet
as most businesses came online you will
find many digital marketing job
opportunities on LinkedIn every single
day Grandview research reports that the
global digital marketing software Market
size was USD 56 billion in 2021 and is
expected to grow at a compound annual
growth rate cagr of 19.1 percent from
2022 to 2030.
the field of digital marketing is vast
however digital marketing is also used
in other areas such as blockchain
blockchain provides trustworthy metrics
for monitoring marketing campaigns in
real time it's also a good chance for
digital marketers to discover other
fields like blockchain
time and cost effective in the long term
digital marketing will save you a lot of
time effort and money traditional
marketing is expensive and the cost keep
Rising there are cost of printing ads
television ads radio ads and billboards
digital marketing will give you more
profits than traditional marketing if
you know how to use it effectively
furthermore digital marketing requires
less efforts for example you can reach
Global audience using your laptop
sitting at home while traditional
marketing involves a lot of efforts
the next important reason is precision
proof job lending your dream job is a
rarity for many in the job market with
the economy still struggling businesses
are cutting jobs left and right so how
you can make yourself Recession Proof if
you are creative and willing to learn it
can happen there are many ways to make
yourself more desirable to businesses
and get job offers however one way is to
become an expert in digital marketing
digital marketing is the internet based
marketing of product and services using
digital Technologies mainly on the
internet
marketing is an integral part of any
business with the ever growing number of
Internet users it is expected that more
companies will use digital marketing
extensively in the future
so now let's discuss the last and
interesting reason specialization the
field of digital marketing has a wide
range of specializations SEO content
marketing influencer marketing sem and
many other fall under digital marketing
an individual has a lot to explore and
once you explode you can pick a digital
marketing specialization according to
your interest additionally there is a
wide variety of skills that you need to
master under each of these categories
greetings everyone this is Rob Sanders
from Simply learn happy New Year and
today we're gonna talk about digital
marketing skills
so digital marketing allows business
owners regardless of the business
non-profit for-profit large or small
National local International to really
expand their business allows them to
personalize their content they could
save money and most importantly they can
measure the results and so that's what
we're going to focus on today when we
talk about digital marketing skills
focusing on measuring those results so
suppose anybody wants to work in
marketing or grow a company or help grow
an individual's company or ensure to
keep up with the appropriate skills this
is what we're going to cover today so
we're going to cover a few channels and
so let's get right to it today we're
going to start off with search engine
optimization or SEO
also known as organic search so SEO
is an interesting channel it's probably
the premier channel for most companies
in fact HubSpot confirms that 57 of B2B
marketers stated that SEO generates more
leads than any other marketing
initiative
so it's really important for not only
just generating traffic but it's also
important for generating leads and and
generating more business
including e-commerce and so what does
SEO entail and what skills should you
acquire in order to manage SEO as a
marketing channel
well if you think about it SEO is really
divvied up into two pies one pie is
called on page the other pie is called
off Pitch and so on page consists of
things you can do to the website to help
you
be found in organic search
so what are those things well it could
be anything from you know page load
speed to four or four errors to sitemaps
and so the point here is if you're going
to manage SEO and you know that you got
to make sure your website's in Tip-Top
shape or your clients websites and good
enough shape for Google to recognize it
as a legitimate site you have to have
some technical skills now I'm not saying
you have to be developer but at the same
time you have to know what a 4-4 error
is you know have to know where and how
to generate a site map and upload that
sitemap you need to know how to edit a
robot's text file so those are you know
what I call soft technical skills but
they're all valid for SEO so you have to
have some technical background
staying in the on page pie
okay you need to make sure you have not
only skills to write content but skills
to optimize content so you need to be
aware of all the different elements on a
page in order to optimize that page
so again that entails you know some
copywriting skills but more importantly
and probably more challenging is to take
those copywriting skills and enhance
them for SEO okay so making sure that
you're able to understand what it is
that you need to do to get a page
optimized so it can rank higher in the
search engine results so those are
on-page skills
and then you got the other piece of the
pie which is off page so understanding
you know what it takes to make sure your
site is relevant so it's understanding
different metrics off page metrics like
page Authority domain Authority external
links internal links and so generally
most SEO managers have a third-party SEO
platform that they work with like
semrush or Moz so it's understanding how
to work with those platforms to measure
off-page results so
we always say that SEO as a digital
marketing channel is an 800 pound
gorilla well it is because you have on
page and off page to worry about so the
two of those together you know is is
quite a task in order to rank
and so it brings SEO and all digital
marketing channels is understanding the
metrics and understanding what you're
seeing in order to measure results and
improve upon those results okay so
that's really the theme for all these
digital marketing channels we're going
to talk about today it's really about
okay what metrics and how do I measure
the results and so when we look at SEO
in terms of measuring results
on the on page side okay you're going to
have to do some keyword analysis you're
going to have to understand okay what
volume is you're going to understand how
to get the competition numbers okay and
you're going to have to understand what
keywords to choose okay so that in
itself is a skill being able to choose
keywords based on several metrics then
you're going to have to be able to
ascertain you know what pages and what
keywords are driving traffic and how
those pages are performing
okay and then again the off page you got
different metrics like domain Authority
or page Authority
you have external links internal links
you have no follow and follows and and
you know a lot of these little metrics
related to off Pages yes you're going to
have to understand what those metrics
mean and if you can understand what
those metrics mean and then more
importantly act on those metrics then
that's what's going to help you improve
your results in terms of SEO
so again that's going to be the common
theme here so I'm just going to
highlight again those metrics that
you're going to need to understand in
order to better manage SEO as a channel
get on the on page side you need to
understand the technicalities involved
but for example page load what's a good
page load time what's a bad page load
tone from a keyword perspective what's
good volume what's bad volume what's
good competition what's bad competition
so if you can understand the intricacies
of the measurements related to SEO then
that'll help you improve upon this big
Channel called organic search so SEO is
the practice of getting relevant traffic
to the website okay from organic search
results so it really is essential to
stay up to date
and have a complete knowledge of the
latest algorithm updates and factors
that affect search engine ranking
so that's SEO let's transition to search
engine marketing also known as paid
search sponsored search Google ads Bing
ads pay-per-click cost per click a lot
of acronyms a lot of ways to describe it
at the end of the day search engine
marketing means that hey you as an
Advertiser have the ability and have the
opportunity to rank at the very top of
the Google search results
now it's different than SEO because
you're actually paying for the placement
and so to be found at the top of the
search engine results
as a paid placement or sponsored ad
means that if somebody clicks on your ad
you're going to pay Google X amount okay
so unlike SEO sem is very fast moving
and so when we talk about fast moving we
mean that you're collecting a lot of
data very quickly so sticking with the
theme of what skills should I have for
search engine marketing well if you're
going to collect data then that means
you need to measure the results of that
data and so sticking with our theme of
measuring results you need to understand
first and foremost what all the
different metrics mean related to
Central engine marketing okay so I'm
just gonna rattle off if you will a few
of the metrics but the commonality here
is
yes you can learn what those metrics
mean but you have to act on those
metrics so one of the the main metrics
involved with search engine marketing is
Impressions so impression is just
basically how many people have seen your
ad okay so if your ad shows up on the
search results page regardless of
whether somebody clicks on it or not
you're going to get an impression okay
so if you're getting a lot of
Impressions that means a lot of people
have seen your ad what's a lot of
impressions well it's objective okay so
it could be a thousand Impressions or
ten thousand Impressions at the end of
the day that's how many people have seen
your ad
now more importantly
you have another metric called clicks
clicks means how many people actually
saw your ad and then clicked on your ad
okay so if you have 100 people that have
seen your ad and one person who clicked
on your ad then you have a click through
rate of one percent
now when it comes to Google ads and
search engine Marketing in general you
want to have a high click-through rate
especially on Google because that does
impact quality score so quality score is
another metric you need to be aware of
okay it's a quality score simply a
number between 1 and 10 that's assigned
to each keyword okay so what impacts
quality score click-through rate is one
of the factors that impact quality score
so if you have
200 or 300 or 500 or a thousand
Impressions and very little clicks that
means your click the rates going to be
low and if your click-through rate it's
going to be low then your quality score
is going to be low
and in order to pay less to Google you
need to make sure that your quality
score is good so you need to understand
the factors involve a quality score you
need to understand Impressions clicks
click-through rate because if you don't
have a good click-through rate
then how do you improve that so it's
about measuring the results and acting
upon the results those are the skills
involved with search engine marketing
and that's just on the click side you
got the conversion side of the house so
you need to be able to understand how to
get conversions
and how to maintain a high conversion
rate so for example if you have a
hundred clicks
and only one conversion
that is a one percent conversion rate
okay fair enough but what are you paying
per conversion what's the cost per
conversion okay and if that number is
high like say twenty dollars and you're
only selling a product that's say ten
dollars
well then you got a problem
and so there's a lot of different
metrics involved with search engine
marketing you're collecting this data
very quickly so you need to be able to
react to the data that you see so that's
the skill set really involves search
engine marketing if you're getting the
data if it's a low click the rate or low
conversion rate or high cost per
conversion
or very low Impressions you need to be
able to understand how to react to what
you're seeing and what your data you're
collecting that to me is the primary
skill bottom line with search engine
marketing and there are other skill sets
involved don't get me wrong I mean it's
nice to be able to write copy because
with search engine marketing
typically the ads have very few
characters involved so you need to be
able to write a compelling ad to
convince somebody to click on your ad
and so writing Copy being able to
understand your target audience
um those are all things involved with
managing search engine marketing but
really the key component here is again
measuring the results okay let's switch
over to a traditional marketing channel
email marketing you know one of my
favorites you know listen we're all
bombarded with emails
uh and you know what it it becomes
cumbersome at times I mean it's easy to
just just regard an email and so to me
the key here if you're going to do email
marketing
you need to have a certain set of skill
sets and so what that skill set is is
really understanding your audience
because if you send an email to a
certain set of recipients
you need to hope that that email is
relevant to that audience okay so you
need to be able to really identify who
it is we're sending this email to
and a recent study done by statista
stated that 49 of consumers really like
to receive promotional emails from their
favorite Brands so if you have a very
strong brand then email marketing it's
probably a good channel for you if you
don't have a strong brand or nobody
really knows about your brand or your
product or your business then email
marketing could be a little bit of a
steeper Hill to climb if you will
but really email marketing is it
involves emails that promote the brands
products and services and if you could
Target the Right audience or making sure
you have the Right audience then you got
a good chance of having successful email
marketing campaigns
but when it comes to emails
you know it's like having a blank canvas
you can be as creative as you want as
long as you're talking to the audience
so the big skill set here again is
copywriting and having some you know
creativity involved with that
copyrighted saying the right things but
not saying too much at the same time
making the email aesthetically pleasing
as possible so that when somebody does
open the email
they're going to be able to react to it
so you know writing copy with strong
call to action a really relevant copy
that really talks to the audience I mean
those are all keys for email marketing
in my opinion
also one thing we didn't bring up in
search engine marketing but it certainly
holds true with search engine marketing
as well as email marketing and that's a
b testing and so a b testing has simply
taking an original and creating a
variant and testing the two to see which
one performs
well you could certainly do a b testing
with email marketing that means taking a
subject line
that has traditionally worked for you or
is relevant for that audience and then
creating
a variant or different subject line so
if I'm going to send an email to 100
people I'm going to send 50
people one subject line and then the
other 50 is going to get my variance
subsequent and why is this important
because I want to be able to see what
people react to
okay so if I see the open rates higher
for the variant
versus the traditional or the original
subject line then I know that this
subject line works and therefore I'm
going to apply this subject line moving
forward and then what am I going to do
I'm going to take it and test it against
another variant so you should always do
a b testing on subject lines so the
concept of a b testing should not be
lost on any digital marketer okay
whether that be SEO search engine
marketing or email marketing
so you should have an understanding of a
b testing and of course going back to
measuring results with email you have a
different set of metrics we already
mentioned open rates so if you send out
100 emails how many people open the
email okay you want that open rate to be
as high as possible and then when they
open the email the people click on that
CTA or any of those links in the email
okay so you want a high click-through
rate and then more importantly when they
click on a link in the email they're
going to go to a landing page
you want that person to engage with that
landing page so it's the engagement rate
of the landing page from the email okay
so it's really important that you have
an understanding of all the different
metrics involved with email marketing
and again
how to react to that data so if you're
getting a low open rate could it be the
subject line isn't that good possibly
that's why you have to do testing if
you're getting a low clicked it right on
the emails
that could be because the copy may not
be that great or the design or the call
to action or it's not compelling enough
for the recipient of the email and then
again the engagement on the landing page
if you have a low engagement rate a low
conversion rate
you got to look at that and figure out
how to improve that okay so you can
apply a B test in the landing page so
there are always ways to react to the
data regardless of what campaign or
regardless of what digital marketing
channel you're working in
yeah so that's the commonality here one
point on email marketing is if you're
going to measure the results of the
campaign whether you're using you know
vertical response or MailChimp or you
know some other email marketing platform
you want to make sure you have what we
call a UTM tracking and if you're using
Google analytics having UTM tracking or
understanding what UTM tracking is
allows you to measure the results of
that email marketing campaign in Google
analytics so that's another skill set
you should have being able to apply you
know tracking to your digital marketing
campaigns including email
okay because if you don't it's going to
be hard to measure the results in Google
Analytics so let's focus on one more
marketing channel here and that's social
media so we all know social media isn't
going anywhere it's becoming more and
more popular
in fact you know offshoot of social
media is really influencer marketing uh
you know if somebody an influencer has
millions of likes on say tick tock or
Instagram you might want to engage with
that influencer and help you promote
your brand or your product
isn't that really what social media is
it's a platform whether that be you know
Facebook or Twitter it's a it's a
platform to help you promote your brand
your product your services and it's a
chance for you to get to message your
user base your community prospective
clients people who don't even know about
your brand it's a chance to build
awareness so social media holds a lot of
different uh strategies if you will in
fact nearly almost 4 billion of the
world's population uses social media let
me say there's seven something billion
people in the world well that's a large
percentage a majority of the percentage
of the world uses a social media
platform okay in fact
just like SEO where you need an SEO
platform there are plenty of social
media platforms there's later there's
Sprouts social there's HootSuite there's
buffer in fact buffer confirms that 73
percent of marketers believe social
media marketing has been somewhat
effective or very effective for their
business and that's promising because
social media in my opinion
having been in this industry a while it
can be a very fickle Channel I mean if
you're trying to promote a product or
service on Facebook
and it's very very gonna be very hard to
pull that person away who's engaged with
their Facebook feed
not only just to get them away from the
Facebook feed onto your website but then
to turn around and allow that person to
try and convert
okay based on what you have on your
website so it's challenging enough just
to get them away from the social media
platform let alone convert it so that's
why when I say very fickle but you know
somewhat encouraging if Buffer's telling
us that marketers believe that social
media marketing can be effective and it
can be effective you just have to have
the right strategy so to me one of the
skill sets you should have if you're
going to be a social media marketing
manager is being able to understand you
know what is the strategy here what are
we trying to achieve
when we set up a social media platform
or enact a social media campaign
okay and so that's really the first
thing it's really understanding what
platforms what's the strategy here
because if the strategy is brand
awareness then what channels or social
media platforms if you will work best
for us is that Twitter is that Facebook
so it's being able to kind of formulate
a strategy a plan if you will for social
media marketing because the last thing
you want to do as a marketer is
endlessly just post content for the sake
of just posting content
because just like any other marketing
channel you're going to have metrics and
social media is not shy on the metric
front Okay so you have reach
you have Impressions you know engagement
rate in fact every social media channel
has its own set of specific metrics
whether that be likes followers shares
uh uh reviews Stars if you will so it
really depends on the social media
platform that you're using but at the
end of the day you need to be able to
measure the results if you're posting
let's just say on Facebook
and your whole
job or strategy is to entice engagement
meaning get people to share that
particular post or act on that post then
you need to be able to measure the
engagement how many people saw the post
how many people engage with the post
okay and so just like any other
marketing channel you're collecting data
and you need to react to that data but
more importantly it's about being able
to you know put a strategy together
first
and then I would you know a skill set I
would recommend you have is
understanding all the different social
media platforms that are out there you
know I just didn't buffer or HootSuite
or Sprout social they're all good in
their own right but they're all going to
have different features so to me
understanding what social media platform
works best for you you want to choose a
social media platform that you know
allows you to control what post you
schedule when you schedule them how
they're scheduled what platform they're
scheduled on
at the same time you want a social media
platform that's going to help you
understand the engagement that you're
getting from that platform
and you'll probably want a social media
platform that allows you to quote
unquote listen in if you will on what
users are you know reacting to in terms
of hashtags or what's trending on that
particular platform
okay so you want to listen until if you
will uh as part of that social media
platform so it's understanding what
platform you want to use when it comes
to social media marketing it's
understanding what strategy that that
platform is going to help you when they
enact okay and then it's also that
social media platform that's going to
help you understand the data so you can
react to the data
so those are all to me the skill sets
you need as a social media manager and
then
an offshoot of social media is paid
social so just like search engine
marketing you can advertise on say
Twitter LinkedIn Facebook on a cost per
click basis meaning if you're showing
your ad on LinkedIn and somebody clicks
on it you're gonna pay
for that click you're going to pay
LinkedIn or you're going to pay Twitter
you're going to play Facebook so it's
understanding you know the skill sets
involved with paid socials understanding
what assets you can have when
advertising on these platforms you know
can you use video on LinkedIn or
Facebook
um you know can you use what type of
images and you know how big do those
images need to be and can you have
wording on those images or what are the
guidelines involved with having images
as part of your ads
so having a full understanding of the
types of assets that you can run in
terms of your advertising on social
media is very important in my opinion
because it's always changing and you
want to be able to put the best asset
the best message you want to put your
best foot forward when advertising on
social media and of course when you do
advertise again a whole nother set of
metrics you know how many people saw
you're at how many people clicked on
your ad how many people engage with the
landing page how many people converted
what was the cost per conversion so all
of those are metrics that we covered in
search engine marketing they apply with
paid social
so you have the opportunity on paid
social you have the opportunity on
social media
to really get your message out there
it's really understanding what kind of
data you're collecting what are the
results of the ad or the post and how do
you react to that and that's really the
common theme with digital marketing
skills if you're not a big fan of
numbers you're not a big fan of excel if
you will or spreadsheets if looking at a
mountain of data scares you
well then you might want to think
otherwise when going into digital
marketing but if you want to embrace the
data
then digital marketing is really a great
career because if you can get the data
and you know how to react to the data
then you can be successful in any
campaign you run
at number 10 we have PPC managers
pay-per-click managers optimize websites
ranking for organic research The
Leverage PPC to gain immediate relevant
visibility focusing on ad relevance and
quality score for success to become a
PPC manager you need a bachelor's degree
in marketing and a strong digital
marketing knowledge PPC managers earn
approximately twenty thousand dollars to
thirty thousand dollars annually on
number nine we have SEO specialist SEO
Specialists are responsible for
improving company websites organic
search engine ranking using various
techniques specializing in trending
Focus keywords and competitive
strategies to become SEO specialist a
bachelor's degree in marketing strong
SEO knowledge and skill in diverse
techniques and competitor analysis works
great SEO Specialists earn approximately
thirty thousand dollars to 40 thousand
dollars annually next on number eight we
have e-commerce specialist
the e-commerce specialist oversees
online sales and marketing of products
and services they analyze website and
online store data to uncover consumer
Trends create engaging website content
and set up payment systems for customers
e-commerce Specialists work for
retailers e-commerce service providers
online stores and may choose
self-employment the eligible candidates
should possess a bachelor's degree in
marketing or business management and
practical experience in e-commerce and
marketing
the annual salary of e-commerce
specialist ranges from thirty four
thousand dollars to sixty thousand
dollars annually moving ahead on number
seven we have content strategist content
strategist is responsible for devising
Content plans adapting to market trends
and aligning content with customer
preference the required qualification
includes a bachelor's degree in
marketing journalism or copywriting
along with expertise in SEO practices
and awareness of social media trends the
annual salary of content strategist
typically ranges from forty thousand
dollars to seventy thousand dollars on
number six we have social media marketer
social media marketers promote Brands
and services using various platforms
they create content manage campaigns and
aim to drive website traffic Proficiency
in social media marketing strategies and
audience Centric content creation is
necessary a marketing degree is
beneficial but not always required the
annual salary for social media marketers
ranges from thirty thousand dollars to
fifty thousand dollars per annum moving
to number five we have visual designers
visual designers are responsible for
creating the visual identity of an
organization's brand the other two brand
guidelines ensuring consistent usage
across all channels websites and videos
collaboration with marketing team is
crucial to align designs with the
company's brand strategy a bachelor's
degree in graphic design or in visual
communication is required to become a
visual designer a strong portfolio of
work and prominent presence on social
media platforms are essential the annual
salary of visual designers typically
ranges from forty thousand dollars to
sixty thousand dollars getting ahead to
number four brand marketing expert a
brand marketing expert maintains and
enhances the company's repetition
devises strategies for brand awareness
and identifies new opportunities for
products and services
typically they need to have a bachelor's
degree in marketing strong social media
skills and can work in various
Industries this highest paying digital
marketing job offers around fifty
thousand to sixty thousand dollars per
annum at number three we have marketing
analyst
the marketing analyst collects analytics
to Target the Right audience devices
sales strategies and identifies
appealing content for a specific
customer groups they collaborate closely
with marketing team typically a
bachelor's degree in marketing computer
science or management is required to
become a marketing analyst the annual
salary of marketing analyst ranges from
fifty thousand dollars to seventy
thousand dollars
towards the number two on the list email
marketing manager the email marketing
manager is competent in professional
accountable for devising executing and
supervising email marketing campaigns
with the expertise in web Technologies
copywriting and analytics they curate
captivating newsletters expands email
lists and drives sales through effective
customer communication a bachelor's
degree in marketing in any relevant
field will work great for this profile
the average salary of an email marketing
manager is sixty nine thousand dollars
per year
but not the least coming to number one
on the list
which is digital marketing manager
digital marketing manager develops
marketing strategies that align with
business goals and organization they
manage and execute campaigns across
various digital channels including email
social media search engines and display
advertising any bachelor's degree in
marketing or in any relevant field will
work great for this profile the average
salary of a digital marketing manager is
ninety one thousand dollars per year
Espionage a competitive intelligence
tool that monitors the entire conversion
funnel and provides data on competitors
they were having trouble with their
marketing blog as it was not directing
enough referral traffic to the main
website now to solve this the digital
marketing team used an Optimum exit
intent pop-up to their blog asking
visitors if they would like to download
their competitors most profitable PPC
and SEO keywords the pop-up only
appeared on exit intent after a visitor
spent at least 10 seconds on the Block
the pop-up was displayed 4144 times in
one month achieving a 5.47 conversion
rate proving the efficiency and accuracy
of the pop-up this just proves how much
importance a digital marketer holds for
any business and with the increasing
importance of digital marketing in
businesses the demand for digital
marketing professionals is also growing
the scope of digital marketing offers a
promising career with opportunities for
growth and specialization now let's dive
into some of the most popular job roles
in digital marketing and see what each
job role entails
first the digital marketing manager
digital marketing manager responsible
for overseeing all digital marketing
activities creating strategies and
managing a team with excellent
leadership skills the salary for a
digital marketing manager in US is
approximately 71 000 per year while in
India it's around 7 lakhs per year
depending on the size of the company and
level of experience next search engine
optimization specialist an SEO
specialist is responsible for optimizing
website content and structure to improve
its visibility and ranking on the search
engine this Rose requires a lot of
knowledge on SEO tools keyword research
and Technical SEO optimization the
salary of an SEO specialist in Us is
around fifty four thousand dollars while
in India it's around 3 lakh per year
depending on the experience level and
location as well next we have
pay-per-click specialist a PPC
specialist manages online advertising
campaigns on platforms like Google ads
and Facebook ads this rules requires PPC
campaigns keyword research and bid
management knowledge the salary for a
PPC specialist in Us is around fifty
thousand dollars per year while in India
it's around 6 lakh per year depending on
the experience level and location next
we have the social media marketing
specialist a social media marketing
specialist is responsible for creating
and executing social media marketing
campaigns on various social media
platforms like Facebook Twitter
Instagram LinkedIn and others this role
requires creativity excellent
communication skills knowledge of social
media analytics now the salary for a
social media marketing specialist in Us
is around forty eight thousand dollars
per year while in India it's around 4
lakh per year depending on experience
level and location as well and at last
the email marketing specialist an email
marketing specialist is responsible for
creating and managing email marketing
campaigns to reach out to potential and
existing customer us increase customer
loyalty and drive sales salary for an
email marketing specialist is sixty
thousand dollars per year in India it's
around 3.5 lakhs per year depending upon
the level of experience and location
let's talk about how skills impact
salvation digital marketing a career in
digital marketing requires a range of
skills and abilities the salary
difference between a person who is new
to the industry and a person with some
skills in digital marketing can vary
depending on various factors such as
location job role experience and
Industry entry level digital marketing
positions offered around thirty thousand
dollars to forty thousand dollars per
year for someone with no skills and
around forty thousand to fifty thousand
dollars for someone with having some
skills now as someone with some skills
gain experience and expertise but their
salaries can increase significantly but
now you may ask how you can obtain these
skills then let's talk about some
certifications certifications in digital
marketing can significantly impact
salaries with professionals earning up
to 20 more than their non-certified
counterparts certifications demonstrate
knowledge and expertise in a specific
area of digital marketing making
candidates more attractive to potential
employers entry level certifications
like Google analytics or Google ads can
help boost salaries for these starting
in this field while more advanced
certifications like HubSpot or hoot suit
can increase wages for those with more
experience employers value
certifications and see them as an
indicator of skills and knowledge and
better job opportunities now let's see
what digital marketing is in simple
words digital marketing is the promotion
of a product or a brand through one or
more forms of electronic media such as
Internet mobile phones Google search
engine marketing Etc it's a way to reach
client on time and retain them with
interactive marketing using digital
Technologies also it is the most
accessible easy to use and contemporary
method of promotion which is also known
as online marketing now we have reached
the most exciting and essential part of
the video every salary of a digital
marketing manager in the digital
marketing industry there is a huge
demand for digital marketing managers
and their salaries reflect that several
factors determine the income a person
can expect including experience the size
of your company your location and your
industry digital advertising has proven
to be more convenient and effective than
traditional advertising since most of
your audience is online as a result
digital marketing is growing and
becoming more popular a digital
marketing manager plays a significant
role in drawing Revenue into the
business and due to their highly result
driven nature their salaries are high
a digital marketing managers earns
approximately 6 lakh 72 000 per year in
India and in the US he or she can earn
roughly 75 000 per year
so when we want to go and promote our
product or service using a campaign we
have different options so there are
different types of digital marketing
channels that we can choose from and
let's just go through that list of
digital marketing channels and the first
one is what I consider the king of them
all and that's SEO so SEO stands for
search engine optimization there's
search engine marketing there's email
marketing affiliate marketing social
content mobile and then we can get into
subsets of each of these digital
marketing channels but really we'll
start with SEO because that's the king
and to me that's basically increasing
the quality and quantity of relevant
organic traffic on the search engines
including Google so depending on where
you're located in the U.S market Google
tends or has a large market share so you
want your pages on your website to be
found and clicked on or organically and
so that means that somebody types in a
key word you want that relevant page to
show up first on Google so somebody can
click on that link okay and we know that
millions of people specifically in the
US but worldwide you search on a daily
basis so if you're ranking for those
relevant keywords you can imagine how
much traffic you can get okay so that's
SEO okay and here's an example so you
type in online shopping well you can see
the first listing here is a paid search
ad I'm going to get to that in a minute
the second organically is Amazon okay so
online shopping you think maybe Walmart
you think maybe Alibaba or you're
thinking probably Amazon okay so no
surprise Amazon's ranking for the
keyword online shopping and so if
somebody clicked on their listing that's
traffic for Amazon let's move on to
search engine marketing you know known
as sem or pay per click or cost per
click or PPC or CPC or sponsored search
or Google ads I mean there's a lot of
different names synonymous with sem so
search engine marketing is really just
using paid ads on search engines just as
we saw the previous example if you want
to be found for keyword you don't have
to worry about organic if you're willing
to pay for it you just bid on that
keyword and voila you have the
opportunity to appear number one in the
search results at the top of the page
for that keyword now when somebody
clicks on it you have to pay Google if
it's Google you're advertising on but
that's the beauty of search engine
marketing you can bid on keywords and
appear at the top of the search results
for that keyword example here if we go
back to online shopping well myus.com is
bidding on that keyword online shopping
so they're actually appearing above of
Amazon's organic listing but that's what
they want to do they want to be found
for that keyword so if they're not
ranking for it organically well they're
bidding on it and if somebody happened
to clicked on that listing then myus.com
is going to pay Google something
depending on what the cost per click is
and so that could be anywhere from one
penny to a hundred dollars it depends
depends on the keyword depends on who
else is bidding on the keyword depends
on the location depends on the time of
day depends on quality score there's a
lot of factors involved and regarding
what you pay however the benefit of sem
is visibility and getting traffic to
your website for keywords you're not
found for so that's why sem's such a
popular choice for a lot of companies
okay let's talk about digital marketing
that's a traditional type of digital
marketing channel it's been around a
long time you know we all send email
miles on a daily basis and we probably
all receive emails on a daily basis just
an effective way to capture leads and
convert them to customers because with
email you can personalize your emails
and you can send your emails to a
segmented audience okay so if you have
emails from females who are 35 years of
age to 44 that live and say this
southern part of the United States you
can segment that send them an email and
cater that email directly to that
audience and of course you can put some
nice call to action in there you can
design it really snazzy and you could
track it just like you can any other
digital marketing channel so email is a
very effective way to really reach a
target audience because everybody for
the most part has a functioning email
account so basically here's an example
of an email that could go out you're
selling a product and and the products
promotion is about to end well you know
get that email out to your target
audience let them know hey you have
until tonight to purchase the product
and if you purchase it you're gonna get
30 off and you can put the coupon code
right in there with a nice call to
action and you can measure how many
people click on that email go to that
web page and purchase the product using
that coupon code so that's an example of
email marketing okay we have affiliate
marketing so affiliate marketing is an
effective way for digital marketers to
basically create a sales force of people
so basically what you're doing is you're
getting Merchants to promote your
products and services and you're using
usually a third-party broker like
Commission Junction or cj.com as an
example to introduce you the the person
selling the product the merchant with
the affiliate so that affiliate could
likely be a merchant him or himself and
they can and basically be a good partner
of yours by publishing your product or
service on their website so that they
can sell in order to get commissions so
it's all based on a commission so you
basically are going to use a third-party
affiliate like CJ get all these
Affiliates to work for you they're going
to promote your product or service if
they do sell your product or service
you're going to pay them a commission
that's more or less how it works with
affiliate marketing and you know with
affiliate marketing to me it's a good
way to you know really promote your
product or service and you can pick and
choose the Affiliates or the Publishers
of whom you want to work with so here's
an example of affiliate marketing at
work okay you basically see a banner
basically you can see earn up to 12
advertising fees with a trusted
e-commerce leader okay so if somebody
clicked on that and purchased for
example or joined you could pay out that
Commission okay let's turn our attention
to social media marketing so social
media marketing you know I wouldn't say
it's fairly new I mean if I think about
it we're in 2019 and I remember talking
about Facebook back in 2006 so you're
talking about 13 14 15 years of social
media it's definitely evolved over the
years and but the concept Remains the
Same it involves creating different
types of content depending on the
platform okay so you could be on
Pinterest or Instagram and be dealing
with photos or you could be on Twitter
tweeting out certain characters up to a
limit okay so it really depends on the
social media platform uh that really
drives the type of content you're going
to promote but we know social media can
be effective because people use social
media I mean Facebook is one of the more
popular platforms and if you want to get
your product or service out there you
could certainly pay to have an ad on
Facebook or you could just post your
account content organically okay that's
the beauty of social most of your Social
platforms like LinkedIn and Twitter and
Facebook and Pinterest and Instagram
they'll have a paid form of advertising
that you can use to promote your product
or service or you can go the organic
route and you know post content
organically in hopes of driving traffic
back to your website so with social you
do have two options here but social is
interesting because in a lot of
different social media platforms out
there it really depends on your product
or service okay so an example of social
media marketing especially on Facebook
with Facebook you got mobile and desktop
and you obviously have the opportunity
to post something organically and have
that liked or commented on or shared or
you can post an ad and get that liked
commented or shared or clicked and have
people go back to your website and
fulfill the goal of what you want them
to do so moving on to content marketing
it's a Content marketing is really an
effective way of really Distributing
valuable content online and when we talk
about content marketing you know we're
talking about different types of assets
so it could be simply text in the form
of a blog post or it could be a video or
it could be an infographic or it could
be an image okay there are lots of ways
to create content these days especially
in digital marketing and the great thing
about content marketing is you're
writing content for a targeted audience
so if you're trying to Target an
audience on say Instagram then you know
who your audience is and you know what
the type of content you're gonna post on
there so it could be in the form of a
video or infographic or just a graphic
and so that's the beauty of content
marketing really putting yourself out
there
um and depending on the platform putting
yourself out there with various types of
content so for example if we look at
YouTube you can see this video here
about digital marketing certified
associate well hey you don't need to
always write the content you can produce
the content in the form of a video and
post it on YouTube this is a form of
content marketing so that's content
marketing and then let's talk about
mobile marketing so content marketing
again different types but if we go now
to mobile marketing you can kind of
segue from content to mobile because the
only difference here is with mobile it's
strictly on mobile phone it's not
desktop so mobile marketing is really a
strategy on its own that helps you the
company promoting your product or
service to reach your target audience
through a mobile device and that
includes tablets and how you could do
that is via messaging you could do it
via email or you could be do it via an
app okay so you have different ways of
getting your content out there to people
okay so as an example you can use
basically SMS or instant messaging via
mobile devices to promote your product
or service here's another example of a
mobile marketing via app install and so
you can even compound that by running a
say Google ad as an example and running
your Google ad on say just mobile you
can do a bit adjustment just for mobile
and the goal could be app installs okay
so and you can even do a mobile or app
extension so there's lots of ways to
really promote your app or your product
or your service Via mobile marketing
Rachel is a baker who runs her own
Bakery to expand her business she
decided to create an online presence by
my first setting up a Blog she began
posting on her blog regularly however
even after regularly posting on the blog
there were barely any visitors showing
up deciding not to give up Rachel began
searching for a solution on the internet
that's when she came across SEO or
search engine optimization a term she's
never heard before
so let's take a journey together and
help her learn about SEO search engine
optimization is a method that could
improve the quality and quantity of the
audience coming to Rachel's website from
search engines it could increase brand
awareness attract local customers and
build credibility and trust and all of
this is possible without having to spend
a single penny to bring visitors to our
website Rachel would have to take
advantage of the two types of SEO
on-page and off-page SEO Rachel first
decides to tackle on-page SEO and get
that sorted on-page SEO involved Rachel
optimizing her website both in terms of
content and the technical aspects
including the HTML source code schema
meta Tags and More she started off by
using tools like Google AdWords allref
and semrush to identify popular Search
terms associated with the recipes she
planned to publish on her blog she began
to look for Search terms related to the
broader area of baking cooking and
related topics once she found these
Search terms she began to incorporate
them into her recipes
she started off by providing an
introduction to the recipe with this she
could provide an engaging beginning to
her story like how the dish reminded her
of her childhood and enabled her to
naturally include the Search terms into
the blog she also included these
keywords in the actual recipe as well
additionally she added pictures videos
time lapses and more to increase
credibility and engagement for her
content and subsequently persuading
search engines to show her content to
more people
after this she moved to the website
metacontent that search engines display
when her blog appears in search results
she optimized The Meta tax alt tags
header Tags and More this completed the
on-page aspect of SEO thanks to this she
saw a significant increase in the number
of visitors coming to her page having
done all she could on her web page she
now decides to explore what could be
done off page to improve her Page's
visibility on search engines off-page
SEO involved Rachel doing things outside
her site page to help increase its
search engine rankings making
optimizations outside the site would
improve the site's popularity relevance
trustworthiness and Authority this is
possible with the help of reputable
websites vouching for your content with
backlinks social media marketing guest
blogging linked unlinked brand mentions
influencer marketing and much more
Rachel also understood that for her
content to reach people she would have
to promote it on social media platforms
like Facebook Twitter and Instagram as
well as Niche platforms like quora
Reddit and medium
these could help her achieve greater
reach for her website by sending
stronger social signals to search
engines
leading to the page being shown as
highly relevant for related searches and
audiences and Eva Eve after
understanding and implementing all of
this Rachel had just scratched the
surface of what was possible with SEO
before we find out what she did next
let's have a look at a quiz which of the
following is the most effective way to
improve off-page SEO one creating plenty
of web pages of a Content 2. getting
backlinks from relevant and
authoritative sites 3. acquiring
backlinks through link Buy
4. none of the above let us know your
answer in the comments section below for
a chance to win an Amazon voucher now
let's go back to Rachel Rachel decided
to take up simplylearn's digital
marketing certification with classes
covering just about everything she
needed to know about SEO it was only a
matter of time before Rachel began to
implement her learnings on her website
and see a massive uptick in the number
of viewers coming to her website in time
she could even earn money off the site
by setting up an online shop and with
that we've covered an introduction to
the concepts of SEO and the
possibilities it can open for you either
as a marketer or a business owner so if
you are looking to become a digital
marketing specialist then look no
further than simply learn postgraduate
program in digital marketing with this
you gain all the necessity skills in
digital marketing like website creation
behavioral marketing keyword research
search engine optimization search engine
marketing campaign management social
media marketing and more with knowledge
of tools like SC ranking hoot suit chat
GPT Google ads Google Keyword Planner
Google Trends and there's much more on
the list don't miss out on this
incredible opportunity take action today
and enroll in a course to unlock the
digital marketing success accelerate
your career and gain the skills you need
to thrive in the industry ready to get
started then click on the link mentioned
in the description box and embark on
your journey to professional growth and
achievement now as you're familiar with
the working of search engines let's dive
deep into types of SEO
that is
on page SEO
of page SEO
and Technical SEO
we will start with on-page SEO
optimizing a web page to gain visibility
and rank high in search results and get
relevant traffic is known as on-page SEO
some on-page SEO techniques include
optimizing content
adding attractive titles and meta
descriptions
adding internal and external links on
the web page
adding SSL certifications for the
website
optimizing images for search results
Etc
next is off-page SEO actions taken
outside the web page or a website to
rank high in search results is known as
off-page SEO
some off-page SEO techniques include
building backlinks
blogging and submitting articles on
other websites
promoting content on social media Etc
and the last one is technical SEO
optimizing technical elements of a
website such that search engines can
easily crawl and index the web pages is
known as technical SEO
some technical optimizations include
reducing the page loading speed of a web
page to a minimum
submitting sitemaps to search engines
have organized website structure as it
informs search engines about the
essential pages of the website
adding redirections for the deleted URLs
or temporarily moving urls
identify duplicate content and replace
it with unique content greetings
everyone this is Rob Sanders from Simply
learn and today we're going to talk
about keyword research so what are we
going to talk about when we talk about
keyword research we're going to talk
about why we would do keyword research
for SEO we're going to talk about the
types of keywords that we need to
research we're going to talk about some
methodologies best practices on how to
do keyword research some alternate
suggestions we're going to talk about
keyword clustering and then we're going
to talk about some tools that you can
use to do your keyword research so let's
start with the why we would do keyword
research so Jesse is planning to publish
a Blog of pizza recipes so she was doing
pizza recipe step by step piece of
recipes with sausage homemade pizza
toppings pizza dough recipes thin crust
pizzas she's doing a lot of different
topics on pizza recipes well well what
Jesse needs to do is understand what's
going to drive traffic to these blog
posts if she's writing about you know
different topics around pizza recipes so
she's Unsure how these blogs are going
to drive traffic so she really needs to
understand that hey you need to choose
the right keywords to drive traffic so
the question is if you're writing a blog
post about recipes with sausages is
pizza recipes with sausages or recipes
for free the best keywords he is maybe
maybe not so you need to take uh care
and shoes in the queue words to align
with your content so that's really the
idea why we would do keyword research
because some of the issues with keywords
that are poorly chosen are they can have
slow search volume for example you may
choose a keyword that just a lot of
people aren't using to search for or
they can be highly competitive so if you
choose a keyword that's very Broad odd
or popular it can be very competitive
and take you a long time to be found for
that keyword or you could just make the
mistake of choosing a keyword that isn't
aligned with your content or you can
choose keywords but use them incorrectly
with your content so these are some of
the issues that you can encounter if you
just go about choosing keywords randomly
without due diligence without the proper
research so low search volume will lead
to less traffic High competition you may
not even rank at all okay if somebody
finds you for a keyword that's not
relevant to the topic they're just going
to leave the page and if you're not
using the right keywords and or if you
are using the right keywords and not
using them correctly in the content then
your pages may not even be found in
organic search so you really have to
take care and choosing the keywords to
me that's the most important step with
SEO is keyword research so we're going
to talk about the types of keyword
research then so we have short tail
keywords and we have long tail keywords
so if you write a blog post about pizza
recipes well what are you going to
choose a short tail or long tail so
let's talk about short tail keywords
first so short tail keywords are
keywords that are usually three keywords
and a phrase or shorter in some cases it
may be two key words in a phrase or
shorter so shortcut keywords usually
have high search volume which means
likely means higher competition but what
it also means it could be lower
conversions because short sale keywords
like for example pizza recipes could be
considered a short joke word but maybe
somebody's looking for homemade pizza
recipes or pizza recipes from their
favorite Italian restaurant so short
taking words may not be as relevant so
if we compare it with long tail keywords
chances are you're going to have lower
competition that's one of the benefits
but you're also going to have lower
search volume but with longer tail
keywords the key word is probably going
to be more relevant with the the content
you're writing about so therefore the
conversion rates likely going to be
higher so that's really the difference
between short-term keywords and long
tail keywords if you want to look at
simplistically short tail keywords are
Broad in nature it's going to capture a
lot of eyeballs but those eyeballs may
look at your content as not relevant
versus long tail keywords that may be
very relevant but not as many eyeballs
on them so short tail keywords the
characteristics they're not as specific
usually they're less than three words
they have high search volume and high
competition so if you just choose pizza
recipes could take you a while to rank
for that keyword but when you rank
you're going to get the traffic but
again it may not convert because the key
word is Broad in nature so pizza recipes
is a short tail keyword that may not be
exactly what you're writing about in
your blog post so it may draw a lot of
traffic but the traffic may not do
anything so the longer tail keywords are
very specific they consist of more than
three words in the search query they
have relatively low search volume
competition so the chance of you ranking
higher faster for that long take word is
probably going to be greater because not
many other websites are trying to rank
for that same keyword and so the benefit
of that is if you have let's just say
homemade pizza recipes with mushrooms
that's a long tail key word but if
somebody's looking for that type of
pizza recipe then you know you're going
to track the right traffic and chances
are that traffic is going to engage or
convert based on the type of conversion
you have in place so example would be
homemade pizza dough recipes that'd be
another example more than three key
words in the phrase very specific we're
talking about homemade pizza dough
recipe so we're not talking about just
pizza recipes so it's a little bit more
specific in nature longer tail so these
keywords are used for targeted Pages
including blog posts if you're writing a
blog post specifically about pizza
recipes with homemade dough then this is
the key word you likely would want to
use versus just pizza recipes so let's
look at an example between a short tail
keyword and a long tail keyword and to
accentuate the differences we're going
to use Google's Keyword Planner tool so
Google's keyboard Planner tool is
located in Google ads the Google ads
platform and when you're in the Google
ads platform you can simply click on
tools and then Keyword Planner and so
what Keyword Planner allows us to do is
get a sense of the type of volume that a
particular keyword has so what Google's
Keyword Planner does is they show you
the average monthly searches this is the
average monthly search volume of a
keyword over the past 12 months and so
in this example we're going to choose
pizza recipes and homemade pizza dough
recipes so one short tail and one long
tail so we enter those keywords in we're
gonna click get results and and what
Google's going to do is it's going to
show us the volume of those keywords so
for pizza recipe we could see the
average monthly search volume is 33 100
for pizza recipe so note that pizza
recipe and pizza recipes are closely
related keywords and so what Google does
is they consider that a close variance
so meaning if somebody ties a piece of
recipe then they're also in Google's
eyes looking for pizza recipes so it's a
close variance and so for the keyword
pizza recipe which is short tail we
could see on average over the past 12
months this keyword received 33 100
queries and so if we hover over the
graph we could see basically the volume
the average volume per month so here I
could see for this particular keyword
here the volume per month is 33 to 1000
and then I can see the actual volume
over the past 12 months and then for the
long tail keyword I can see homemade
pizza dough recipe again close variants
homemade pizza dough recipes I can see
over the past 12 months with the search
volume is for this on average it's 2400
but I could see here in December the
volume went up to 3 600 but for example
in May it was 1900. so it's gonna
fluctuate a bit over the past 12 months
but on average it's about
2400. so shorter tail a lot of more
volume longer tail not as much volume
but nonetheless there is volume here and
so these are the difference between a
short tail and a longer tail and so well
Google's Keyword Planner also does is
allow us to get a sense of what the
competition is and so here I can see the
competition is low for both of these
keywords fair enough so we now know that
if we want to optimize or choose the
keyword homemade pizza dough recipe for
our blog post we know for ranked on page
one of Google even in the top spot we
can expect about 2400 search queries for
that keyword now whether you get all
2400 clicks for that keyword remains to
be seen chances are you're not going to
get all 2400 you're going to get a
Lion's Share of those clicks but you're
going to at least get some volume on it
so even the longer tick keywords have a
lot of Promise because there is some
search volume here for this keyword how
to do a proper keyword research so we
looked at Google's Keyword Planner tool
and Google ads and we typed in two
keywords and we were able to get a sense
of what the average volume is so we
definitely want to choose keywords based
on the following factors we want to
choose it based on search volume search
volume is a good indicator of the
potential traffic we can obtain so again
for the keyword homemade pizza dough
recipe we know that it averages 2400 a
month in search volume again we may not
get all 2400 but we're going to get a
line share of that we also need to look
at competition and so Google's Keyword
Planner gives us a high medium or low in
terms of the competition but if you're
somebody who wants to get a better sense
of what the competition is and you
should because competition is a key
component in choosing keywords and so
what I want to do is get a sense of how
many people are actually optimizing for
that keyword so Google's Keyword Planner
tool is going to give me a low medium
high really what I want to do is get a
better sense of that numerically so what
I can do is go into Google search and I
could type in pizza recipes and I could
see there's about 1 billion results
that's a lot of results however that
means that every potential web page out
there on the internet that mentions
pizza recipes is going to be included in
this number here and so I want to get a
better sense of who's optimizing for for
pizza recipes so I'm going to put in the
all in title syntax and so what that is
going to ask Google to do is tell me all
the websites that have pizza recipes the
keyword pizza recipes in the title tag
so if I do all entitled colon space then
pizza recipes my result drops down to
336 000. so what that tells me is that
there are 336
000 results with the keyword pizza
recipes in the title tag now if I want
to focus in on my other keyword if I
choose my other keyword was a longer
tail keyword homemade pizza dough recipe
so if I type that keyword in the
homemade pizza dough recipe or recipes
remember close variance and I just click
enter or type the keyword in hit my
Enter key I'm going to get 35 Million
results but again is that really an
indicator of the type of competition I
have no because every listing that
mentions homemade pizza dough recipes is
going to be included in the search
results so I'm going to type in my all
in title colon space and then I'm going
to get a better sense of how many
websites have the keyword homemade pizza
dough recipes in the title tag and I get
2 160 different results so here I can
see the first result in the title tag
homemade pizza dough recipe second one
homemade pizza dough recipe so these are
sites or web pages that have that
keyword in the title tag so now I have a
numerical number to work with and so the
thing you have to understand about SEO
specifically about keyword research is
you need to do research on a few
different keywords not just one or two
so what we want to do is have a
spreadsheet the spreadsheet is going to
contain keywords that we can potentially
want to optimize for choose as keywords
to optimize for SEO and so my
recommendation is you come up with a
theme first so the theme for us in this
exercise is pizza recipes and so that's
our theme so we chose the keyword pizza
recipes so the close variance here is
pizza recipe what was the volume well we
know the volume was 33 100 for pizza
recipe so what are we going to do we're
going to put that number in in our
volume column what was the competition
well if we go back and type in pizza
recipes it was 683 000 so I'm going to
type in 683
000. what was our next keyword well it
was pizza or homemade pizza dough
recipes so if I go back for this
particular keyword is 2400 so I'm going
to put 2400 in under my volume column
and then what was my competition well my
competition was I typed that keyword
back in
2160. so I'm gonna put two thousand one
hundred and sixty so now I have an idea
of what kind of volume and what kind of
competition I have now you want to do
this for a number of different keywords
and when you do it for a number of
keywords what you do want to do is
obviously choose a relevant keyword that
has high volume and low competition so
another way of saying it is the volume
or ratio of volume to competition and so
basically what we could do is take
volume divided by competition if I make
that a percentage I can see it's 0.35
percent is the ratio between volume of
competition if I do the same for my
longer tail keyword 2400 divided by 2160
I can see that 111 so this just kind of
proves the point that yeah I'm still
going to get some volume but I have a
better chance of ranking for this longer
tier keyword homemade pizza dough
recipes so you want to be able to do
that for number keywords and examine the
volume the competition and the ratio
between volume and competition for your
themed keywords in this case pizza
recipes so Rel relevancy you want to
choose keywords that are very relevant
to the content that you're writing and
then again commercial intent what
keywords are going to drive more
conversions and revenue for the business
so when we talk about commercial intent
we're talking about you know are you
choosing keywords that are going to get
somebody to do what you want them to do
so we could say You Know download pizza
dough recipes so somebody's typing in
the keyword download pizza dough recipes
then chances are they're going to find
you come to your site and take action by
downloading that pizza dough recipe so
you want to be able to also think about
the intent of the keyword is it going to
help you drive conversions and revenue
if you're an e-commerce site so search
volume is the average monthly search
volume made for a particular keyword and
phrase so we can get that number using
Google's Keyword Planner tool in the
Google ads platform we want to Target
keywords with high search volume that
will help bring traffic to the website
we want volume but we want to take into
account seasonality as well so that's
where the Google's Keyword Planner tool
comes in place because if we go back
again we can just hover over we can get
a sense of any particular Trend going on
or season out so for example if I saw a
large growth in the winter months and
not much volume growth in the summer
months then that might indicate to me
that this keyword is more popular during
the winter time so pay attention to the
grass that you know the Keyword Planner
tool gives you use them to your
advantage to take into account
seasonality so a good example would be
funny Halloween costumes well we know
that for Halloween you're going to have
a spike probably towards the end of
September all the way through October
and then it's going to drop after
October 31st which is Halloween so
that's an example but in the case of
pizza recipes you know you may find that
more people are choosing to search for
pizza recipes during maybe the summer
months versus the winter months so pay
attention to seasonality it will affect
search volume so competition based on
our example it's one of the most
important key metrics you don't want to
choose a keyword that's highly
competitive because if it's competitive
then it's going to be harder to rank
number one or even on page one of Google
depending on competitive it is so high
search volume low competition in other
words the ratio between the two is the
ideal combination so going back to the
spreadsheet recommend you have that
spreadsheet handy put your theme in
place okay theme pizza recipes we use
Google's Keyword Planner tool to find
the volume we use the all entitled
syntax to find the competition so we
entered both of those numbers in and we
get our ratio and so when you have these
numbers for a number of different
keywords you want to be able to choose
that ratio of high volume low
competition but all always relevancy
always trumps ratio so always go with a
key word that is going to be relevant to
your content don't choose a keyword
that's not relevant if you choose a
keyword that's not relevant it's not
going to bode well for user engagement
so the difficulty of a keyword ranges
from 0 to 100 and Google's keyword tool
so it's going to be easy it's going to
be medium it's going to be hard but my
recommendation is also to get the
numerical factor and that's the all in
title syntax and again relevancy is what
drives the traffic to your website and
keep the traffic there on your website
and also not only will keep the traffic
on your website but hopefully get that
traffic to engage and convert so that's
the key about relevancy you always want
to choose keywords that are relevant to
your content even if it's sacrificing
volume relevancy again trumps volume and
competition so always choose relevant
keywords first first so when you do that
you're always almost guaranteeing that
at some point somebody's going to find
your content because somebody out there
might be looking for it and if they do
you're going to get found and then the
engagement is going to be better so
understand your business find keywords
that are relevant to your business and
then focus on those keywords that'll
help you with getting the right traffic
to your site always keep in mind the
commercial intent so these keywords are
more specific and result in conversion
rate for example buying is a good
commercial intent keyword so if you
really want somebody to come to your
website and buy then focus on those
types of keywords in the case of the
pizza recipes maybe it's download could
be our commercial intent keyword again
there may be low search volume but those
are the type of keywords you want to
focus on because that's the type of
traffic you want to drive to your site
so some other examples a commercial
intent keywords or discount deal your
coupon shipping you know don't be afraid
to use some of of these keywords as part
of your longer tail keyword phrase again
the volume may not be high but the
traffic quality is probably going to be
better so keyword research is the
foundation for SEO so if you have chosen
your keywords properly then if you do
get ranked for those keywords then it's
going to lead to better engagement with
some conversions and so when we talk
about keywords we also want to talk
about our primary and secondary keyword
so every page should have at least a
primary keyword and then a second carry
keyword to work with so primary keywords
are really defining the nature of your
content the secondary keywords are
relevant to the primary keyword so why
do we choose a primary and secondary
keyword because you may choose a keyword
as a primary keyword that is relevant to
the content but may not necessarily rank
very high or have a lot of volume that
secondary keyword is also relevant to
the primary keyword but also relevant
into content and you may rank for that
secondary keyword so you always want to
go with two keywords versus just one
keyword you want to give your yourself a
chance to rank for at least two
different types of keywords of relevant
nature so for web page there can be
several secondary keywords but only one
primary keyword so your primary keyword
is always going to be relevant to your
content secondary keywords can be
relevant to the keyword but and you may
have multiple secondary keywords but
it's also going to be related to the
content and it gives you a better
opportunity to be found between both the
primary and secondary and search Okay so
let's take a look at another example of
how to use primary keywords and
secondary keywords when choosing
keywords so if our primary keyword is
healthy diet plan remember healthy diet
plan is directly related to the content
so that's what we're talking about but
these secondary keywords are also
related to content and play off the
primary keyword and so what we want want
to do is go to cool Google's Keyword
Planner tool and get an idea of the
volume for healthy diet plan and then
also the volume and competition for some
of these secondary keywords like healthy
diet for weight loss healthy diet food
low carb diet healthy meal plans and
diet plan weight loss so if I go in to
Google's Keyword Planner and type those
keywords in I'm going to choose get
results and now here I could see healthy
diet plan keyword I'm focusing on is my
primary keyword has an average monthly
search volume of 9900 and then some of
my secondary keywords healthy diet foods
diet plan weight loss low carb diet you
know Google will give me a number of
different keywords to work with so I'm
going to look at the search volume of
those as well and so ideally what I want
to do is be able to then look at the
volume and then look at the competition
so healthy diet plan to go into my
keyword analysis here that's my theme so
that's my keyword what's my volume for
healthy diet plan nine thousand nine
hundred what's my competition so my
competition is seventy four thousand
seven hundred and that's going to give
me a ratio of volume the competition of
13 so that's what my content's about
that's a considered a short tail keyword
because it has a lot of competition and
so my ratio is 13 and what I want to do
is I want to be able to put these other
secondary keywords in here as well maybe
even go to a little longer tail because
I want to be able to find two key
release two keywords I want to be able
to find my primary keyword that's
relevant to my content and then I want
to be able to find my secondary keyword
which is again related to the primary
keyword which is also related to the
content and so I want to be able to
choose two keywords basically and I want
to choose two keywords that are relevant
that have good ratio between volume and
competition so that's the whole idea
again I'm how to do keyword research you
want to be able to find your keywords
use the tools available to you and get a
sense of what the volume is what the
competition is look at the ratio between
the volume and competition and then
based on the content choose that primary
keyword and then again based on the
keyword you chose choose some secondary
keywords as well because you want to be
found for not just one keyword but
multiple keywords okay let's look at
some alternative suggestions to keyword
research so for doing keyword research
we want to take into account LSI
keywords we could take into account
other platforms that host a lot of
content like quora or Reddit we can use
Google suggestions in the keyword search
bar we can use popular platforms like
Wikipedia and we can use social media
bookmarking like Reddit so there are
lots of suggestions that we can obtain
from various sources so let's start with
LSI keyword words and LSI stands for
latent semantic insect indexing and so
basically what it is it's just keywords
that are linked to your primary keyword
and so when you're choosing keywords you
always want to choose that primary
keyword and then secondary keywords that
are similar to the primary keyword and
usually those are LSI or latent semantic
indexing type keywords so they're used
to drive relevant traffic to your page
so if you focus in on one keyword we
want to have other keywords that are
similar to increase our visibility on
the search engine result pages so we
could find latent semantic indexing
right in search so if we use the term
healthy diet if we go to Google search
for example if I type in healthy diet in
Google search all I need to do is scroll
to the bottom of the page and I can see
searches related to healthy diet so
healthy diet menu healthy diet essay
what does a healthy diet look like
notice at the top Google's also given me
some other suggestions here so they're
saying low-fat diet veganism gluten-free
diet so there's lots of different
suggestions right in Google search bar
so all of these are LSI related keywords
so if you're optimizing a page for a
healthy diet then you could choose
low-fat diet as a secondary keyword you
can use gluten-free diet as a secondary
keyword it really depends on what the
content is but you always want to
support your content with as much LSI
keywords as possible so you can be found
for as many different keywords as
possible in Google search so it's
important because if you have a Blog
that you know talks about python so how
do the search engines know if the
website python is about the programming
language or the snake so Google for
example uses LSI keywords to understand
what the page is specifically focusing
on so if you're just focusing on Python
and your content you want to support
that with LSI keywords and so that will
allow your web page to better
communicate with Google also to have the
visibility to show up on search so they
can certainly improve your search
positioning and featured Snippets as
well so if you have a keyword that
answers a question you can certainly
found for feature snippet for example
maybe you know healthy diet recipes if I
type that in you can see here there's a
featured snippet so if I'm talking about
recipes that's a key word I may want to
use and if I use that then Google has an
opportunity to see what my content's
about and place my information at the
top in this featured snippet you can
also again see what some of the
questions are being asked what males are
good for weight loss what is a good
healthy diet plan all of these can be
keyword phrases that you can use so the
answers are right here in Google so core
is a great platform because core is a
platform that people go and ask
questions in a community response with
answer errors or responses to that
particular question or topic and so the
great thing about core is it's a good
eye is a good place for you to go to get
some ideas about a specific topic so if
we're talking about healthy dieting so
we can find keywords with high search
volume writing quora so the whole idea
is you can look at you know the top five
questions for specific topic like
healthy dieting and find relevant
keywords to healthy dieting so if you
just type in that particular keyword in
quora you're gonna probably get some
responses to questions or responses to
somebody else's question and so if we
take a look at core for example so if I
just type in healthy dieting what I'm
going to do is I'm gonna get some
responses to the the topic healthy
dieting so what's the best diet for
Healthy Living what are the top five
tips for a healthy diet habit so all of
these could be keyword phrases that you
could take away with for your own
content and so the benefit here is
you're getting kind of an idea of what's
trending what people are talking about
and if you use tips for a healthy diet
habit for example and you optimize for
that well again that could turn around
and bode well for you because you could
be featured in Google as a featured
snippet at the top here you can also
turn around and use LSI related keywords
for healthy diet habits and you can
simply just look for those LSI keywords
right in Google remember at the bottom
or at the Top If I scroll down I could
see some related LSI keywords at the
bottom so writing Google as well you
could see in the Google search bar that
Google provides some LSI related
keywords to your query so if I go back
here and type in healthy diet recipes I
can see here Google's suggesting some
other related keywords healthy diet menu
healthy diet for man healthy diet foods
healthy diet for women so these are all
LSI related keywords that you can use to
support your primary keyword and the
content you're writing about so we've
talked about LSI keywords where to find
them so they're found right here they
can be found at the top of Google and
they can be found at the bottom you can
also then go to core as well and get
some ideas for the types of questions
they're being asked so if you ask a
question and use that as your keyword
phrase then again you have an
opportunity of showing up for a featured
snippet in Google just by doing some
additional research within Google itself
or on quora so according to Google the
autocomplete predictions are
automatically generated by Google's
algorithm without any human intervention
it's based on a number of factors but
the primary factor is how often past
users have searched for terms so Google
collects all the keyword queries that
somebody types in and they're suggesting
some of the most popular terms that
people have typed in so if I go back to
Google again if I start to type in
recipes I could see some of the other
queries that somebody else has typed in
or some of the most pop popular queries
related to that topic so if you enter
the keyword healthy diet Google's going
to suggest multiple keyword suggestions
that users have asked in the past and
you could certainly get the search
volume of those keywords just by looking
in Google itself I could see for healthy
diet recipes billions of pages related
to healthy diet recipes I can also get
the search volume by going into Google's
Keyword Planner so if I type in healthy
diet I'm going to be able to see what my
search volume is for that keyword and in
addition I can see the seasonality of
that particular keyword and in addition
to that Google is going to provide some
other related keywords to my search
query so if I'm looking for healthy diet
Google's going to suggest hey maybe you
should choose healthy food or healthy
eating or how to lose weight so those
are LSI related keywords that Google
provides in the keyword plan which is
built into the Google ads platform
another option for you is Wikipedia so
Wikipedia is a vast platform of content
so we could turn Wikipedia into our own
asset and use it to our own Advantage by
finding relevant keywords in an easy
fashion so with Wikipedia we can
identify a list of keywords in The Meta
description itself we could choose
keywords from the paragraph of Wikipedia
that has many relevant keywords or we
could take a look at keywords from the
Wikipedia content section so we can also
see additional Pages like the see also
section that gives relevant keywords
that you're looking for we can also look
at the references section as they
contain relevant keywords so go to
Wikipedia as an example and I type in
healthy diet into Wikipedia here I can
get just in the first paragraph alone I
can see some additional keywords that I
might choose to use like micronutrients
I never knew that micronutrients was
related to healthy diet but Wikipedia is
providing some information about what
micronutrients is and maybe I can use
that as a keyword an LSI related keyword
to my content so if I scroll down I get
to see also section so it might give me
some information food information
consumers for example dietary guidelines
I can look at categories like dietetics
and diets I can also look at the
references section so I can also see
what information was provided like
health effects of overweight and obesity
I can look at diet and physical activity
so all of these are related to my main
keyword healthy diet so the answers are
right in here on the platform they're
just all over the page so Wikipedia has
an abundance of information you just
need to know where to look so again with
Wikipedia you can look no further than
the first paragraph you look no further
than the see also section the references
section category section there's lots of
information right on the page itself to
help you get ideas for keywords so if
you Google your keyword with Wikipedia
term in the search query and get
relevant keywords from the title tags in
the serp so you can also do that as well
so if I type in healthy diet Wikipedia
and search I can also get some
information here as well so people also
search for healthy food advantages or
healthy food habits essay or information
about healthy food all of these are
related to my keyword healthy diet so
again another bit of information for you
to choose or look to choose some
additional keywords for so Reddit it's a
popular Community where people post
content and discuss a variety of topics
so that's what Reddit is so with the
help of subreddits an individual can
find relevant keywords with with high
search volume so in Reddit there's an
easy way to find out keywords they have
a keyword tool called keyword it so the
keyword it gives the average monthly
searches for particular a keyword so if
we type a Word in key Reddit and choose
keywords from the auto generator list
this tool will extract the keywords and
give us those relevant terms with search
volumes so if we go to the keyword it
and Show an example of that for example
healthy food if I get keywords I can see
what keywords are relevant in the search
volume of that keyword so if I just type
in healthy food keyword tool is going to
tell me some relevant keywords and what
the volume is so if you don't have the
Keyword Planner tool in Google ads
available to you this is a good
alternative solution to finding keywords
so it's free you just need to go to
keyword.com type in your keyword click
get keywords and what it's going to do
is give you some relevant keywords
related to your primary keyword with the
search volume let's talk about keyword
clustering now so the whole idea about
keyword clustering is to really take
advantage of the key words that we're
optimizing for to gain higher ranking so
if we can cluster keywords together in a
theme and that theme of keywords is
relevant to a specific page of a website
then we have a better opportunity to
rank so in other words why do we have to
Target just one keyword when we can
Target many so keep in mind you know LSI
keywords we want to group a bunch of
keywords together that are similar for
Content so for example after some
keyword research you can thematically
group keywords into a core topic so for
example we can cluster these group of
keywords together like for example what
is SEO how does SEO work intro to SEO
what are the basics of SEO all of those
are related to the chord theme what is
SEO another cluster of keywords for
example could be SEO techniques SEO best
practices tips and tricks website
optimization on-page SEO techniques Etc
so those are clusters of keywords okay
that we can group together other in
themes and if we group keywords together
in themes we can apply that to a
particular content on our website so the
whole idea behind clustering keywords
it's going to provide more diversity
more of an opportunity for us to be
found so that's the whole idea behind
clustering so some additional steps
remember stay up to date on industry
news to brainstorm your ideas first and
identify a list of keywords like a theme
of keywords that you can cluster
together and then you could determine
the keywords that your competitors are
already ranking for so for example if we
want to rank for the keyword SEO best
practices for example we can use a tool
called keyword Moz if I go to keyword
the keyword Explorer tool and Moz and
just type in SEO best practices what
it's going to do is it's going to give
me some volume related to that
particular keyword but more importantly
what it's also going to do is it going
to show me what pages are already ranked
for that particular keyword so therefore
I can get a sense of who is already
ranking for that keyword so here I can
see Moz mozmedium.com alexa.com so I can
get a sense of what web pages are ranked
for a particular keyword or group of
keywords I want to rank for myself
greetings everyone this is Rob Sanders
and thank you for joining me today we're
going to talk about SEO tools let's get
started so if you're doing SEO and
you're doing on page and off page SEO
for an organization or website you're
going to need some tools to help you so
you can't go at it alone you can't do
anything manually you have to lean on
tools to help you work more efficiently
help you gain an advantage and so if
you're doing SEO you're going to need
tools for keyword research you're going
to need tools to help you with the
technical aspects related to SEO you're
going to have to to use some tools for
off-page SEO including backlink
monitoring and Analysis and then there's
tools for helping you track where your
keywords and Pages rank so there's tools
for every element of SEO and today we're
going to take a look at some of the best
tools out there on the market to help
you do your job better so let's start
with the keyword research so with
keyword research tools you can do your
job a lot more efficiently finding the
right relevant keywords I mean that's
really key to SEO is finding keywords
that are relevant to your business
product or service that you want to rank
for so you want to be able to choose
keywords with high search volume and low
competition so where do you get those
numbers you get those from certain tools
you also want to get forecasts for
certain targeted keywords you want to be
able to generate a list of latent
semantic indexing type keywords keywords
close to the keyword you're trying to
Target you want to be able to select
primary and secondary keywords wisely so
having a list of keywords or certain
data points will help you do that and
you want to be able to identify the
keywords that your competitors are also
ranking for so good keyword research
tool will help you do all of those
things so what are some of the tools out
there well look no further than some of
the free ones that Google offers like
Google Trends so Google Trends is a good
tool that you can lean on if so if we
look at Google Trends all you need to do
is trends.google.com you can type in a
keyword I can look at the volume or
interest of that keyword over time here
I'm looking at football versus American
football and I could see how it's
trending then I could see you know how
it Trends in specific regions of say the
United States as my market I can also
look at other related queries similar to
football or American football and so
Google Trends is a good tool helps you
look at the volume helps you look at
what specific regions help you look at
other keywords you know if you want you
can simply just do a keyword search or
you can actually just see what's
trending just by looking at the latest
stories and insights so we could see
International women's day you know
started to pick up steam it's picking up
more steam Etc so it's certain keywords
that tend to Trend well and you can pick
up on what those keywords are using
Google Trends now you could also use
another Google tool called Google
Keyword Planner the only difference is
this one's paid you need a Google ads
account so if we go into Google ads hey
you'll need to go to tools and you need
a Keyword Planner but when you're in
Keyword Planner you can find new
keywords so if I type in for example you
know online marketing and click get
started what the keyword tool is going
to do is give me the data that I need to
do appropriate keyword research it's
going to give me my keyword and similar
keywords it's going to give me the
average month and volume and the great
thing here is I can actually see the
trend for that keyword over time just by
clicking on this little bar graph so for
digital marketing I could see what the
trend is over time I could see what the
competition is I could see you know if
I'm going to bid on this keyword I can
see what the bidding range is so more
important I could see the volume and I
can see the competition here's my volume
for this keyword over the last 12 months
on average and here's my competition so
Google's Keyword Planner gives you the
necessary information you need to choose
relevant keywords wisely now there are
other tools out there that are paid that
help you look for Relevant keywords like
semrush or keyword finder that's a
freemium tool so there are plenty of
tools available to you you know another
tool I use that's not listed here is Moz
so if you just type a keyword let's just
type in the same keyword like online
marketing for example okay so what Moz
is going to do is going to give me some
volume it's going to give me some other
keyword suggestions okay it's going to
tell me how difficult that keyword is
and it's going to tell me who else is
ranking for that keyword so it gives me
again all the relative information I
need including competitive information
so you can use these two these keyword
tools moz's freemium summer paint some
are free there's plenty of tools out
there but these are the ones I would
recommend for keyword research now let's
turn our attention to technical SEO so
for technical SEO you're going to need
to use some tools there's no getting
around that because you want to be able
to monitor how your website is
performing I mean is it loading slow for
example does it have a lot of uh issues
with the website in terms of server-side
rendering for example or server response
time what about four or fours and
redirects so you want to be able to
gather a lot of the technical
information that could Aid or prohibit
your site from ranking so you want to be
able to also you know look at what the
Bots are saying and how they're viewing
your website so if Google goes to crawl
your site are they experiencing you know
a slow server response time were they
experiencing page is not found you also
want to see if you have a site map you
know what's the site map are these Bots
crawling your site or getting the pages
from assignment again you want to be
able to lean on some of these tools to
help you fix errors that you may
encounter like meta tags or four fours
or canonicals so you need a good tool to
help you manage all that and so I'm
going to go back to Moz starting out so
if we go back to Moz Moz is a good tool
it's an all-in-one it's a great SEO
platform so if I go to Moz and I log
into an account I can just go to site
crawl and so what Moz is going to do
it's gonna give me a lot of information
about how Moz is bot is seeing my site
okay so if I go to the site crawl I can
look at all the particular critical uh
issues that I've experienced so I could
see four or four errors okay redirects
related to that I could see Meta
descriptions missing meta descriptions
duplicate content so there's a lot of
different issues that Moz is detecting
for this particular site and the great
thing about Moz and this is why I use
Moz as my SEO platform I don't work for
mods I've just used them a long time is
if you do have issues then they give you
ways to fix it the how to fix it section
so if I see missing description here if
I just click on review and get a more
in-depth analysis as to what the issues
are here but I can also click on the why
and how to fix okay and they're going to
give you some information about how this
is impacting SEO and what you could do
to fix the issue they lay out the issues
pretty prominently here you can see for
all the metadata issues I have I have
you know 142 total metadata issues I
have 10 title tag two Longs I have 122
missing meta descriptions so they lay it
out nicely here up the top so you can
kind of get a sense of what to work on
and again they prioritize it based on
the severity of the issue and then they
break it down into several categories
for example I just looked at metadata
issues you can see if I click on content
issues I have some duplicate content
that Moz is recognizing or missing or
valid H tags so Moz does a really really
great job playing all all the issues out
for you to recognize okay there's
another tool that I like to use called
screaming frog it's a pay tool so if we
go look here great thing I like about a
screaming frog it will crawl your site
and it will give you some a list of
issues just like Mazdas of you know what
it sees in your site is experiencing
four fours broken links are there any
redirects it's picking up duplicate
content site Maps you know they're
JavaScript issues how is it see the site
architecture so it really does take a
deep look at everything that could
impact your website from ranking okay
there are other tools out there like you
know deep crawl or woo rank they're both
paid and so pay tools are really great
as well it's just depends on you know
your pricing structure what your budget
is but really when it comes to all these
tools they all more or less overlap and
do the same thing you just need to rely
on one of them to make sure that you're
able to see what the issues are now
there's nothing wrong with using two of
them just as a second reference point to
see if both are picking up the same
issue and of course I like to use search
console I always like to lean on Google
search console because that is the
source so search console will also
you'll give you some feedback on how
Google's bot is crawling your site so
that's under the crawl error section
here so you can also you know use search
console to upload a site map so that's a
key to SEO you want Google to be able to
find your web pages quickly so you can
simply just signify to Google where your
site map is located so the search
console does a lot more gives you some
HTML improvements gives you some
backlinking uh and then the process of
update creating the search console user
interface so there's a new user
interface that you can use with Google
search console the great thing is it's
free and it has everything you need to
know about your website and how it's
affected by SEO organic search the only
thing you have to do with search console
is verify the site but once you verify
it it has all the relevant information
you need so let's talk about backlink
monitoring and Analysis okay so this is
related to off-page SEO so you're going
to need a good tool to help you monitor
your website backlinks and backlinks are
simply just links from external sites
pointing to your site and you need to
keep an eye on what sites are linking to
yours are they spammy related sites are
they good relevant sites or anything in
between so you need to really be able to
analyze what the good links are what the
bad links are pointing to your website
you want to identify and disavow Port
backlinks okay so you want to be able to
recognize what's sites or linking to
yours that's actually hurting you from
an SEO standpoint and you want to be
able to do something about that okay you
want to measure citation flow and Trust
flow you want to check the ratio of Link
distribution in terms of is it internal
or external or you know what kind of
sites are linking to my site are they
you know social related are they pure
content related and then you want to be
able to track the number of do follow
and no followings you know how many
links pointing to our site are actually
telling Google and other Bots not to
follow the link or how many are actually
allowing the Bots to follow that link if
a bot follows a link it's going to pass
what we call link juice so you're going
to get credit for the backlink if it's a
no follow you're not going to get credit
for the backlink and we want to be able
to measure that and so we want to have
tools that will help us do that so what
are some of those tools well hrefs is a
good tool it's a pain tool Majestic is a
freemium tool Moz again Moz is the tool
I use sem rush and then again and I
gotta mention Google search console so
let's take a look at some of these tools
in terms of backlink monitoring and
Analysis so let's start with Google
search console again it's free you just
have to verify your site and so if I go
to Google Search console I can look at
links and I can see what external links
I have pointing to my site okay so I
could see I have 17 000 in this example
pointing to the home page of this
particular site okay so if I click on
that I can see all the the top sites
pointing to my home page now from an
off-page SEO perspective do you want
every backlink or external link pointing
to your home page no so you want links
pointing to internal pages so you want
to be able to measure that so I could
see with the top linking sites are and I
could also see what the anchor text is
so do I want my anchor text always to be
my brand name no I want it to be you
know keyword we're trying to Target
search console also gives you some
internal links okay what are the top
link Pages for or internal links so from
an SEO perspective you always want to
have a nice balance of internal linking
so this report helps you understand what
pages are getting links and are the
links evenly spread so this is Google
search console this is the links report
this is totally free this is provided by
Google all you have to do is verify your
site now if we go over to Moz we type in
a domain any domain so I just typed in
simple and learn okay Moz has some
metrics that are important to off-page
SEO including domain Authority so the
higher your domain Authority the better
off you are and so what helps a domain
Authority grow is how many quality links
are pointing to that domain and so here
we could see over
7500 linking domains to Simply learn so
what's important is we just don't want
any site we want quality relevant sites
pointed okay so we could see how many
total inbound links and then how many
ranking keywords we have okay so here
Moz is going to give me kind of an idea
of what my domain Authority has been
over time they're going to tell me the
top followed links to this site so they
can tell me you know what are those
links pointing to my site and what's the
page authority of those sites okay here
I can get a nice graphical breakdown of
the linking domains by domain Authority
so you want pages with high domain
Authority pointing to your site so here
I could see 69 linking domains between
91 and 100 so that's really good we want
High relevant domains linking to our
site so just like search console I could
see the top anchor text being used okay
and I can see the top pages that have
you know good page Authority on the side
I could see following versus no follow
on internal and external links so this
is just the overview so Ma's really
really does break down for you you know
what those pages and linking domains are
so if I just click on linking domains
now I could get a detailed look for or
my home page what domains are pointing
to our domain so I can see microsoft.com
has a domain authority of 100 YouTube 99
and so not only does Moz provide you
with the domains it also provides you
with your domain Authority score and
spam score so you want to keep an eye on
any particular site that has a high spam
score so having a site with a high spam
score and a low domain Authority will
hurt your domain and Page Authority for
that page so Mazda does a great job of
breaking it out and this is for any page
it doesn't necessarily have to be the
home page okay if I take a look at
another example here Majestic so
Majestic again I can use a free version
of the tool they have their own metrics
citation flow trust flow so when they
say trust flow what's the link quality
all about okay citation flow what's the
link volume and they can get an idea of
how many external backlinks are pointing
to the site and what's the trend on that
referring to domains so Majestic does a
really good job again some of the same
metrics that we could see here except
they go into detail about languages as
well so this is majestic and you got
search console you got a lot of other
tools and then I'm going to just revert
back to Moz because you want to be able
to compare link profiles if you're in a
competitive space and you're doing
off-page SEO you know Moz will help you
compare how your site stands against
maybe another competitive side or
relevant site so just doing this
analysis I can compare my domain
Authority spam score how many total
links you know how many external file
links or external no file links a
breakdown of linking domains so it does
a nice job of comparing one site versus
another that's going back to Moz and
that's what you want you want a good
tool that's going to help you do that I
mean there's other tools out there not
listed like bright Edge that will also
help you compare linking profiles so at
the end of the day if you're doing and a
half page SEO you want to get a sense of
what sites are linking to yours are they
quality sites are they spammy what
anchor text are they using are they no
follow are they do follow you know are
they top domains how do you compare
against your competitors I mean all
these metrics are related to off-page
SEO so you want a good tool that's going
to help you measure this okay so let's
talk about rank tracking so when we do
keyword research we're looking for
Relevant keywords we find our relevant
keywords we sign primary and secondary
keywords to Pages we optimize those
pages we do off-page SEO and we do in
all this work for SEO okay we want to be
able to measure the fruits of our labor
we want to be able to measure how we
perform for on and off page SEO for the
keywords we covet in the pages they're
related to and so that's where rank
tracking comes into play so we want to
be able to track our website's ranking
and not just our website all the pages
we've optimized we want to be able to
measure our click-through rates and
impressions we want to be able to track
the ranking for both desktop and mobile
for specific locations and we want to
identify top performing gaining and
losing keywords so in other words we
want to look at Trends is a keyword
ranking is it going up and ranking is it
going down and ranking if it's going
down in ranking then you need to take
action so you need a tool a good tool
for rank tracking so we can look no
further than again Google search console
it's free it's right from the source so
let's take a look at what Google search
console has to offer in terms of rank
tracking so if I go to Google Search
console and I put in a URL what it's
going to do is it's going to give me and
this is the search queries report it's
going to give me what queries people
have used to actually type into
google.com and it's going to be able to
tell me how many times my pages show
Pages showed up for that query it could
be more than one page so that's an
impression and if I did receive an
impression meaning did my my page show
up in the organic listing then did I get
a click as a result and so in this case
if I got 68 Impressions and 10 clicks
for keywords somebody typed in that's a
14.7 percent click-through rate and so
with search console we'll also do is say
hey look for that particular keyword you
appeared on average in position 4.1 so
it gives you really good insight as to
you know what people are typing in and
how you're being found for those
keywords it breaks it down by Pages it
breaks it down by country breaks it down
by device so I could see you know mobile
I've had
899 Impressions over the last three
months on mobile and I received 33
clicks as a result my average position
on mobile is 2.6 so search console does
a really good job again this is free
information uh providing you the actual
keywords somebody's using on Google
search as a query and how many
Impressions you're receiving for that
keyword how many clicks click the rate
and then average position so in theory
the higher you are positioned on Google
the more clicks you're going to receive
so if I'm not positioned properly for
keyword let's say page two then I'm
probably not going to receive as many
clicks as I would like so that search
console there are other tools out there
like hrefs again does a good job of
tracking AMZ tracker we look at wincher
so there's some good tools out there I'm
just going to show you another one again
I'm going to go back to Moz for example
so Moz has a tool called so if I go back
into the account so Maz has a rankings
tool that you can look at to see where
your keywords are ranking so if you've
already chosen keywords and optimized
Pages for those keywords then you want
to be able to load those keywords into
Moz and so Moz allows you to do that and
so what Moz does they do a crawl once a
week and they'll be able to tell you
where you rank for all your keywords are
we moving up in the rankings are we
moving down how many keywords do we have
ranked between positions one and three
eleven through twenty four through ten
twenty one through fifty so we'll be
able to see where our keywords Rank and
so it gives you a breakdown here of
nationally in the United States where
this keyword is ranked and if it's moved
up or down and for what URL is it ranked
for and so you can label so the keywords
and and this is what you want to look
for in a good tool you want to be able
to organize your keywords and label them
so for all our brand keywords we want to
be able to label them branded because
ideally you don't want to optimize for
your brain keywords so maybe we want to
exclude our brand keywords and look at
our non-brain keywords in terms of
ranking and so you can certainly add
locations and look at specific locations
the whole idea between a good ranking
tool is to be able to measure you know
if a keyword is trending up or down okay
so I can simply look at a particular
keyword and I can see the trend of that
keyword and then you know if a keyword
is not ranking then we want to wonder
why it's not ranking well is it
difficult is it not ranking because of
its difficulty or can we do a better job
of optimizing for that keyword and so
Moz also has a page optimization tool so
if you're not ranking for keyword you
can flip over to the page optimization
tool then put in the keyword put in the
URL and mods will give you some idea as
to what you can further do to optimize
the page okay so that's Moz you know
this is hrefs so you can see ahrefs does
the same thing they provide you some
visibility average position how much
traffic you know where you're ranking in
terms of positions one through three
four through ten eleven through fifty
and so you want to be able to get a
sense of where my track keywords are
trending are they trending up are they
trending down and the whole idea again
Beyond a ranking tool is if you're
trending down you want to be able to
address why it's trending down so you
want to start with on-page SEO can we do
a better job of optimizing or off page
does does that page need more backlinks
so that's why you need a backlink tool
to support your ranking and ahrefs does
offer up some competitor information as
well so you can see how your competitors
are performing so these are some good
examples of ranking tools that you can
take advantage of now there are also a
few important SEO tools that can be
helpful in different ways for example if
you're doing video so there are some
tools to help you measure how you're
performing via video for example vid IQ
so let's take a look at vid IQ so if I
load in say video in YouTube in this
example how to rank YouTube videos I
have a vid IQ extension loaded into my
browser in Chrome and so now I can get a
good eye sense of how many views the
duration the engagement rate the like
ratio how many people shared it on
Reddit but further I can look at how the
video is optimized so they're telling me
the title is too long here maybe shorten
it up but we have tags we have
descriptions we have cards we have end
screens it's been shared on Facebook it
hasn't been shared on Twitter okay it is
public we do have pinned comments and we
do have hearted comments and so this
gives me an idea of how we did in terms
of optimizing this particular video okay
so if we wanted to tweak it we could
tweak the title tag make it a little bit
shorter to help it rank better on
YouTube so you want to be able to use a
tool like this because if you have
videos then you want those videos to
rank and so you can certainly watch this
video on how to rank your YouTube videos
and in that video we do allude to vid IQ
so you want to be able to use a tool
like this because you know YouTube it is
a video portal but it's the second
largest search engine behind Google so
if you do have videos you want to be
able to rank for them and you want a
tool that's going to help you measure
and help you understand if you are
ranking if you're not ranking why are
you not ranking now for Content
optimization there are tools you can use
like SCS site checkup or site analyzer
are some good tools if you already have
Moz as an example just going back to Moz
as you already know I use mozz a lot so
they have a page optimization so you
could check the content and how you're
optimized your content so it's going to
give me some good feedback on you know
is your page title meta description are
they in line okay so it's going to give
you some good feedback on that you also
have again I have to allude to search
console you can always look at a
particular page in search console see if
it has any errors as well so is it
duplicated meta description is it a
duplicated title tag is it any Pages
missing title tags or meta descriptions
so when it comes to content you can look
at search console you can lean on Moz or
you can lean on some of these other paid
versions like site analyzer when it
comes to traffic and metrics look no
further than Google Analytics there is a
free version of Google analytics as well
as a paid version so if I go into Google
analytics it's going to tell me all of
my website Behavior okay who's coming to
my site how they got to my site how they
behaved once they went to my site and
are they achieving the goals I set out
for them to achieve via conversions and
so you want to look at first in Google
analytics how much traffic you're
getting so if I go to Google analytics
if I go to acquisition all traffic
channels I should be able to see how
much traffic organic search is driving
over a period of time so I could see how
many users how many sessions then if I
click on landing pages I can see what
landing page they went to so I could see
the home page over a particular time had
over a thousand sessions I can also see
engagement from organic search are they
bouncing how many pages are they looking
at in the session after they landed on a
particular page are they staying on the
site a long time what's their duration
or are they achieving any goals so
analytics will provide me all that
information about how organic search as
a channel is performing the other thing
about Google analytics I like and that
goes back to the technical aspect of SEO
and that site speed so if you go to
behavior and you go to site speed
overview you'll be able to see how my
pages are loading what's the average
load time so they'll break it down for
you by browser by country and by a
specific page so if I look at page
timings I'll be able to see what page is
loading slow what page is loading quick
compared to site average and so the
great thing about analytics is if I have
a page that's loading slow compared to
site average they'll actually provide me
with some suggestions so if I go to site
speed and speed suggestions what they're
going to do is they're going to have a
link in the report that's going to allow
me to click on it and I'm going to be
able to see what suggestions they can
provide so when this report loads I'll
be able to see what the speed
suggestions are are for my pages so here
I could see the page I could see what
the average low time is of that page so
for example this particular page is
loading at six seconds ideally we want
to have you know three seconds or under
maximum so if I just click on this link
here they're giving me six page speed
suggestions so if I click on that I'm
gonna go to another Google tool called
page speed insights and then paid speed
insights is going to run for both mobile
and desktop for this particular page and
then this page speed insights report is
going to give me feedback as to what I
need to do to speed up the load time of
that page so here you can see for
desktop and mobile they're going to give
me some suggestions and opportunities so
reduce the server response time properly
size images serve images in next-gen
formats so all these will shave off time
off my page load time and so that's
what's going to help me speed up the
page load and that's page speed insights
you can get to from the speed suggestion
report and analytics so in theory the
higher page load time your chances of
ranking on Google organic search
diminished so Google wants pages that
have very low page load time that load
quickly so Google analytics is a great
tool for Speed suggestions it's a great
tool for finding out what the traffic is
doing on your site how they're engaging
and are they achieving goals now there
are other tools out there from an
organic perspective like keyword it
that's a good keyword research tool for
Reddit so if you go to keyword it you'll
be able to see from a Reddit perspective
what keywords are driving volume these
are just the results but you can put any
keyword in there and get the results of
that keyword so if you're looking to
become a digital marketing specialist
then look no further than simply learn
postgraduate program in digital
marketing with this you gain all the
necessity skills in digital marketing
like website creation behavioral
marketing keyword research search engine
optimize station search engine marketing
campaign management social media
marketing and more with knowledge of
tools like SC ranking hoot suit chat GPD
Google ads Google Keyword Planner Google
Trends and there's much more on the list
don't miss out on this incredible
opportunity take action today and enroll
in a course to unlock the digital
marketing success accelerate your career
and gain the skills you need to thrive
in the industry ready to get started
then click on the link mentioned in the
description box and embark on your
journey to professional growth and
achievement hello everyone welcome to
this new video by simply learn search
engine optimization has been playing an
essential role in the success of various
businesses for those who are still
looking for growth in the industry and
have search engine optimization
otherwise known as SEO as their primary
weapon then yes you are in the right
place this video on how to rank number
one on Google will give you the best
tips to get a higher ranking without
spending a penny but before we begin
subscribe to our Channel simply learn
turn and hit the Bell icon to never miss
any updates from Simply learn so before
we begin I have a question for you the
process of getting the quality and
quantity of traffic to your website
organically is known as search engine
marketing search engine optimization
search engine advertising or none of the
above let me know your answers in the
comments section Below in this video
first we will understand why it's
essential to rank high in search engines
next we will have a look at the top five
mantras on how to get ranked number one
on Google search result pages and while
understanding this we will put a light
on why these success tips are important
for getting a good ranking and how we
can actually implement it we will share
some necessary tools to help you carry
out the needed process and stick to the
end of this video to find out the one
thing that can impact your business
tenfold
so definitely we're going to take a look
at the best tips for ranking high on
Google but before that it is necessary
to understand why it's important to rank
high on Google
well we are all aware that most of the
businesses are shifting online nowadays
ranking on search engines has become one
of the most important aspects that
Define the success of a business
the data states that around 1.17 billion
people across the globe use Google
search which is estimated to increase
exponentially in the coming years
moreover Google has gained the trust of
their users with their services over the
years this definitely makes the point of
interest to understand why it's
important to rank high on Google search
ranking at the top of search engine
result pages also known as serps allows
a business to generate more traffic to
their website and possibly get more
leads by which then they can get a
chance to convert leads into customers
thereby boosting sales
it also helps in generating authenticity
for your business well not one or two
there are numerous reasons which makes
SEO important to know more about SEO
check the complete playlist on SEO you
can find the link to the playlist in the
description box below
to gain expertise in search engine
optimization get certified as a skilled
SEO professional with simply learns
search engine optimization training
course you can check the course details
from the link in the description box
below as we know how important it is to
rank high on Google so in the next 10
minutes let's get to know the top five
success mantras that will help you rank
high-end Google so the fifth tip on our
list is promote your content whether you
are a business owner or a blogger you
definitely need to promote your content
to get a good audience reach by content
here we mean data on your website that
can be products services or even a
simple blog to do this find the relevant
groups on the social media platforms
like Facebook or Instagram and post your
content with an excellent call to action
context some blogging or article
submission sites like quora Tumblr and
hub pages may also prove helpful online
forums and communities can be a good
option to spread a word about your
content with people having similar
interests let's focus on our number four
tip internal linking a good site
architecture is always a happy bite for
web crawlers a website with good site
architecture and internal linking helps
web crawlers understand the website
structure and helps them to crawl the
site more effectively the more the pages
of your website are crawled greater are
the chances of getting indexed if pages
are successful indexed they get eligible
for appearing in the search results
let's move to our tip number three yes
it is backlink building any website
linking to your website is a backlink
for your website websites with more
backlinks suggest to the search engine
crawlers that that website has good
content and is trustworthy and should be
ranked higher on the search result pages
to get a backlink the most important
thing is to understand that the da or
the domain authority of the website for
which you are looking for the backlink
is greater than yours getting backlinks
is somewhat entirely a gesture of
Goodwill you can find a page relevant to
your business and ask the website owner
to add the link to your website to the
page in a humble manner you can create a
better or updated version of some other
web content let the site owner know
about it and then ask for a backlink in
a humble way yes you can find some more
relevant backlink building techniques in
the video how to build backlinks check
out the link in the description box
below
and number two we have a tip which is of
utmost importance to win a good position
in the search results on page
optimization on-page optimization are
also known as on-page SEO is a process
in which we take essential measures to
improve the website or web pages
position in search engine rankings
on-page optimization is a vast concept
that includes technical optimization of
websites like server speed page loading
speed removing page errors submitting
Pages for indexing and more maintaining
a good website structure and improving
it adding internal and external links on
the site adding SEO optimized images and
video on the page efficient use of
keywords on the page and links and much
more
get the detail guide to learning on-page
optimization by simply learn
check the link in the description box
below and finally the best tip we have
is the most effective one and the one
that rules them all which is keyword
research
keyword research is a process of
identifying and implementing the
relevant keywords for the content you
tend to create
proper keyword research may prove a boon
to your business but it also has the
power to ruin your business so be wise
When selecting your keywords try
choosing long tail keywords if you are
new to the business as these are easier
to rank for you can look at Google's
Auto suggest feature to understand what
people are looking for in your industry
be updated with what your competitors
are doing if something is working for
your competitor there are high chances
that it may work for you as well you can
also take the help of various keyword
research tools like Google's own Keyword
Planner answer the public tool Google
Trends and Etc
these fantastic and 100 practical tips
can drive your business to Heights make
sure you implement all these tips with
more detailed attention as SEO can make
and break you so what according to you
is the most effective way to grow your
business online let us know in the
comments below to the simply learn
YouTube channel in today's video we are
going to talk about Google business
profile you may remember Google business
profile as Google my business but Google
has changed to name and I'll explain to
you later the reasoning behind this
change we're going to be talking about
what is Google business profile what do
you need to know about it how do you use
Google business profile as a small
business yep and we're going to discuss
many other topics in relation to this as
well but before we start let me
introduce myself I am Mark kempman I am
your digital navigator for this video if
you like the video click the like button
and if you want to subscribe to our our
Channel click the Subscribe button below
and you will get lots and lots of access
to more videos and get notifications
about when we publish new videos so
let's dig straight into it let me give
you some facts about Google which will
tell you which will show you that you
cannot afford to miss out on what Google
has to offer you did you know that
Google was visited
89.3 billion times in the past month
only
yeah Google holds over 90 market share
in the search engine Market Google
processes 99
000 searches every second which makes
that a total of 8.5 billion searches
every day
I also remember 63 percent of those
surges are done on a mobile phone
now Google Maps is a key part of your
Google business profile did you know
that there are over 5 billion downloads
of the Google Maps app
and as you find to finalize these
numbers yeah Google generated
146.92 billion dollars in advertising
Revenue in 2020. so do I need to
convince you any further that Google has
to be center stage of your marketing
efforts let's talk how you can do this
when you are a local small business so
what are we going to be talking about we
will talk about what is Google business
profile
how can you use Google business profile
for your local marketing
yeah how do you get started with Google
business profile how can you use your
Google business profile for your search
engine optimization to get a higher
ranking in your Google search engine
results and I'll finish off with a few
pros and cons of the Google business
profile so are you ready let's first
talk about what is Google business
profile it used to be called Google my
business Google has renamed Google my
business to Google business profile to
make it more simple yeah to bring more
of the business profile management
functions out of the Google my business
app directly into Google search and the
Google Map
yep so now the history of the name it's
you currently called Google business
profile you may remember Google my
business before that it was Google
places before that it was Google Plus
local remember those good old days and
when it officially started it was just
Google local
but to keep things simple it has now
been renamed as Google business profile
that you can access through the Google
search or through Google Maps
so how would you define it Google
business profile is a tool that enables
you to manage and optimize your business
profile on Google
yeah so you can create a free business
profile on Google for your shop or your
service area so you can turn people who
find you on Google Search and on Google
Maps into new customers and once you've
created your Google business profile you
can then personalize it with photos with
offers with posts and many other things
and later in this presentation I will
show you how to do all this
so your business profile is Google's
term for your Google Business listing
yeah they appear in Google maps and in
the local results of Google search and
that's very important you can access it
through Google Maps and Google search in
the local search results and you can
also see it on the right side of the
search engine results page
so let me show you an example if I open
up a new frame and I search for Indian
restaurant
yep then here you see the search results
yep you see
restaurants and here you see a map where
you can find those places yeah so that
is in the first place where your
restaurant will show up
yes so if I go then click on one of the
restaurants I can get more details of
different restaurants but also more
details about a restaurant that I picked
yeah and this is what you specify in
Google my business profile
so I could also access them through the
map
yeah so if I click on that that opens up
the same window with more details about
the restaurant as specified in Google
business profile now what is all in
there I'll share that with you in a
minute
so that is the power of Google business
profile
so how can you use this for your local
marketing why is it good to use it to
set up your business profile
Google has reported that 46 of all
searches done on Google have a local
intent
and at business location is the main
piece of information sought by local
searchers
yeah so it's the easiest way and the
fastest way for you to show up in the
search feed
so Google business profile gives you the
ability to incorporate your search
engine results into your marketing and
that is a huge Advantage for local
businesses it's not just an ordinary
business listing but it's a robust tool
that gives you benefits from appearing
in the Google search results so if I
would summarize the benefits of Google
business profile they are as follows
they will give you customer engagement
they will help you highlighting your
business in Google
you can gain insights from the people
that visit your website and you can
optimize your online presence for local
SEO
so let's dive into these a little bit
deeper let's start with the customer
engagement
so through Google business profile
customers and Prospects can contact you
and in your business profile you can
specify your telephone number your
address and directions to your business
so people can contact you they can find
you and they can engage with you
say for example a potential lead comes
across your business in the search
results but he wants something special
so how will you reach out to you
directly from the search list
Google business profile has a messaging
feature that lets you directly chat with
potential customers who will find your
profile on the search results page it
enables you to quickly answer questions
in real time and help your current and
potential customers
Google gives you the option to activate
this yeah so when you activate it users
visiting your page will see a clickable
message icon on top of that they can
call you or you can add posts to your
business profile to promote special
offers or events and updates to keep
your customers in the loop you can also
reply to public customer reviews to
build trust with new returning customers
and of course you can post answers to
frequently asked questions by your
customers
the second Advantage is that Google
business profile offers you the
opportunity to highlight your business
yes it gives you a ton of opportunities
to specify a lot of things about your
business when you sign up and sign in
you get to your dashboard and that's
where you can add items like showcasing
what makes your store special show
photos of your latest products and your
store to stand out to customers who find
your profile yeah you show whether your
offer options like a pickup or a
delivery you can give people who find
you online a warm welcome with posts
about discounts new products upcoming
events so lots of things that you can
highlight about your business again let
me show you an example if I go to Google
and I search for instance for Disney
Paris
yeah you will see I find or let's say
Disneyland
Paris
yes so when I click here on Disneyland
Paris then here I get all the details I
can see the description I can see the
address the rights that you can do the
hours of opening you can see who is
owned by you see events that they have
there's questions and answers there's
reviews yep and there's more information
there's links to social media so lots of
stuff that you can find here as long as
you specified it all on your dashboard
when you highlight your business
so the third benefit is that you can
gain a lot of insights with people or
from people that visit your um and that
find you on Google yes so you can gain
data about your target market and your
local search performance
you can track your performance over a
given time period and it will give you
insights how people interact with your
business on Google you can check how
often your profile has been viewed you
can use profile views insights to track
how popular your business is with
current and potential customers
yeah not obviously only the owner of the
business profile can view the profile
insights
you will get metrics like the queries
people used to find your business the
number of unique visitors to your
profile number of unique customers who
request directions to your business the
number of clicks on the call to action
button on your business profile number
of clicks on the website link number of
unique conversations through messages
a number of completed bookings by
customers a summary of all your
interactions number of views on products
over a selected period And if you are a
restaurant you can get food orders
placed for pickup or delivery and you
get a number of clicks on the menu
content per user per day so you gain a
lot of knowledge about who what and when
people are accessing and finding you on
the on Google and finally one of the
biggest advantages that you can get with
Google business profile is that it
improves your local search rankings
leading to a higher visibility of your
business on the web
so when you search for a product or
service on Google the first three
listings are usually Google ads
yeah followed by a map with the local
three pack as we call this and then you
will see the organic search results
so let's show you an example of this
local three pack on Google if I go to
search and I search for shoe shop near
me
yeah I'm getting ads yeah that's the
first part and then I'm getting three
places and here is your Google three
pack your local three pack with the map
and then I have the organic search
results
yes so one of the biggest benefit then I
get the shirts results so for local
businesses prior to this local pack yeah
there were two main ways to show up on
the first page of Google
through local pay-per-click and through
local SEO
now with the addition of this Google
local pack you now have three potential
ways that you could show up on the first
page of Google for Relevant local
searches and that's something that can
not be ignored now what is this local
three pack it consists of the top three
local businesses based on the searcher's
location
yeah the best part of it is that
customers now end up at your shops Front
without even having to visit your
websites
so remember this used to be a seven pack
and it's now limited to only three local
listings hence the title the local three
pack
now many businesses have been trying
different SEO tricks to get into this
special category of three listings yeah
but what most of them don't know is that
by creating a Google business profile
listing you can significantly increase
the chances of making it onto this list
now there's more that you can do to make
it in this three pack it's important to
get reviews on your Google my business
profile yeah so that helps you increase
the chances of showing up in this local
pack and it's also good for your
reputation which is very important for
your business and Google will reward you
for that with giving you higher search
rankings
and additionally all the SEO rules and
guidelines that apply to standard search
engine optimization they apply to your
local listing as well so think about
your keywords your website SEO getting
backlinks these will all contribute to
your local search listing and whether or
not you will appear in the three pack
now also consider that paid advertising
can help you in getting your business
listed here
yeah through local search ads on Google
there is an opportunity for your
business to serve a local pay-per-click
ad in the three pack
yep and remember just a few tips in
order to show up in the Google three
pack with your pay-per-click ads there's
a few steps that you need to take yeah
enable local extensions or location
extensions as we call them in Google ads
bit the location and use sorry bit by
location and use location targeting
and optimize your keywords to include
your location as well
so having your business appear in the
local three pack can help you tap into
potential Revenue opportunities as
Google not only shows customers your
business on Google Maps but it also
places it before organic search results
and let's look at the final topic before
we go into a demo of Google business
profile let's look at a bit more detail
about how Google business profile can
help you with your SEO and what you need
to do to optimize it for SEO
there are three aspects in using Google
business profile for SEO
you need to Target your information by
including your SEO keywords relevant to
your business
you need to make sure you maintain
information quality by ensuring all
information is accurate consistent and
correct and you need to build trust by
engaging with your customers
so to achieve this here is what you need
to do you need to verify your business
you need to fill out your profile
completely
you need to make sure your profile
information is and stays accurate you
must ensure that your nap name address
place is consistent across the web which
is very important yeah your address is
unique across all your places where you
are on the web you pick the most
relevant categories for your business
make sure that your pictures your photos
are of the highest quality
focus on getting reviews
create posts on your business profile to
drive engagement with your customers and
when customers ask questions on your
business profile make sure you answer
those questions
yeah here you see the importance when
you fill in all the data of the various
Fields you see the most important yeah
there is name address phone number
website link but don't forget the all
the other items as well
so for determining your local ranking
Google takes three factors into
consideration
there's the relevance of your listing is
how well your business matches the
user's search intent
and to increase the chances that your
local business appears in the search
results you should feed Google with as
much information as possible
Google will also look at the distance
yeah so the distance refers to how close
your business location is to the
location of the user who searches
and finally prominence yeah Google
determines your local ranking by
checking out how well known your
business is and whether or not you have
a good reputation
and to influence this reputation you
have off-site links and articles related
to your business they can really
contribute to building your reputation
online
so now that you've got all the details
about Google business profile let's have
a look at how you set it up and I'm
going to show you how to sign into your
Google business accounts how you can add
your business how you can enter your
location how you can fill in your
contact information I tell you about the
process of verifying your business and
then finally how you can customize your
profile
so let's have a look at Google business
profile if I go to the Google business
profile website then I just go there by
searching for Google business profile
and click on the link that I see on the
search results and then I get to this
page yeah a short summary of what your
free business profile is all about how
you can access your dashboard if you've
got to be a business profile you see
some benefits free easy personalized and
then it gives you all the benefits that
you get from having your business
profile on Google
yes so that is one area where you can
access of course your Google business
profile now the other area where you can
access your Google business profile is
to go to Google Maps so if I go to
Google Maps
and I click here on Google Maps this
takes me to Google Maps if I now want to
go for instance to register my own
business own Google business profile let
me show you how to do that I can be on
Google Maps I can go to
the place that I want to to register
yeah so and I want that actually on
Google Maps so I don't want that here I
want to stay on Google Maps so let's say
I say like
South Cerny
there is where I have a lodge that I
rent out and if I go zoom in on that
yeah and then here I can see it is
dislodge yeah and currently there's
nothing on there you see this house has
no
business profile this one has
yes so this one has as well so how can I
register this Lodge on Google business
profile very simple I can register it by
right clicking on it
yep so I can get directions what's here
I can say add your business so if I
click here on add your business guess
where that takes me it takes me to
Google business profile and I'm now
going into this setup under my Google
account
yeah I'm going to the setup on Google my
business for this place so the place
name is Isis 97.
Lodge
okay so I click enter and I'm going to
click continue
now it talks to me what is this place
about what kind of business type is it
an online retail is it a local store or
is it a service business let's say it is
a local store customers can visit the
business in person click on that and it
takes me to the next screen
yeah so I'm going to go for an enter a
business category there's a whole load
of uh categories here I can say just a
lodge or I can say what is it a
um a resort let's see if I can do that a
resource Hotel yeah or a resort place I
can just say a holiday
sort of
a home
yeah so let's call it a holiday home and
I'm going to click next
now it wants the business address so the
country in this case is not Malaysia
because that's where I am at the moment
so it takes my default address it's in
the United Kingdom the street address is
Isis Lake
and then it is I need to put the address
97 Isis Lake
spine Road
East
yeah the post tone is south
Cerny postcode gl75lt
so spine Road East which is the
watermarks
spine Road East I don't mind to share
this data with you because it's going to
be public anyway because people will be
able to find this on the internet yes so
I'm going to click next
what contact details do I want to show
my customers I want to show them the
phone number and that could be 07545
and then three two eight
nine nine nine
is United Kingdom and I can also say I'm
going to skip this step actually for now
I'm going to skip this step
put your business on the map you start
connecting with your customers across
Google all in one place so here are the
details that you've learned earlier in
today's presentation get discovered
respond to review manage your business
details yep and now I'm going to click
do I want to get tips and alerts I'm not
interested in that I just click continue
and here I am in my
dashboard now here comes the process of
verification which is an important
element of Google business profile
yeah so we talked a bit about businesses
using it for spam purposes yeah so the
verification is very important for
Google there are various ways that you
can get verification Google has made it
fairly simple you can verify through a
through a phone number you can also
verify by getting a card sent to your
physical business address
your listing will not show on Google
until you have verified your business
okay but for now I'm going to click next
and I'm going to actually I'm gonna
click verify later because I don't want
to do the verification yet
so now I can add business hours I'm
going to skip that
yeah I remember we talked about
messaging I'm going to skip the
messaging and now I can add photos of my
business so let's grab a photo from the
internet yep so let's say Isis Lake
South Cerny
and I'm going to go to images
so here is the park where you see images
so I am going to uh take any random
image let's say we'll take
this image
yep I'm gonna right click I'm going to
click save image s and I'm going to do
Isis Lodge om
all right so I'm going to complete my
profile I'm going to add a photo I'm
going to select photo from the computer
I'm going to YouTube and then desktop
and here is the Isis Lodge
yep there's the photo and I can
obviously add a lot more photos there's
the next do I want to start advertising
on Google ads I can actually claim a 400
pounds free advertising credits of
course that is really good what they do
here just to get you to start using
advertising
and then get a customer domain name for
a website I haven't got a website yet
but I'm not interested in that at the
moment
yes so remember your edits will be
visible once you're verified all right
so my listing will not be visible yet
but here is basically my besting list
business listing as it stands at the
moment but it is not publicly visible
but at least I have set up my business
profile yeah so now I'm in my dashboard
in Google
my business I had to go into a separate
app for this but now I can actually edit
it all through the search so that is
very useful so here is edit profile read
reviews read the messages
add photos what is the performance do we
want to go advertising all the things we
discussed in our earlier session so edit
profile and here I can get information
about contact information location
information hours of opening my business
name of my launch the opening date
contact information yes so location I
can specify here
so all the details that I need and if I
do this properly is where it will show
up in Google and if I really got my
reputation shorter than everything I may
show up in the Google three pack as well
so that is the process of setting up
your Google business profile so let's
now look at an existing business profile
let's switch my account
so I'm going to sign out of this account
and I'm going to sign in again into my
own accounts
so now I'm in my own Google account and
I'm going to I'm switching to Chrome I
say no just leave it as it is
okay well we can do that
yeah so now I'm in my Google Chrome my
my personal account and I'm going to
show you an existing
um Google business profile that I have
which is for a website for another house
in Marrakesh which is Riyadh farasha
yeah so you see here it is already on
Google my business oh sorry it's already
on Google business profile but I haven't
really populated it yet with information
okay so here you can see I can access
this
through the Google search to manage my
profile
yep so I can edit the profile I can read
the reviews all the things that I want
to do I can add an update I can see the
photos yep so here I have access to it
and then here you see the site panel
with a summary of all the things that
you've done
okay I could also access this through
Google Maps again if I go to Google Maps
and I search in Google maps for riyat
for Russia
yeah here it is
it will take me here's the basic details
in Google Maps yeah and it will take me
here to Riyadh for Russia but it is
empty I haven't added any information in
it yet so I can now click here
um manage my business profile or I can
see where
um the all the details that I have added
so far
I get some basic data so 55 people
feuded this month
and without actually having done any
effort in optimizing it or populating it
with information so if I here click on
manage your business profile that takes
me back to the Google search screen
where I can add all the data so let's
add a photo I can click here for add a
photo or I can click here to add a photo
I'm clicking here add a photo I'm doing
a photo click here
and then select photo or video and that
is from the YouTube
desktop it's here for Russia 01 it's the
photo that I'm going to add
yep so now I can see the photo
let's see if I can do here you see the
photo
call it
yeah and of course I can add a lot more
I can do a logo a cover a video photo of
the Interior here's a photo that I've
done so far so I can now go back to my
business profile
yeah I think it will take a bit of time
before the photo shows up on the
on the profile
yeah so click add photo
yes so the photos don't show up yet
yeah but that's how you can optimize
your profile making sure all the
information is relevant yep so that is
basically all there is to managing your
profile on on Google business profile so
remember you can access it directly by
searching for your business name in
Google search
or you can exit it access it directly by
entering for searching for your business
name on Google Maps
both show the results and then they also
give you access to your dashboard where
you can add all the information that
needs to be added
yeah performance we talked about that as
well yeah so here you can check by month
you can see I've I've started the um the
the created the pro the business profile
sort of the beginning of October so here
you can see I can check from October to
December apply
so I see I had 18 business profile
interactions I can check people that
called me people that message me the
directions people that look at website
clicks booking clicks so you can get a
lot of information
of people that visited your business
profile
okay so that concludes the demo of the
Google business profile and now let's go
back to the slides to give you a summary
of the Google business profile and the
positives and the negatives of it
okay hope you found that useful so let's
finish today's presentation with a few
more facts about the pros and the cons
of your Google business profile we
talked about old approach all the
benefits that you can get yeah and to
summarize Google business profile can
help you with reaching your customers
it can help you responding to customer
interests it can help you respond to
customer feedbacks and you can get into
engagement with your customers and most
important of all it can help you in a
very easy way to get a presence on
Google search results page without
actually having a website
so it is of extremely powerful tool and
it's a free tool for your business to
get yourself an online presence where
your customers can find you
and where they can engage with you
but there are some cons as well yeah I
have to think hard about cons but as
most things in digital marketing one con
you could say yeah it takes time
yeah of course you need to set up your
business profile yeah and it takes time
to do that it takes time to maintain
this but I don't see this a considerable
serious drawback
because people that are prepared to put
a time and effort into it they will be
rewarded accordingly
one potential negative of Google
business profile can be that fake
businesses can use it as well because
it's a free service
yeah and although you do there is a
verification process in the Google
business profile yeah there may be
businesses who take advantage of this of
this free service yeah so anyone can
realistically set up a profile to
promote their business
so there was an example a few years ago
that fake locksmiths were committing
fraud through local listings on Google
business profile with bogus profiles so
while the majority of the profiles are
genuine businesses trying to promote
themselves in a very competitive World
there are some to see this as a feature
and an opportunity for scams
yeah so people believe that reviews
photos and verifying a business by mail
would be enough to disturb scammers
however in this age of fake news as well
as misleading e-commerce reviews Google
must take action to constantly optimize
their verification process of Google
business profile
welcome to today's session
I am Sachin sehgal and I am here to talk
about a very important tool Google ads
what is Google ads
Google ads is a online platform or an
interface or a tool we can share a
software which is developed by Google
to help the advertisers to run different
kind of ads on different publishing
sites or publishing platforms
if I make it more simple for you suppose
you are an Advertiser and you sell a
digital marketing course
so you know that the bulk of the traffic
would come from Google because this is
the most used search engine in the world
so when we type this we see lot of
results here
and when we start a website it is very
difficult to rank organically or free or
through the SEO on the very first few
pages
with the help of Google ads in a very
starting days we can rank on the top
like this this this
[Music]
or this Advertiser so these are the four
top positions which right now has been
given to the advertisers who are playing
or who are running their ad using Google
ads
on a first page we see seven of such ads
four on the top I've shown you and three
on the bottom
so these are the maximum placements
which we see on a Google search page
this is the first kind of AD which can
be created under the Google ads tool
which we would definitely going to learn
today how to create such beautiful ad
copy second ad which generally we see on
different
sites like if I'll open any new site if
I'll open any block site if I open a
site like a speedtest.net then you would
see a beautiful banner or a responsive
ad like these these and these okay how
come I am able to say that these are ads
so if you'll just hover on this this
would say ads by Google
ads by Google so a different Advertiser
this is a Paramount this is from GoDaddy
and the publishing site which has been
selected by these advertisers is
speedtest.net
the Third Kind of AD which we generally
see on Google itself but in a different
colors and shape is called shopping ad
so if I just search suppose I want black
formal
shoes
then
the add copy is changed it is not
like a text ad which we have seen
earlier
though there is no text ad in this
search but we have just seen in the case
of digital marketing course
but it is an ad we can see from here
okay so this is called a shopping ad
then if I go and if I'll open
YouTube
and if I'll search our term maybe I am
in a search of email
for beginners course
and if I just play any of the videos a
random one
and before the video please
we can skip after
five to six seconds and sometimes we see
a ad which streams but cannot be skipped
so these are video ads which again
created by this beautiful tool Google
ads one more ad Mobile Installation but
I cannot show you as I am from the
desktop though I would able to show you
the screenshot of the same
now coming to the part why Google ad is
so important okay so I'll be just quick
now because we have to be making the
account today and also the campaign
Google ad is important in many ways
because Google ad helps us to increase
the visibility of our products increase
the visibility of our brand because you
can just imagine you were there on
Google but you were somewhere on Sixth
page or probably you know in the next
pagination if I just go and not beyond
that there are the results but suppose
you are you are on the sixth page so we
can just assume that nobody goes beyond
first or second I don't know if you go
or not but I don't go okay and that's
how the service is 97 of people doesn't
go beyond first to second page so that
means we have to be on a first page if
we really want to sell our products so
increasing that visibility of our brand
would take time if we just keep waiting
for SEO results to come or to give us
the first page or a second page ranking
so for that reason for a quick results
by making a relevant ad copy and by
targeting the right keywords we can
increase availability we can increase
the brand awareness we can increase the
traffic
okay we can also use a beautiful way of
retargeting or a remarketing where
people are able to recall our brand or
able to make the decisions if at a first
time they were not actually taken
suppose I say they went to my site
or any of the sides but in a very first
time they have not given me a result so
for me as this website the result is
getting the lead form field this is a
lead form and this is the page where we
have reached and where wherever you know
you would see a relevant page connected
to the particular ad that page is called
a landing page okay so this landing page
has a Content this landing page has an
objective to get the form field and this
landing page has a CTA which is called a
call to action okay so for me as an
Advertiser or as a digital marketer or
as a campaign manager of this brand did
you perform it's very important to get
as many as people to this page plus it
is the most important part that I get a
lot of form field and lot of CPA clicks
or this call to action clicks but every
time I cannot assume I have to be
realistic as well if even hundred or
thousand users have landed to my website
from the ad I cannot expect more than
three to five percent conversions okay
so if I say suppose 100 users have
reached my page today since morning so I
can only expect three to five percent of
leads or three to five users would have
filled the data but when we talk about
the remarketing then it is about
retargeting those guys who have reached
here but did not
filled up the data or did not convert it
or in the same case if I have taken them
to the black formal shoes site they
reached to the landing page or a product
page but did not bought the product so
for that reason we can always retarget
them using the website data so all these
things are very important once we start
learning Google ads deeply then you
would know how these works like you know
how the functionality of of these works
like okay so they are talking about the
same thing rlsa is retargeting list of
search ads we are able to Target people
who have not converted okay who have not
converted okay
then it is also used for
um I think I've talked about branding
now they're talking about how these
strategies work like so we generally
work on the different bid strategies
like how you pay to Google so the most
important one when it comes to Google
search ad this is called search art or
techstart is CPC so CPC is cost per
click okay now I'm talking about a very
important technical term the very first
technical term probably we have just
talked uh about the broadness off of the
Google ads how that is you know
important to increase The Branding
visibility and traffic we did talked
about the remarketing a bit but now I'm
getting into the campaign terms which is
going to be very important if you want
to learn today how to create a search
camp in a search art so the very first
thing is bidding strategy so we pay CPC
or it is also called PTC when we are
doing this sort of an ad which is called
text ad this means cost per click or pay
per click so when somebody clicks on
this clicks on this clicks on this as a
user as a Searcher as a viewer then only
Advertiser would pay to Google
this is what PPC means pay per click
marketing so Advertiser is getting an
advantage that till the time the ad has
only been shown
he is not paying any Penny to Google but
the movement a very first user comes and
clicks on it then the amount of certain
bid value starts deducting from the
advertisers Google ads account which we
certainly going to be creating for you
guys as well in a while okay so you
create a Google ads account you put some
money into it you start running the ad
of different sort text ad Banner ad
video ad shopping ad and the movement
somebody clicks or somebody watches a
video or somebody takes any action on
your ads then only you pay most of the
times okay that is what the CPC strategy
works like
then also it is a very important part
that we should know how we are measuring
the results so in anywhere in the
digital marketing if you talk from my
experience I know we are only able to
get better results or we are only able
to get more conversions if we are just
not running the ad we have to be first
researching how the ads should be
created we have to be working on the
areas which should not be filled uh we
should not be left unfilled and it
should be focused on the audience it
should be focused on certain
parameters and after running the ad also
it is very important to keep measuring
the performance and optimizing
optimizing and optimizing further or
otherwise taking care in the next
campaign okay so I think superficially
we have talked about lot of things on a
go why not just to get into the Google
ads now see how the account is created
for free and then let's make a campaign
first and we'll come back and we
understand we'll try to understand some
of the important things like you know
there are metrics which we have to be
seeing there are formats okay so for
maths I've already talked about okay so
this is the text that I've already shown
then there is a banner ad which I've
shown you on the uh you know
speedtest.net there is another kind of
an ad image that again you know you see
on a different platforms like websites
and apps then there is a app ad which I
could not show you practically because I
am logged in from my desktop so this was
the fifth kind of an ad which I was
talking about a Mobile Installation ad
so this probably you see only on most of
the time on up mobile because as an
Advertiser he would want that
installation Button as a CTA should be
directly placed under the ad so that if
person searches for something on a
mobile then the ad is directly showing
them the installation button and the app
can be downloaded into their mobile
gadgets okay so now then there is a
video ad which we already seen in the
shopping ad I've already shown you okay
then there's a another ad which is just
a call only though it is again you know
created by the Google ads only we will
see now coming to create the Google ads
okay so first of all
creating the campaign we need to be
having a Google ads account that's a
very first requirement so I'll just help
you now how you create a Google ads
account for free by using your Gmail ID
okay so we go to Google
let me just search probably here itself
and we type Google ads just ensure that
you are logged in with any of your Gmail
ID
and then we see Google ads
on a top
then we just need to click this
and
once you reach to this page you have to
click get started
after get started probably in my case
you would see a different screen because
I have lot of accounts created a lot of
clients accounts are there but in your
case it will show new Google Earth
account
like this
so I will repeat my steps so that you're
not confused
so you go on Google
you type Google ads
you click Google ads the very first
result
or either if it is not showing in your
country in your location then you have
to just find ads.google.com
and you click get started
okay the moment you click get started
you would directly reach to this page
okay that's why I just repeated my steps
because I have been taken to some other
page where my already created accounts
were showing but in your case after just
clicking get started it will directly
going to take you to this page now here
you have to ensure that you are not
clicking anything why because this has
brought us to the express mode Express
mode is more of the kind like automated
or a smart mode which is created by
Google for uh making the quick ads you
know it is not going to be showing you
all the exhaustive settings or you know
advanced settings inside so for that
reason what we do we go down we just you
know I've just I've just scroll down
okay and then switch to expert mode
okay I'll again repeat when we click
this get started we reach to this page
where it takes us to the smart or
Express mode where we don't have to be
doing anything we scroll down and we
click on a switch to export mode
once we click that
then you would see few things which you
have just seen in the PPD probably that
what is your objective why you have come
here you have come here to increase your
sales leads website traffic and XYZ
things but because right now I'm just
teaching you or just letting you know
how the account is created then we can
ignore these tabs for a moment of course
in a while we'll talk about these as
well so we'll just scroll down and we'll
create a account without a campaign as I
said we are going in a sequence so we
are not creating the campaign first I am
considering most of the users would not
have the Google ad account as of now so
I am going that way so you create the
account first without a campaign so when
you click this
then you see
there are a few basic questions been
asked like from which country you are
building would be which time zone you
want to follow or which currency you
would be paying in okay once this is
done just click submit
okay just click submit
once this is done congrats you're all
done okay and you just need to click on
explore your account
and this takes you to the
dashboard of this beautiful tool Google
ads from where we can start our journey
of making the very first campaign
okay so now let's again come back to the
PPT because our account is created now
before making the campaign what all
things should be cleared let's discuss
okay so you can create all these kind of
campaigns or with all these goals inside
the Google ads which we have just
learned how to be creating the account
okay how the account is created we can
create the campaign to increase the
sales we can in we can increase the
leads by running the ads you can
increase our website traffic we can work
for the product branding or a
consideration we can also work for brand
awareness and app promotion okay these
are the subdefined goals or predefined
goals before we jump into the campaign
making of a search or a display or a
video okay I I hope this all these all
are very much defined or self-defined
one so I don't have to be you know
telling you what is sales and what is
branding and what is awareness but still
if you feel so in our in a while I will
just going to throw some light on it
okay then
setting up the ad group so I'll be just
making all this practically with you so
we don't again you don't have to be
understanding all this now coming to
some of the metrics which you would see
inside
the campaign once that is created so
let's just go back and
see one of the
ads from any of my clients so that we
can learn better
only I'll just open in a different tab
okay so if I just have to show you
probably I can just use right now the
demo account or simply learn where
important metrics
we can discuss which which has already
been given in the PPT but of course I
would just show you how they look like
inside the campaigns or inside the
Google ads account so if we move to the
dashboard when we have created and if we
have already been running any campaigns
and we want to see results or any of the
metrics then what we do we go into all
campaigns
and from here we can see all sort of
campaigns created in the past okay
because I wanna see only the results
from the search campaigns because there
are all kind of campaigns been created
here like video campaigns and display
and all so what I can do I can click
this
this law of uh navigation menu on the
top left
and then I can just select the search
campaigns
when this is selected
only these search campaigns would be
visible
now if I just go on any of the campaign
suppose inside
then this breadcrumbs changes earlier I
was only in the all campaigns then I
just selected search campaigns and now
inside the search campaigns I have
selected a specific campaign okay so
considering suppose this was the
campaign I have run in the January for
any of my digital marketing sales okay
or any of my product sales or any of my
services lead generation XYZ objectives
could have been okay now coming to the
main part
from the metrics point of view so we see
here that there are
results been shown of course because
this is a demo account so you don't see
numbers we can always change the dates
like suppose I wanna see the uh result
of last 30 days so I would just go here
and this would show these many
Impressions have come Impressions like
how many times the ad is just been seen
okay impression means just how many
times I had been seen okay then it would
show how many times the ad actually been
clicked okay how many times the ad been
clicked assuming 100 times The
Impressions have come and two clicks
have come so the percentage which is
basically a ratio of a clicks to
impression is called CTR
a click-through rate which is the next
one
clicks impression and CTR okay so
click-through rate is the ratio of
impression to clicks your ad been shown
hundred of times or 100 times probably
but only click today for three times so
your CTR is three percent your ad been
shown
100 times but when you clicked seven
times so your CTR is seven percent which
is a very good number okay anything
around 5 to 10 is good okay we don't get
to see lot of Clicks in our initial days
because people do trust the brands which
are already established but slowly
gradually with the right branding with
the right awareness our click rate
increases our CTR increases okay then
comes your average CPC which certainly
you would see here as well so average
CPC is a price which you actually end up
in paying for every click
okay so there is a bid value bid value
means when you started to create your
account or with a campaign of a search
then you decide for certain keywords
that how much money you would pay for
every click okay that is called a bid
price which we certainly see here okay
and once you start getting the clicks
after running your campaign then the
exact pricing been shown as a average
CPC price okay then comes the cost cost
is basically going to be your
multiplication of number of clicks
you've got with the average CPC you have
paid suppose you have got 100 clicks
today and for every click you paid five
rupees so 100 into 5 going to be 500 or
if you uh understand by the dollars so
suppose for every click you have paid
one USD so for 100 clicks you will pay
100 USD by the end of a day okay that is
going to be your day cost or average
cost you have paid for
particular ad on a particular day that
is also understood by saying daily
budget you have spent okay so if I have
allotted that I would pay 900 rupees a
day and 9 900 rupees a day in the
average of the CPC if I would have
probably 10 Rupees so I will get 90
clicks okay because 90 clicks into 10
Rupees for a click going to exhaust my
900 per day budget if this would have
been 100 dollars
and then 100 clicks multiplied by one
dollar will going to exhaust my hundred
dollars per day okay this is how Google
calculates like for how much uh budget
you want to run the ad for and on
various factors your average cost per
click is decided okay this is the uh
understanding of all these terms cost
per conversion and conversion depends
that how your next step actually been
designed so by Next Step I mean suppose
if I talk about this particular ad only
a person clicks and person reaches here
okay so we can Define the conversions
like suppose 100 people have reached
here on the landing page this means 100
clicks would have happened okay so the
dashboard would say
thousand Impressions 100 clicks one
rupee 100 rupee okay one rupee being the
average CPC 100 clicks we have received
and we have spent 100 rupees but it
doesn't mean that all those 100 clicks
which actually
took the users to the landing page would
have been converted okay so when the
conversion code has been placed on the
confirmation page which opens after the
conversion happens or after the goal
completes so that actually tells us how
many people got converted or how many
people actually uh fulfilled or
completed our objective of goal whatever
it was lead generation sales download
brochure any of the subscriptions any of
the ctOS you talk about okay
so talking about the numbers suppose
only three people or two people or two
users have filled this data okay so the
numbers in my dashboard would be like
1000 Impressions have been shown 100
clicks have come means 100 people have
reached to the landing page but only two
conversions have happened okay and the
cost for all the clicks would be like
100 rupees because average CPC was one
rupee okay so when the conversion is two
then we can say that our conversion rate
was two percent why because out of 100
clicks I was only able to get two people
across the confirmation page or across
that CTA which was a call to action of
buy now shop now or sign up or download
whatever it was that is called a
convergence and conversion rate two
percent cost per conversion can only
also be divided like two conversions
I've got in 100 rupees so my cost per
conversion would be 50 rupees okay my
average CPC is one my clicks been
hundred my Impressions been thousand my
CTA been ten percent how 100 divided by
1000 CT or ten percent I have a CPC one
cost becomes 100 rupees my conversions
been two that's why my conversion rate
is two percent and my cost per
conversion comes like 50 why because
I've got two conversions on the spent of
100 that brings 50 rupees here
I hope this is clear if I have to just
demonstrate
you just wait
so that this is basically you know
uh been captured in your heads with more
clarity so I'm just going to
use a normal example
impressions
the same numbers which I just explained
so that you know
ok so this is Cosmic conversion suppose
your ad received thousand impressions
today 100 clicks have come so your CTR
becomes ten percent because that is how
this is calculated Clips by Impressions
where our CPC was one rupee
or it has
a billion dollars so your cost would be
100 rupees
or hundred dollars
you've got two conversions means two
people or two users have bought anything
or have subscribed or have just you know
completed that call to action and the
conversion rate for that reason would be
2 divided by 100 so 2 percent
and cost per conversion in this case
would be 50 rupees because you have paid
100 rupees for two conversions and in
this case it would be 50 dollars just a
hypothetical number did not be very much
worried about the numbers okay with the
high priest okay this would change
certainly when we do the research of our
keywords
okay
now coming
to the part how now these ads been
created that's the most important part
how we create a beautiful ad copies and
all that okay so we go
into the campaign making by all campaign
and then we click on a campaign
we will click on a new campaign
Google ads most of the time works low
nowadays so you have to be a bit patient
with this and then we click on a create
campaign without a goal guidance or we
can always click website traffic lead
sales okay these all four can be created
uh for the Google ad search campaign you
know we can only use these four for the
search app because if I'll just click
this this will not allow me to create
search and this only allows video ad if
I'll click this this only allows display
and video ad this only allows mobile ad
and this is for the local so if I have
to create a search ad like this or a
text ad like this so I have to be either
creating through sales leads or website
or either without a guidance so I'll
just going to be teaching you all the
settings inside so that you know the
Google ads uh you know search ad
settings in advanced level so I'm just
taking without a rule
then you click search ads
our focus is just to create search ad
you can leave this part right now
because your conversions are not being
created we'll do in maybe in the next
session when we'll talk about the
advanced settings and website visit is
my Premiere goal and suppose I am
running we add for any of these sites
probably I'm running the ad for
thank you
just see if I can get the simple
learning page
so this remarkable search
marketing
just a minute guys
yeah digital marketing
course
click on continue
and then the very first thing you see
bidding which we have just learned that
we pay on the cost per click basis so
clicks
and you can always set up your
bid limit that I do not want to pay more
than suppose one rupee I click or two
rupee a click or five rupee a click
okay and there is another
thing which we have to be discussing
before we talk about the bid limit so
let me just take you to the
Keyword Planner so this comes from here
tool settings
Keyword Planner
so that we get an overview that how much
actually we should be paying for every
keyword we are running the ad for
suppose my keyword for which I want to
run the ad is digital marketing code
that is the Premier keyword or the most
searched keyword by which
the ads of a competitors also are
showing and also I want to show my ad
for okay so what I would do I would just
go into this beautiful tool I again
repeat my steps I can just go tool in
settings
Keyword Planner open in a right tab why
so that your existing campaign settings
are not Disturbed okay you come here you
click this and you click discover new
keywords and you search your term like
digital marketing course
click get results
and then you are able to see
digital marketing course in the period
of last one year in India of course you
can change the country to U.S Canada
Australia anywhere and you would see in
the last one year how many search
queries on a monthly basis have come for
this particular keyword in addition you
see lot of suggestions as well suppose
we're just sticking around one keyword
right now to understand the bid part and
all so we see that we got around 1
million searches in India for this
particular keyword with the competition
of medium competition medium means that
most of the advertisers who are selling
this digital marketing course been
running the ad for the This this term or
not if this competition would have been
high then I should have ignored this or
would have changed the keyword but this
is medium so I would take this and this
you know talks about the bid value this
is the low term and this is the high
term like low price means this is the
lowest price any of the advertisers
would have paid this year for this
particular term to show the ad and this
is the highest bid price which any of
the advertisers would have paid in this
year for this term so they doesn't tell
which part of year it was which
Advertiser it was but at least we get a
fair idea that our bid value would be
around 46 to 195 so we go bit smart
we go on the average price suppose a bit
46 so I'll just go 30 40 over this price
so suppose I take 30 percent around 12
rupees or 13 rupees so that makes it 15
and around 60 rupees so this is the
build value I am aiming 60 rupees plus
what I do I take some of the keywords
which I feel like from a naked eye at
this moment are very important for my
campaign just like I take this I take
this I take this
no you can just take any of them
you can download this data into Excel
and copy paste as well so there are a
lot of ways to do this
okay and then you can certainly
just name the new ad group and they
would be added to it or otherwise it is
very easy
that we just copy them from here okay
there are ways to do it so this is the
simplest of the way suppose I just liked
all these keywords from my product point
of view and I like the pricing as well
so what I would do I would just copy
this
copying this
and then putting into maybe here
so when there would be a space you know
when the campaign would ask me please
tell me for which keyword you want to
run the ad
certainly it would come here when we are
done with these two settings then I
don't have to waste time I will just go
here and copy these keyword and paste in
here under the keywords okay I can take
more but before uh you know the time
exhaust because I have a uh you know in
my head that I have to complete all the
campaign settings and everything within
one hour so that you are not bored of
this and I want that energy level to be
on a higher side so you can do this
research probably and you can also you
know add a lot of keywords you know
dependent on how much you know you wanna
actually leverage from them and as well
more keywords means you end up in paying
your budget uh you know in a very quick
basis so it's important that we
segregate them from the monthly searches
High monthly searches keywords are
always important because the demand is
high and then we always check the
competition should not be higher okay so
I probably would not take these you know
because these are high ones okay I can
delete and I can always aim the low ones
like medium medium medium and medium so
I can just take this yeah okay so copy
and we'll be replacing these
because I got the better keywords now as
compared to the other ones because they
had the high competition keywords as
well so I'm just now aiming the medium
keywords with the higher searches and I
have just decided that I would give the
bid value or a highest bid cap of a 60
rupees because I have just seen the
average that if I have to rank for this
particular one or probably this one or
probably this one you know which are on
the higher side then I should be paying
40 50 extra as you know compared to the
low priced okay so that is how the bid
value is calculated roughly okay anyhow
you would only pay to uh you know
outrank your competitor that's how the
algorithm works like you will not going
to pay high amount it is like if three
advertisers are bidding on a certain
term then if the next one to you is
paying 2 rupee or two dollars so just to
outrank him you would end up in paying
some amount over like 2.1 or 2.2 it is
not like that you would be paying 40
rupees so that's how the algorithm
calculates okay you you put anything as
an account as a bid value but it will
only going to take our CPC depending on
how the competitors are working and how
their pricing is being given okay so
just on a safer side we give our average
price but moreover to save the cost of
the CPC we work on the quality score or
on the quality of our content and on the
ad which certainly is a very important
part okay so coming back to the campaign
making we come here and we give a bit
value suppose of 50 okay this is what we
have seen or other 60 from that
particular you know keyword sheet from
here 30 40 percent over this particular
keyword which is the most important one
for me and then I click next
once this is done then I just select my
Google search Network I don't have to
select the Display Network because this
will going to put my text ad on the
different websites and apps Display
Network are good when we are running the
banner ad because we are just running
the search ad so we're just going to
keep it around the Google search result
and Google sites like Google News Google
Maps Google shop Google YouTube so all
the text ad wherever the placements can
be given so it will going to take
directly we don't put on our search
Partners too because that is again going
to lose the visibility search patterns
are like ask.com AOL newarktimes.com
okay so again you know it is my strategy
that I don't want to increase the
visibility outside Google I'm very happy
in showing my most of the Impressions
around Google only okay or either on a
Google widgets like these wherever the
text ad has a possibility just like you
might be wondering how come I said
YouTube so if I just go here and if I
just type again this so probably you
would see text ads on the top okay
nowadays there are a lot of Tech stats
been running so this is a tech start
okay this is not a video this is not a
banner ad this is the banner ad this is
the text ad
okay so this is coming from here only
Google sites okay then comes your
location you can run the ad on different
locations by you know sitting anywhere
suppose I want to run that for the
worldwide then I'll select all countries
and territories if I want to select
particular country like India or I want
to select multiple countries like
suppose United States
or I want to select
Canada
or I wanna select India too
so I can do this way
Okay then if I want to exclude any of
these states probably suppose I wanna X2
Texas from here so I'll click Texas and
I'll click exclude
I wanna
exclude probably
Mumbai
so Mumbai as a city can be excluded
and probably I wanna extrude Ontario
from Canada
because of XYZ reasons just to explain
the settings I'm doing this so this is
also done
okay then we also can use advanced
search where a beautiful setting of
radius can be worked and the second
advantage of advances tab is that you
are able to see the map so whatever you
have selected like we have selected
Canada and us and whatever you have
deselected or excluded will come in red
blue part included red part X2 did the
same way you would see in India as well
blue part included and this small dot
Mumbai excluded okay plus we can do the
radius targeting here suppose I sell
something within the radius of one or
two kilometers or one or two miles so I
have to just select that part suppose if
I just deselect India right now
and deselect the Mumbai exclusion as
well and consider that I have a
restaurant or a cake shop in Delhi
and probably I will also add this
keyword into my keywords so that that
matches the term if anybody searches
this I have to be seeing the character
limits that's why you have to be always
checking and changing things accordingly
okay then digital marketing Google
then simply learn until
marketing
digital
online course probably if we can get
that space
okay
then going down and we can always see
where we are lacking right now so we
have not very good headlines been added
including popular keywords been there
description works well so let's see what
they give us is the idea like
so they say
we are not given any online availability
brand call to actions okay I'm just
going to play with some of the terms now
so let's just see
from CTA using the ctnr
you can see the strength has improved
learn
I don't know it is actually
pausing my recording again and again and
that could be disturbance for you guys
so I'm just taking some time so that
this comes back to normal
yes
okay so this is how you can add up to
headlines 10 headlines and that would
improve your ad strength and last not
least you can add the descriptions which
are very relevant to the ad copy okay
try to get some headlines or deceptions
here from the landing page okay once
this is done you can just click done
here
and your ad copy is prepared you can see
here very much and click next
and then you can set up your budget so
the budget which we were talking earlier
in the Excel if I have to show you so
you got 100 clicks you have paid one
rupee for every click so you have given
100 rupees per day so this is your daily
budget which you have spent okay so you
can always decide your daily budget by
setting or customizing it you can put
anything though it is showing dollars
but this is INR you can see here this is
kind of a bug which we are seeing since
almost a month now so your average daily
cost which they say like a weekly cost
rather after 41 multiplying by 33
forever CPC price would come to 1382 but
we are giving a daily price so we can
always divide this by seven or you know
by 10 probably so I'm just giving a
rough number 100 okay or thousand could
have been you know 500 also because it's
been given okay
so every day I would spend 500 and
accordingly my clicks you know would
come and then you click next
and your ad goes to review like they
would going to be checking your landing
page they will be checking your uh you
know uh what else the ad copy everything
can be checked and would take some time
I think I just need to change that
let me just keep it
5 am
so this is simpler
and then just click next
and publish the campaign from here
publish
so once this is done
then your ad which can be checked from
here
would go into a review part and it would
say
under review
once this is approved then your ad start
showing and you start seeing the results
like impression clicks and CTR obviously
busy whatever we have talked about
okay so this is all about the hard
making now we can see some of the
important things there like Matrix we
have discussed
all these we have discussed CPC
conversions cost per conversions
CTR the only thing which you'll notice
is the quality score so quality score is
you know completely
um the part at the backend which works
like to improve our ranking so quality
score is something which has been given
out of 10 and when we see a ad which is
already been created like suppose for
this campaign if I'll take you so if I
just go to the keywords
so every keyword been given quality
score out of 10.
okay so if any of the keyword has got 10
out of 10 it means there are three
important elements like their CTR like
how many clicks have come their landing
page and their ad copy is relevant or
not okay they see three elements how
relevant the landing pages how relevant
is the ad copies and certainly they see
how relevant being the ad copy with the
search then only your CTR increases
somebody searches something in the art
shows and if the clicks are high then
the CTR goes high so that's why the CTR
the landing page and the add relevance
has to be above average that's how you
know they Define they don't give Marks
here they give total marks out of 10
here the quality score so above average
is going to be the highest average going
to be the middle one and the below
average is going to be the lowest one
okay so if you have any issues uh in any
of these elements then your overall
quality score impacts okay this is all
the call disco so high quality score
means you end up in paying less and you
get a better value for your money okay
that's I think the last part of it so
Google ad ratings of quality of your ads
keyword and landing pages I think this
is what been given here as well then you
check I have already shown you you check
the keyword which are the timing which
which was the best timing you have from
the ad which were the best locations
your ad has actually got the result from
and then accordingly your ad can be
optimized and can be changed you change
your budget you change your bid price
you change your location you change your
timing you change your headline it all
depends after your ad actually been
shown and then you research or you do
the analysis like you know we are seeing
which keyword is working better which
keyword is having the best of the cost
which keyword is giving you the good
impression to interaction rate like a
CTR then we check the ad copy you know
how the ad is working suppose if I have
multiple ads to just compare if this ad
works better or this ad works better
this ad works better so I would just
going to
be comparing these three ads which one
has given you the better of the clicks
as compared to the other one which has
given me the better CTR or whose CPC was
lesser whose CPC was higher that is how
I will be checking it okay I can always
have number of ads created under the
campaign just like are we right now we
have created one campaign one ad we can
always test with the another ad copy by
clicking this so that we can see which
ads performs better okay that's why in
this existing account you can see
multiple ads so because we were testing
which one works better so this is how
you can also make one other AD copy and
you can just click done and that would
be added to the list of ads okay you can
see now one more ad actually been added
so out of these two which one works
better would be only uh diagnosed or
checked if the ad starts running okay
you can always add your account the you
know money the the billing part into the
student settings building summary
and from here you just need to add your
mode of payment okay you have to select
your country you have to select the
currency you know you are paying in and
then of course you would have options to
pay like debate money transfer net
banking and India paytm qualities also
available very much available
so if you are looking to become a
digital marketing specialist then look
no further than simply learn
postgraduate program in digital
marketing with this you gain all the
necessity skills in digital marketing
like website creation behavioral
marketing keyword research search engine
optimization search engine marketing
campaign management social media
marketing and more with knowledge of
tools like SC ranking hoot suit chat GPT
Google ads Google Keyword Planner Google
Trends and there's much more on the list
don't miss out on this incredible
opportunity take action today and enroll
in a course to unlock the digital
marketing success accelerate your career
and gain the skills you need to thrive
in the industry ready to get started
then click on the link mentioned in the
description box and embark on your
journey to professional growth and
achievement
hey guys
welcome to today's session
my name is Sachin sehgal and I am here
to talk about a very important tool
Google ads and out of all the ads we can
create under Google ads today we would
be talking about a very important one
Google search ad
this is going to be very exciting this
is going to be very deep from my
experience I can say I will going to
take you through a lot of technical
aspects and lot of optimization
strategies where you can really bring
down the cost down if you're really
paying high for your clicks and
conversion so please be with me and I
would try to give you the best from my
site great so let's just start guys
Google ads is something which we have
discussed in the last class if you have
seen my last session if you have not we
will leave the link in the description
where we talked about the basics of
Google ads and we also talked about how
to create this beautiful ad account or a
tool with a free Gmail ID okay
we did talked about few more things that
how many types of ads you can create
just to give you the quick glimpse we
are on Google and when we type something
like if I want to do a data analytics
course
so I would type few things like a word
or a keyword or a query into Google
search engine and then Google as a
search engine would show me few results
the results which we see on the top we
are talking about these today you know
this is the topic or this is the kind of
an ad which we would create today in
this session this is called text ad or
this is also called Google search ad
okay so this is the first type of an ad
you see or which you can create under
the Google ads there are few more just
like if you would go and search for any
of the e-commerce product probably by
winter
jacket
online
so then there would be results but in a
different shape and color and different
structure there is an ad which is a text
ad but on the top we are able to see
some more ads but they are not just text
they have a pricing they have a title
they have a brand name they have an
image of the product so they are called
shopping ads or product listing ads in
addition to that sometimes you know when
you go to a product a website like speed
test and you see the product ads there
but again in the different shape and
color so they are called
display ads because they've been
displayed on different websites and
different apps so why I'm going so fast
in explaining you different type of ads
because as I told you we have another
video created uh with the name of Google
ads for beginners 2023 you can just
check the link in the description and
you will able to get all this type of
ads and whatever the uh you know bidding
strategies to be used in basic in that
particular tutorial or that demo just
has to show you if you can see that ads
by Google so this is the display Adder
Banner right just quickly I have shown
you three types of the ads but our Focus
as I said today going to be on a very
specific ad which
is the most important ad from the Google
ads family okay so let's just begin guys
when I come to Google ads this is how
the Google ad structure looks like
we have a Google ads account created
again I repeat if you don't know how to
create it please find the link in the
description to create the Google ads
account once a Google ads account
created then you would have a dashboard
like this okay in this dashboard you can
see there are campaigns there are ad
groups there are ads there are videos
there are landing pages so a lot of
things can be confusing if we are just
coming to this account or to this
beautiful tool for the very first time
so to just keep it very simple or to
explain in uh in a very simpler way what
I did is I just drawn this structure for
you okay so the structure says that you
have a Google ads account imagine that I
am a simply learned Google ads manager
so I am running the ads for all simply
learn keywords like data analytics
course digital marketing course or any
machine learning course python course so
whenever somebody types this so there is
a ad which shows like from Simply
probably we have to just assume because
currently I'm not able to see any simple
an ad here so data analytics course
India
and then probably we can see if there
are any
you can always change the keywords but
just to test time randomly changing the
words or I could have just written
simply learned specifically because I
want to go with simple learn only I have
researched a lot and I feel like this is
one of the best okay so probably there
is no ad though
still I would check
probably I have to just change the codes
so I will go for the another course
which is by simply learn again and then
probably we can expect any of the ads
running
because this is not a very peak time so
we are probably you know saving some of
the cost not running the ads at this all
hour anyhow so we can assume that this
is the ad you know I am running for so
how we can create this ad how we can get
the best of clicks as I said it is not
the very best time to run the ad so this
is also kind of a change you know we can
bring into our ads by doing some
research so how all these things are
done we're going to be learning it okay
so when we come here to the dashboard
and then we see our dashboard looks like
this a bit complicated so we can be
confused we can be disheartened that I
have created the account by seeing uh
the first video but now I am all stuck
okay so probably I have to again wait so
the wait is over now we are here to
understand the whole structure okay so
let me just take a very simple example
suppose I uh I'm someone who's selling a
shoes okay because I have just said
simply learn probably let's just convert
it to any of the Google ads account of a
shoe seller probably I am Nike okay and
I am making the add for Nike shoes and I
am selling two types of the Nike shoes
today probably formal or Canvas OR
probably I am selling the casual or any
sports shoes and what I did I created
the campaign named it search ad
uh any month you know whatever the month
you have started with supposed November
so November 2022 that is the name which
I am giving name can be changed name is
something which is being put it up for
my reference so that after creating a
lot of campaigns I'm not confused in
which campaign I have to check the
results okay so I'm running the search
art for shoes for the month of February
or November or December 22 23 whatever
and then I open two ad groups into it
why I'm opening two ad groups under one
campaign because I'm selling two kind of
products under the shoes only I am
selling formal also
under the shoes only I am selling casual
also so what happens suppose I would
have just you know created one art group
and would have inserted or submitted all
the keywords of formal and Casual inside
one hat group then if somebody would
have searched a term called formal black
shoes then this ad group would have got
confused that should I show formal ad
shoes or should I show casual ad shoes
because what I did I have just got all
my keywords like formal casual Cricket
shopping jogging party office you know
all the mix of the keywords from formal
and Casual family into the same ad group
the moment any of these six keywords
being typed or been searched on Google
then this ad group would have got
triggered and then again randomly it
would have shown the ad of a formal or
ad of a casual because both of the ads
would have been under this okay but
after doing uh this bifurcation or after
doing this segmentation what would
happen all the formal keywords like
party shoes office shoes formal shoes
formal black shoes would go here
this ad group would trigger if any of
this keyword would search and
accordingly this ad which has everything
related to only formal shoes will be
shown and of course with that ad the
landing page is connected which would be
open you know when somebody clicks the
ad okay and vice versa if somebody would
have searched for a casual term like a
casual shoes sports shoes jogging shoes
running shoes then this ad group would
have triggered and then the casual shoes
ad with all the headline related to that
casual keywords would have been shown
and accordingly if somebody would have
clicked then the landing page of casual
shoes you know would have opened okay so
if this is clear actually you are very
much ready to uh dive into the Google
ads because many people takes a lot of
time to understand the structure because
uh you know maybe they are very much
confused at the art group level but I
have just tried level based by bringing
this example why I am creating two
different ad groups I why I'm not just
going with the same ad group you know
mixing all the keywords
second scenario could have been on a
second permutation could have been I
would have just you know probably
created two different campaigns all
together I would have named The Campaign
one with search ad formal shoes November
okay then only that only this part would
have belonged to the first campaign then
I would have created a different
campaign all together and would have
named it campaign search ad
casual shoes November then this second
campaign or a second campaign can be
assumed here with you know with a green
color would have been drawn okay so this
is how on the structure it works like we
can always now create inside so let's
just see a few things uh before we
create the ad okay very important uh
requirement or rather I would say uh if
being the campaign manager of any any
any any company you name any startup you
name or any client you work with or
probably for yourself as well you have
to be very much sure how these terms
works like Okay so this terms when I
talk about is going to be a bit inclined
towards the search ad today only and
when I talk about the display ad in the
next video then I would you know take
you through about the terminologies and
all the kpis off display Banner or video
ads okay so now if I talk about a search
ad a very important
um term which we should be aware of is
the maximum bid price
okay because we all know when we're
talking about this ad which is called a
text ad then we are paying on every
click okay that's why this is also
called PPC ad this is also called PPC
marketing or you can understand in a
very simple words uh Advertiser which is
Emirates this in this particular ad only
has to pay when somebody like Sachin
this movement clicking this ad I click
this ad I reach to the landing page of
this particular University or this
college and a certain amount is deducted
from this particular ad account and that
certain amount actually decides or
decided on the basis of the keyword
helped to show this ad okay so as an
Advertiser must have paid something to
Google ads for showing this ad for this
keyword okay so when I say a maximum bid
price it means it's a maximum bid price
of a keyword that's why now this would
be easier to understand by this example
suppose I want to run the ad on the term
called data analytics course 2022 what I
did I have opened the Google Keyword
Planner you know I did talked about this
in the previous session but I will take
you through again how you use a Keyword
Planner smartly so I have got this data
from the keywords planner that the
average price I have to pay for this
keyword to show my ad is 5 to 10 Rupees
so what I did I just played a bit of
maths and I have bidded something over
the minimum bit price okay this is the
minimum bit price is the maximum bit
price okay and this is what I've got
from the Keyword Planner so rather than
going for a very high price or the
maximum bit price to secure my position
I want to play safe and what I would do
I would just take a chance maybe 30 40
over the minimum bit range and then I
will see if the Impressions or clicks
are coming or not if this starts coming
it means that my ad is accepted and my
keyword is you know winning in the
auction and I'm able to get the clicks
but if it is not picking then certainly
I have to increase my bid price but
coming back to the terminology is what
we're talking here is once I have set it
up my maximum bit price of seven rupees
then my ad would start showing suppose
my ad shows for 1000 times today and
every time when my ad been clicked you
know certain amount being deducted there
is a competition there are other
advertisers also you know who are
running the ad and after showing my ad
for the whole day Google in the
dashboard just shown that you have paid
average CPC of 5 rupees only so I bid it
for 7 but by seeing different uh you
know factors like the competition the
demand and how many times the ads got
clicked what was the position where my
ad was shown I ended up in paying five
rupees for every Click by the end of a
day so the average CPC sometimes you
know people get confused they have a CPC
and the maximum bit price the same no so
maximum bit price is something which I
uh you know submit to Google that this
is the maximum I can pay for my ad to
show on certain keyword for every click
and I have a CPC something which
actually you know I pay every day or you
know in that average of the duration you
had got displayed or got clicks uh for
every uh click on that particular
keyword okay or the number of keywords
if you have more than one keyword uh
submitted and suppose I've got 100
clicks then you know it's a simple math
that my budget which I have spent today
is five rupees for one click 500 rupees
400 click so daily budget would be 500
rupees and tomorrow if company says I
need 300 clicks then of course my
average CPC which I have from the
historical date of yesterday you know I
would just do my maths and I will going
to submit the daily budget of not 100
rather 300 today so that in 1500 I can
expect 300 clicks at the cost of 5
rupees per click okay so this is a very
simple of the example to just make you
explain how things works you know you
submit something then on the basis of a
lot of factors you know Google
calculates Google gives you clicks and
once you have the data then you know you
can just understand how this all is
working okay last thing before we dive
into the tool is Keyword Planner so I
just told you we have done in the last
class how this works like so we go into
tool and setting and then we go into
Keyword Planner I'll show you in the
account also the Google ads account just
after 30 seconds uh the screenshots over
so your Keyword Planner opens and then
you discover the keyword suppose I am
selling data analytics course so I would
just put my search term data analytics
course and then I'll click the get
result and then accordingly it will show
me lot of options and this is the
pricing I was talking about it gives me
the low price and the high price so I
would take the 30 40 percent over the
low bid price or the average price
between these both and that would be my
maximum bit price and after checking all
the permutations Google would show my ad
or either it would not show my ad also
there can be a chance so I have to just
wait for my impression and clicks and
the results by the end of the day and I
would you know I would know how much the
average CPC actually I'm paying for each
keyword okay so I'll show you all those
reports in a while uh that's it right
now let's just go and see few things so
the Keyword Planner will start with
suppose I start
um you know in researching all these
things my campaign is about data
analytics course
I'm making it for symptom probably and I
would go and I would just try to you
know search into planning my Keyword
Planner and then I will write a term
quickly here you know whatever I want to
show my ad for
suppose data analytics course as I said
okay probably let's check digital
marketing because we would have more
results so it's
easy to understand with a lot of results
because I would be able to tell you how
to sort and filter them down uh digital
marketing course and you can just test
it with any of the keywords I'm just
doing a random check
so once we are here we have a lot of
keywords in addition to what we have
submitted so the keyword which I have
provided is this and the result shows
that it had over 100k uh you know
monthly searches and uh of course in the
range of 1 million in the in the in in
the month of 2021 to September 22 so
this is actually the average monthly
searches happened in between this period
and uh the advertise is actually paid as
low as 44 Rupees to as high 20 224
rupees okay that can easily be uh you
know converted to dollars uh half a
dollar or maybe more than half a dollar
UH 60 70 cents probably and uh this is
like going to be a three dollars cost
okay so what we can do is we can see now
there are a lot of keywords been given
and we can easily sort them down here on
certain you know uh bases like you know
suppose the monthly searches are high or
the bid is low and all that stuff of but
this is quite you know difficult when we
have to sort down here in the Keyword
Planner so what I do is I'm just going
to talk about the same you know like hi
how I actually go when I am working for
my clients okay I have clients here a
lot of clients I don't want to show you
but yeah I have and um suppose I just go
and download this data from here
and then this would be you know
downloaded in the Excel format and we
can just save it anywhere suppose I just
bring it here and then now I would open
the keyword sheet
and I would have a data in my Excel okay
so I need this this one so this is the
most important column because I have to
highlight uh which column is important
and what is not required right now so
whatever is required I'm just I'll be
keeping with me and what I feel like is
not very important as of now I'm just
not going to be taking them so now there
are
five column which I have kept with
myself like
these four where we talk about the
results
okay
this is not required this is not
required so I'm just going to be
deleting or hiding them okay so when we
talk about our competition index value
so this actually tells us that a
particular keyword is how much uh you
know from the competition point of view
is difficult to rank suppose I talk
about two key ones right now let me just
take
um a one with a lower score suppose this
one and I would take the higher or the
highest one probably is this one okay so
now when I talk about a comparison you
know probably uh or or probably let's
say this this one because this has a
monthly searches which are equivalent uh
you know from the compression point of
view they are very different but the
search has been same so if I would stuck
to something of this sorted if I have to
finalize between these two so what I
would do you know that's something which
we are talking here you know if we have
a kind of a combination where we have to
decide out of these two so both both of
the keywords meaning very important if I
would just check from my naked eye a
quick Scan they look very promising they
look very great to me suppose and they
have a equivalent number of searches in
the last you know one year on the
average monthly basis but there is a
difference between the competition okay
now people can be confused what is this
competition so I would just make you
explain in a very simpler way Suppose
there are 100 companies so there are 100
you know ethic institutes or probably
physical institutes who teaches uh
digital marketing because we are doing
online marketing or you know additional
marketing course online so so let's keep
it online uh institutes like simply
learn and all okay so what they have
done is in the last one year they all
have used these keywords to run their
ads you know to show their advertisement
or their digital ad on a Google space
okay when this data has been given so
this is telling me that out of those 100
advertisers or my 100 competitors
66 or a 66 percent advertisers have used
this ad
okay or have used this keyword to show
their ad okay and out of 100 33 or if it
is 100 then 33 advertisers have used
this keyword to show their ad okay so it
brings you know kind of a
comparison to US that probably these two
keywords are very much in demand you
know like equally from the searches
point of view because both have been
searched equally but whenever this has
been searched then there has been a
competition where 66 people or 66
advertisers or 66 percent advertisers
are fighting to show their ad okay and
when this keyword being searched as
equally then only 33 percent or 33
people or 33 advertisers are fighting to
show their ad on Google space okay when
I talk about 100 then that seems to be
okay where my AdWords look like you know
where my ad would show because if I just
go on a Google space you know that only
seven ads are shown when you know when
we go on a Google search engine one two
three and four and then the rest three
would be at the bottom if they are shown
at this moment or not I'm not very sure
so three would be here somewhere so
total seven adds placement on the first
page nobody goes beyond first we know
that 97 of the worldwide audience don't
go beyond the first pagination okay so
we have to be on our first page so if I
talk about from the first page seven
positions point of view it would make
more sense so let's imagine there are
only 10 advertisers of digital marketing
course so out of 10 if I take out 66 66
percent then it means almost like six to
seven advertisers are fighting or have
bidded or probably are trying to outrank
each other to show their ad on the top
or on the first four versions of Google
but when I talk about this then only
three to four advertisers are fighting
or have bidded for this keyword to show
the ad on the first page so this
actually is a very important data
sometimes we just you know Miss it
because it has not been uh I think
explained anywhere else that what
exactly this value is we only go by the
low medium high which is the very first
column I delete nowadays you know I
don't you know go by this because they
both come under the medium but there is
a big difference you know seven out of
10 would have been bidded for and only
three to four would have been bidded for
this keyword so never go by the high
medium or low just go by the index value
okay that's a percentage of The
Advertiser who are actually trying to
fight for the same keyword to show their
ad on the top okay this is how we you
know shorten or we get the best keywords
we try to get the best search keyword
with the you know kind of a index value
between 50 to 60 less than that and then
we of course you know go for the bit
value or a bit price which is also on a
very lower side not a very high price
keyword we go with so this is the
criteria you know I actually follow and
that's something which you know you can
see I have also mentioned here you can
see that much uh you know we go for the
high search keyword and then we'll try
to get the low medium competition
keywords which of course less than 60
index value and then I put a price you
know kind of a price of my price you
know which is like if the low bid price
is 10 Rupees then I just make it 13 by
adding 30 to it so if the pricing is 10
so I would add 30 to it that makes my
price 13 and then I check you know uh if
in the first if the Impressions has come
it means my price actually been accepted
but if any of the keyword my price is
not accepted then I would again revise
the price by 20 30 and then would wait
on the secondary report and that's how
you know I keep changing for the first
two three days and keep seeing the
results and once the you know every
keyword gets pick up and I get the you
know it starts getting the stable
results then I uh just allow the
campaign to work uh you know on the
algorithm and uh you know I I see uh
results actually moves in the positive
direction when you give some time to
campaigns to read and to learn uh you
know from the audience Behavior okay so
this is about the keyword planning which
we have just seen
now moving to again a very important
aspect because campaign making is
something which I've already given you
the you know Glimpse in the last class
so I would again give you today but
before that I really you know wanted
today to speak on all these technical
aspects you know which works at the back
end so that's why my focus is more on
this uh presentation parallely I would
keep showing you the uh you know uh the
uh Google ads other demo and everything
okay so now when we move to the next
part next part is very important from
the
um add algorithm point of view so what
happens or what used to happen uh when
when the quality score you know which
I'm just trying to speak now I was not
there uh what used to happen the one who
used to pay the highest bid price used
to get the first position and the second
one used to get the second position and
the third bidder used to get the third
position so I have just brought into
this table suppose a Advertiser has been
at 8 rupee B10 C 15 and D 20 and when
the quality score concept was not there
so they actually been given the very
direct position this one first this one
second this one third and this one
fourth but they have realized or Google
has realized that the one who is paying
the most is not having a very good
quality of the ad uh his landing page or
the website it's is not working or
probably the pages which is which are
connected are not very relevant and the
keywords on which the ads been shown is
nowhere near uh you know when the
landing page is open so it it was like a
very negative impact on Google when the
reviews been checked and people or the
users who are clicking on those ads were
not happy so what Google did Google
brought us you know kind of um uh test
score or a check which is called quality
score for every keyword we bid okay and
this is only for the server chats that's
why I said all the keywords we made okay
I'll just show you the result on a
client side so when we submit our ad on
the basis of you know different keyword
we bid and the and the strategy we use
and the landing page we connected the
backend so what the system does is
system starts analyzing and starts
checking everything from top till you
know bottom from the start till the end
and I would just talk about the factors
and what impacts it brings is so the
quality score the score which has been
given out of 10 is then been given to
every Advertiser on the basis of the
keyword suppose every Advertiser here is
bidding on the same keyword you know
let's just let's
um assume that they all are running the
ad for the digital marketing course so
what would happen they would check and
on the basis of the you know factors
they would give a score out of 10.
suppose the a Advertiser who bid it for
the least had the best of the quality
score because of the reasons we'll just
going to talk about B got 8 out of 10 4
out of 10 and 2 out of ten so the one
who have bidded the most for the very
least quality score probably the reasons
you know would be more clear once we
talk so how this allow we're going to
impact the whole position system is that
their Google rank not Google position
okay there is a Google rank kind of a
kPa can be understood your Matrix which
is a product or a multiplication of what
you bid and how much quality score you
were able to get so 8 into 9 being 72 10
into 8 brings 80 15 into 4 bring 60 and
20 into 2 is 40. okay so the combination
of a good pricing and a good quality
score got B bidder as a first position
okay and the one who got the best
quality score but still paying very less
from the average price in globally is
you know brought the Google position or
add position to Second and then the one
who was spraying very high but the
quality score was below average which is
a Force 5 6 is average price average
score they've got into third position
and the one who was paying so High
probably would not get a position
because this is the maths from the match
point if you have got these numbers if
the quality score would have been below
5 then the ad would not have got any
position rather because Google always
tries to you know show the ads which are
the best uh for the users you know
because Google always pays very
importance to the users behavior and
users
um you know expectations so and when I
said that I think you were able to
understand more now how the factors you
know which which actually results in
these quality score is
um like relevant score like buy 11 score
means when you type a query or a person
would come here would type a query so he
doesn't know that this is called a
keyword we as additional marketers know
this is called a keyword for them it is
a normal query because they are about to
start a course where they would be
taught about all these things but right
now they are not very aware you know
very much aware of these things so they
are putting a query when they put the
query they want to see the ad or ad
extensions or a description relevant to
what they have searched and when they
see all these three things here with the
search uh you know what they made they
would definitely going to click more and
Google only earns when somebody clicks
so it means Google making Revenue only
when somebody is clicking so from that
perspective also Google always tries to
pay you know or rather give more score
and give a better position to the ads
where all the components of the ads are
perfect are relevant and the ones who
starts getting more clicks in the very
first hour or a first day okay so the
important factor which after the click
is the landing page so when somebody
opens this so it has to be very relevant
to this query and to whatever being
shown outside they cannot just show
anything here which is not relevant to
the ad which has actually been shown
outside so all these you know factors in
combination gives the quality score very
important factor is CTR which you must
have understood when you know we I I did
you know explain the last session the
basic one but if you do not aware of it
so CTR is called click through rate okay
and a click through rate is a ratio of
clicks to impression
okay it is a ratio of clicks to
impression
just a spell check okay so suppose today
when we are saying ABCD so let's see
these are this is the a or this is B and
this is C and I've got you know
equivalent quality score on the basis of
all what they have done okay their
landing page their ad their description
everything is very much common so Google
in the starting of the day you know when
the ad actually started to show for
everyone uh you know giving them a very
good quality score probably of five okay
and when this quality score of 5 been
given to them then the other factor
which actually adds on you know to that
algorithm is the CTR so CTR is I just
told you is the ratio between click to
impression so now they all have a same
quality score but this got 100 clicks
out of the Thousand Impressions been
given today this got 50 clicks out of
the Thousand Impressions given today
this got by any mean probably 200 clicks
out of the Thousand Impressions given
today okay every time this this search
is happening here digital marketing
course so these
ads are very much visible equally so all
got thousand Impressions thousand
Impressions thousand Impressions but
this got 100 clicks this got 50 clicks
and this got 200 Clicks in the very
first hour or maybe in the next two
hours okay so this CTR you know when we
are talking about 100 out of 1000 to 10
percent This Is 50 out of thousand it
means this is going to be five percent
and 20 uh sorry 200 out of 1000 means
twenty percent of the CTR so Google was
actually benefited or made the most of
the revenue and you know clicks have
come from here because it is almost like
a double or a four times of this so
because of the high CTR the quality
score of a force you know every every
Advertiser would improve but this one
would be improved from probably from
five to seven and this would you know
probably from five to five point five
and this probably from five to six so
because of that quality score has
improved and uh you know because of the
high CTR this ad has got so this
position will be changed and this would
you know probably would get the first
page on the second position and at the
end of a day this ad has to pay or
Advertiser has to pay lesser because
it's quality score increase we have just
seen it is you know almost like the uh
you know inversely proportional the ones
who are actually paying or the ones who
are having the best of the quality score
are paying the least one has to pay the
least okay so this is all basically you
know can be checked once your ad starts
running so I will just open the client's
account uh where you can just see this
with
you know better
understanding you would be able to get
out of this
hopefully I am able to show you from
okay I'll just see because I have
multiple
advertisers you know
but I cannot just show for all so let me
just check if I can show you how many of
the older one
just wait it is actually asking you some
verification
okay
it's taking too much time
yeah it's just done now
so once this is done
so I'll just take you to one of the
accounts where
my main focus will just show you how the
quality score report look like and then
you know you will get a fair idea but
all the factors you have to be focusing
to bring your quality score high or two
take your qualities for high
okay
so I'm just going to open the search ads
because we're talking about a search ad
here only and suppose if I just go into
this
Campaign which is of course you know not
running right now but I just want to
show you how you check the report and
all suppose this is the campaign you
have run for and you got 75 clicks at uh
you know
um app with CPC price of 40 peso and you
have just given this much pricing and I
have made it for many keywords but I
wanna see which keyword had got the best
of the quality score and how the
qualities would have been given and all
okay so once you reach to the keyword
report here you know at this level then
you see
um uh you know the kpis or metrics here
which gives the quality score out of 10.
okay you can see here very well and
every keyword being givener you know if
there are 10 keywords I don't know how
many keywords for we've bidded 50
keywords okay and you know you can see
all the keywords here and every keyword
being given the quality score out of 10
okay because their CTR which was the
last part which I've explained you the
ratio between the impression two clicks
got the above average so they give below
average average number average so above
average is best actually for any of the
factors so the CTR is above average the
landing pages above average and their ad
is above average means all are perfect
then they got the 10. the moment
anything goes below average or probably
to the average suppose you can see this
is above average for them this is above
average for them but they're landing
page experience from this keyword point
of view is only average their quality
score has come to 8. okay if you go
further down uh let's see anything where
two of them yeah so here the kids ride
on is a keyword where CTR is also not as
high or as great you know to as compared
to the other keywords which we have seen
and also the landing page is not as
relevant to the keyword so there are two
factors like CTR and landing page has
come to average as compared to the
Android 11s which is above average so
their whole quality score got impacted
which actually came down from 10 to 8
and then seven for this particular
keyword and last not PC if I just take
you to somewhere where
something is below average has come now
one is above average
one is okay we are getting clicks but
probably the ad is still not very much
relevant to the keyword okay so they are
below average above average has brought
the quality score to 6 out of 10 which
certainly would have you know impacted
on the cost and also to the position
okay so this is something which you
would see
when you come here also you can check
one more thing here suppose you have
bidded for your keyword and your bid
price where you are paying for is
maximum bit price let me just see where
that column is
so otherwise I would just add that
column so that you can learn that part
as well
okay
[Music]
just wait okay so this is basically
CPC price is being given in the average
cost 2.50 is the cost for every click
and we got 249 clicks so got 623 you can
just check the maths it's always good to
cross check so 249 clicks multiplied by
the CPC price which is 2.50 rupee would
give you 6 22.5 which is the cost you
know for the keywords
um you know we beat it for and the total
clicks we have paid okay and the
maximum beta price suppose you know you
have got uh the maximum bit price of uh
one rupee and you paid 17 PESA 1.66 and
all and then what happens you wanna
secure your position suppose the very
first page bid you're seeing that you're
getting the position but you're not
getting the first page then here because
this campaign is not running so I'm just
giving you the hypothetical example so
whatever the pricing you would have
given for the particular keyword suppose
we talk about these three keywords right
now a particular one keyword uh I
suppose so this is something which I'm
you know trying to show on a one rupee
cost but to show on the first page it is
saying that you have to pay 1.5 okay to
show on the uh first four positions here
one two three four it is saying that
probably you have to pay 2.5 and to get
the absolute first position which is
going to be the top most it would tell
you that you have to probably pay five
rupees you know you bring one it is
asking 1.5 the first four it can be paid
for 2.53 or this has to be five so you
can always go and change your you know
bid price for the particular keyword
okay so there are ways to do it suppose
if I'll just go here and I just go to
the edit I can change my maximum CPC bit
price for this particular bid or a
keyword like 25 rupee okay because I'm
not changing for all the keywords so I
have selected that particular keyword
and I have made the change to this
particular keyword to five rupee so if
you know the average price was one and I
was not getting the keyword uh from this
keyword the position secured on the
first page or the first absolute
position and I want because this is the
most important keyword for me then I
would just come here and would check the
pricing okay this says five rupees you
have to pay for the top position so I
will just go here edit and would change
the bid price or a maximum CPC bit price
of this particular keyword you can do
for all you know you have to just of
course you know select all of course but
if you would do for all then it you can
really impact your whole budget okay so
try to go for the keywords where you
really feel like it is required and
always go by the quality score it has
you know it has a very good quality
score so I should be paying or I should
be ready in paying uh the maximum price
which actually Google is asking me to
pay to secure my first absolute position
and certainly that would increase the
chances of clicks and certainly if
clicks are there so conversions can be
expected too okay so this is all from
what I've just taught you as of now now
I will just move to the campaign making
though we have done as I told you last
time but I will try to make it again so
that we can quickly see how the Google
ad search ads or the search Google ad
created okay so if I just go to the
campaign uh My Demo
account so if you just go to the Google
ads account the dashboard and then I
would come to the campaigns
I would just click Plus
new campaign
and whatever the you know
objective is you can always go for
website traffic or without a guidance
because this would have all the settings
inside the same more important part is
what we select next so we select search
campaign because we are making the ad
for the search Network you can always
test for website traffic that would not
make much difference and click continue
I will talk about the conversions and
remarketing in a separate session
altogether so we are not doing the
conversion and remarketing today we are
making a normal search ad with all the
strategies we have just understood and
with adding the extensions to the add as
well today okay website visit and
suppose my website is just open safety
learns
landing page
so that I can make the ad for
simply additional marketing as a demo ad
of course not a
mean AD
so copying and just putting in here I
have to just put a you know website
domain that's it I don't have to bring
the whole landing page here and then I
can just name it probably November
search and
and then I will just go and continue
start new
and then I'll just select my bidding
strategy which is going to be clicks
and of course from my Excel I would
learn that okay my bid price which I am
going to be paying uh you know uh is
certainly in the range of something like
probably 50 60 and I have just told you
that I bring my price kind of a thing
into this like I always bring like this
and then
let me just delete all the other columns
which are not required
so this is the sheet which I did
explained to earlier with the index
value and all so my price what is my
price like so I always pay 30 40 extra
to the low bid price so I can you know
just get the formula here like
this
Plus
this 30 percent
okay so that is just going to make it 57
so you can just understand 44 plus 13
going to bring 57 and I can just drag it
and now I've got the average suppose
these are the you know keywords which I
have finalized just assuming so these
are the keywords which I have finalized
probably because of x y z factors such
as an index value and all that and I see
that my pricing is varying from 35 to 89
so maximum being 89 so what I would do
keeping that in my head I was going to
give the limit to my bid price and I
don't want to pay anything extra or more
than 90. okay so this is something which
you can do on this particular level
and then you move ahead and you remove
this because you just want to keep your
ad on the Google search and then you go
down you select your countries you
select your location if you want to show
the ad in all the locations then you
certainly can just go and keep the very
first option open which is all countries
and territories if you want to just show
your ad
um
in a particular country like you know
right now if I just go India so the
whole India would see your ad and if you
want to go for a manual locations like
suppose I want to select any of the
states or cities then what I would do I
would just probably take daily so Delhi
would be targeted like this okay or
probably I just want to Target the state
of Texas here so I just would go and
Target the whole state or if I want to
Target any of the provinces of Canada so
I would just go and take the uh
provinces of Ontario Canada and I would
just Target the whole Province and now
if I also want to go for any of the uh
PIN codes suppose I want to Target to a
certain pin code then I can just go and
Target the PIN codes like this so it is
up to us that we want to go worldwide or
if you want to go for a country specific
if you want to go for us State specific
or if you want to go as a province or a
pin code specific okay otherwise uh if
you suppose
um a restaurant or if you are a you know
somebody who only delivers into certain
radius then you can just leave all these
options and you can go and advance
search
and then you can go to radius and you
can just bring this whatever you
understand better in India we understand
kilometers better maybe the person us
would understand miles better so we just
go and take that two kilometer radius
and probably I am the cake shop in Delhi
so I'm just going to search my location
this is my location and now we're just
going to Target people around 2
kilometer because I don't deliver
outside two kilometers so it's all up to
us how we're gonna go uh this is called
radius targeting or geofencing when we
go to the locations we can also learn
one thing suppose I want to show the ad
to the
um whole country India I have targeted
at the same time I am not delivering in
um uh in in in Mumbai okay or probably
in Karnataka you know Bengaluru where
the city is okay probably I'm not
delivering in any of the uh northern
states like haryana Himachal Punjab so
what I would do I would just take Punjab
suppose for example and I'm just going
to exclude that okay so what would
happen now my ad would show in all these
states and all the cities of India but
just not in Punjab okay so I can save it
that's how you go about the location
language is you know in which language
the users will uses the search engine
and all so you can keep it all languages
that's the best and
audience we don't cater here much
because we are doing the search ad which
actually shows the ad on the basis of
keywords and location only so in the
display ad we're going to talk about
this uh one and that would be the next
video I would create so we're going to
learn a lot of things from the audience
segment in the next display ad and then
the more settings comes where you talk
about the add rotation so add rotation
is already default being selected as the
perform best ad if because the nowadays
the ad actually been created a
responsive and dynamic so when we'll
reach to the ad level I'll show you the
headline changes for every user the
description sometimes changes for the
user what I mean is it's actually
selecting or you know writing this
keyword so probably this headline is
shown to be and after one hour if I'll
come again and put search the same term
so the headline from the same Advertiser
could be different or the description
could be different so that's how these
anime cards works like okay so once you
are done with this okay the start end
date is important and you know the
basics from the previous chapter so I'm
just going a bit faster in here so you
would select the date and then if you
want to schedule this campaign for a
certain period like suppose you don't
want to run on the weekends so you can
just select Monday to Fridays and you
know our timing whichever suits you
suppose just like a very common time of
8 AM to uh you know the late nights like
23 45 and you don't want to run the
weekends if you want uh Saturday Sunday
to be you know 24 hours then you don't
have to put any timing so that goes like
24 hours for Saturday Sundays and then
you click next and you reach to the next
level
where it will just going to ask you for
certain things like keywords you want to
submit and the ad you want to run for
and the ad copy you know you have to
create okay so once you come here it is
the you know work you have done so you
can just copy paste them and you know
bring in there and otherwise these all
keywords are the ones which Google has
suggested you from you know the page
which you have submitted okay so the
landing page is this so I'll try to
change the landing page first so that I
can get more appropriate keywords and
then it would mean to search again on a
scan again for us update keyword
suggestions of course we can always
click on and now the keywords would be
more digital marketing oriented because
this landing page will be scanned by
Google and this would show a certain
results which would of course going to
be digital marketing oriented but why we
don't just uh you know use them because
we don't know uh what is the pricing of
these keywords what is the competition
of this keywords is how much the monthly
search has been so we go by our own
maths we we calculate we do all this
pre-homework on the Keyword Planner
sheet just like we did today and then we
bring them here by deleting all what
they have actually submitted or
suggested us okay and once this is done
then we ensure that our keyword uh uh
you know in the headlines and everything
been used how that copy is created I'll
just show uh you some you know strategic
part of it ensure that your landing page
is correct and it is opening there you
know otherwise your ad would not be
approved secondly always give a display
path display path is something which is
added after the ad or the landing page
link suppose I'm selling online
digital marketing so I would just going
to write whatever I want to show
okay
probably I'll just keep it here
okay so that works okay so now it has
computational marketing and then the
part comes where you know you have to be
thank you
I'm just going to tell you the call
extension once the art is created so
headlines and all so the headline is
something which shows
you know you know the basics so I'll be
fast again
under the landing page link this blue
which actually uh you know brings the
most of the engagement or which actually
appeals the user to click it is
something in blue which is you know
going to be the headline so we have to
be focusing very much on bringing the
best of the headlines here so that we
can get the best of the clicks because
you know once the click increases the
CTR increases CTR increases the quality
score would increase quality Square
would increase your cost you would come
down and your position would rise so you
have to ensure that your headlines your
clicks everything is in you know in a
line whatever we have learned so your
headlines right now has been given these
of course they are not very relevant so
we're going to just bring the headlines
which we feel like are more relevant to
the ad we are showing okay and
I'm just going to get the headlines as a
suggestion being given okay and
we can have more ideas from here by
clicking this so they are not giving any
so we can always have from the keywords
which we have submitted so probably
digital marketing course online
try to get your best keywords here
this is okay this is nice this can be
changed
digital
marketing course
online is not taking so this Marketing
Online probably I'll just take because
course I already submitted and then I
can take few more like social media
marketing I just seen
or whatever the length it would accept
I'll take otherwise I'll delete the rest
this is the one and I should ensure that
I have at least 10 headlines or 12
headlines so six been given and headline
section actually you know been given egg
a half blue and then I would see
headlines which are unique so unique you
should have um uh you know online
availability benefits and the offers and
all or call to action so enroll
register
today
or free demo
then we will talk about
you can see the moment I've added the
headline this the strength has changed
100 plus
tools for free
job
assistance
program
okay so I'm just adding few random
things I'm just not paying much
attention but yeah of course we would
have seen these headlines in any of the
acting companies ads uh include some
popular qos popular keywords could be
your brand name as well so simply
learn
courses online
of hopefully the spelling is fine and
we can batch for
professionals
oh
[Music]
um
just a batch for professionals
and that's it you know because I already
added a lot of keywords a lot of red
lines probably they win so I would just
not work on the headlines anymore uh
I'll see you know if deception doesn't
takes it high then I'll just add one
more but right now the description is
also not giving me the full uh take like
in the headline unique and the headlines
been given so I'll just try to bring the
description so simply an online to do
online that's great that's great so just
try to get something from Google itself
let's see what they have given so I'll
just going to bring this one
okay so that it has been taken from the
landing page itself so that would make a
difference to
uh the quality score simple digital
marketing courses focus on so we're just
going to put
our courses focus on skills
co22
focus on
else like success
so we're doing this one here so that
has been picked up so now you can see
this has also been picked up and the
last thing I would do is now going to
bring some headline uh again you know
I'll just check probably
uh digital marketing
notification I'm not sure if this
headline I have submitted earlier or not
but I'm just going to test it out okay
so
you should
training
so now it has you know come down to good
and uh that's the best you know right
now we can do of course you can take it
further but yeah that doesn't
um matter if you are just stuffing it to
get this one completed you have to just
ensure that all the keywords all of the
headlines are relevant just do not
overdo 10 to 12 are okay okay once this
is done your ad is created you can just
click done and you can click next
and then your budget so we just
discussed about the budget when I was
explaining we'll just take you back so
because you know that your average CPC
price would be around 80 you know
whatever the pricing you have just got
from here if you know the sheet and I
was explaining you so the the bit price
which you have submitted for you know
when I told you is like something which
is in this range uh like 80 90 whatever
it is so you know that bit price would
come down to 90 and you need
um at least 100 clicks today so 90 into
102 mqp you are 9000 daily budget so
because you know that you know you would
end up in paying maximum 90 rupees per
click because that's the maximum bit
price you have submitted if that comes
down to 70 80 60 then of course your
clicks would increase but right now
though being very uh you know hypothetic
hypothetically thinking that okay I
would pay 90 rupees per click at Max
because that is what I submitted so to
get 100 clicks I have to pay 90 into 100
which would be 9 000 your you know
delivers it has to be so he would have
come here and you were just going to
change it set a custom budget and you
were going to bring down 9000 Rupees
there okay so on that yeah average CPC
whatever it would be you would get the
number of clicks if you have a CPC goes
down from 90 to 45 then of course you
are not going to get only 100 you'd
rather get double amount which is going
to be 200 okay once that is done then
you just click next and your budget goes
uh you know your campaign goes for a
review
and then you can add the extensions from
outside okay so they're just giving you
some of the uh you know kind of uh
suggestions so let's see uh there is one
issue in the ad
let me just check that first
let me just see
you can always fix it
with that foot again you're not going to
give you the option of publishing you
know to fix it but it is not clickable
or not no
uh what is the problem
I'll just go away from here you know
sometimes those links doesn't work so
let's see what is the issue
[Music]
okay so because just to do that the
get the limit part I have not given the
space so that is something which is not
acceptable by them
I'm just going to put like skills like
this and
now so these all small things you know
they do
take care of so here only because you
have come down so why not you know just
to see the extension here itself because
that would I'm going to save our efforts
by going from outside so when you see
the ad you see some extensions here like
you know when you have created the ad
right now so you have created on detail
this limit okay this is the elements you
have put it up right now the landing
page the headline the description but in
this ad by emirators you can see more
links like applied to IMS learn how
industry so one is landing page and
three different uh Pages or a sub pages
also been shown in this same ad how they
are done so they are done through the
extension called site link okay so you
can see here if you go down after the
headline there's an option to have the
site links here okay so you can just
click Plus
here itself you know I'm not submitting
the ad because I wanted just to show you
from here itself and then you can go
down because in your case these would
not be given because mine are already
created yours or not so you would go
down and you would create the new South
new site link from here and you can just
give a name suppose download
brochure
and then you can give a URL of that
download brochure page right now I'm
using this URL and I'm just going to be
adding my own made page
like this like this has to be the
landing page which is workable for the
downloading brochure of course so this
would be added and then I can just go
and probably add
um
testy nails
and reviews
okay so somebody wants to read the you
know testimons and reviews of when they
see the ad so you can see that on the
desktop how that would look like so they
would have an ad and then they would
have these four links involved which you
have just seen the Google when I show
new so final URL of reviews can be given
which would directly take them to the
page where the reviews being given and
uh site 2 could be anything you know
which can just see
um industry ready modules or the fee
structure you know the fee structure is
something which people always wants to
just know
from the uh very first glimpse of the r
itself so I can just maybe
take them to the page where V is
actually been you know talked about and
the last could be uh maybe tools
provided
the tools and
certificates
we would get so that can also be one of
the links which people would very much
interested in you know clicking and
checking okay so you would see the the
ad in certain shape you would have a
normal headline uh the description which
you have put it up and then four links
where people can directly reach okay and
then you know this had to be saved here
and you can always see the preview which
I've already shown you but yeah this is
how that would look like so you add
your ad and your four
extra links which actually been added
okay so this is one which you can apply
now
and now your ad has the extensions in
addition to that you might have seen
somewhere that you know your ad as the
number as well sometimes you see the
number being given here because right
now it is not showing any of the ads
with the number but the you know uh
generally have when advertisers have now
raised the numbers in addition to the
headline and everything okay so you can
add that as well by just going up and
you can see there is an option of calls
okay okay let me you can add from here
uh certainly I can show you wow you know
you can just go down and add the number
by clicking your
country and you know giving your number
here it will just be cross checked by
some verification and all so that is
done you can save it so you can see what
actually I was showing you you know I
would just show you
um from outside also that if by any of
the uh you know
um that is done that we have corrected
so you don't have to be you know
uh worried about so if I just click done
so that should not be there if it is
still there I have to check now which
spacing it is actually talking about
um
actually I have unacceptable spacing
contains comma and I think I have just
corrected it but it is not taking maybe
I have to just
um
delete the whole description properly
that would something which
and I would say about time
so you're not adding that description
though
just click done so this is actually you
know kind of a bug because that is
something which has been deleted rather
in front of you so this is not um
taking but I will just click next and
probably this would now be not the error
in which we would see
so you go for a review so what I was
saying I did shown you from outside the
you know the the campaign was created
from the ad itself how the site link is
connected and how the uh call been added
for now the publish campaign you can see
because that ad error actually been
rectified so if by mistake you know you
just forgotten that you have to add the
call number or extension you know which
we just added so but you don't have to
be worried because once you back to the
dashboard you know where you would see
all your campaigns certainly you would
see your this campaign as well in which
you had just created then you can just
go inside the
um add group and then
you can see there is ADD and assets
let me just click that
so there is an ad which you just created
and there's an assets
you know where you could see the
extensions and like you know you just
have added today now we just started
this site link and this number so if I
want to add again or if I would have
forgotten then what I can do I can just
go and take from here suppose if that
call extension was not added there you
know when I just added you would come
here in the assets you would click that
plus button
and then you would just go to the call
and you would see the same kind of a
preview which you have seen inside the
ad when we were creating okay nothing
different it's just like the you know
where you do it you know either you do
when the ad was created or otherwise you
can just go uh let the campaign be
created published and you can come from
outside you can click the add an assets
you can go to plus and you can create
any of these extensions I will talk
about more in the coming you know
tutorials and demos uh and the sessions
but today you know we'll wind up here I
just uh you know wanted to give you the
thorough learning on the Google search
ad with the extensions and also the main
agenda for today was to make you
understand how these you know terms
works like and how the keywords can be
researched how you can bring your own
pricing to the keywords how can you save
the cost and of course to understand how
the quality score works like you can
have a lot of videos on a YouTube where
you can find the quality score of Google
ads working though I tried to you know
bring everything under this session but
still if you want to go for a deep
learning you can always search more and
research more what is email marketing
well email has been around for a very
long time of course and in the very
early days there wasn't an email
marketing service that you could use
yeah you couldn't easily send out
hundreds of emails so what you did you
were actually using the BCC or the blind
carbon copy in your email system to send
out emails to many people of course the
IT department of companies in those
early days they didn't like that because
it would block the email system of the
company so they come up with little
marketing email Marketing Solutions on
the company's Mainframe but it was all
very inflexible you had to take your
email you had to take your mailing list
give that to the guy in the IT
department and if you're lucky then
maybe in a couple of days later your
email would be sent you wouldn't get any
data at all about those emails yeah you
knew how many emails were sent but you
didn't know who would have opened to
email or who would have clicked on the
email
nowadays of course things are completely
different yeah now you have email
marketing where you can use email
service providers who offer you lots of
tools and lots of analytics to manage
and plan and measure your email
marketing campaigns
so what actually is email marketing it
uses email addresses from people to
inform your email list about your
product or service we call these
commercial emails which is completely
different of course from the billions of
personal emails that are being sent yeah
around the the internet every day so
this is a commercial email that you sent
to an email list about your product your
service or a newsletter and what have
you
Additionally you can integrate it into
your marketing automation so you can and
it can help your customers to see your
latest products and offers and you can
obviously use the email list to and
persuade them to buy your book a demo or
sign up for a trial or register for an
event
yeah we call this email nurturing where
you can send a range of emails to take
people through that journey to help them
to make the decision
so what are the different uses of email
marketing it can be used in relationship
building with existing customers who
bought a product for instance sentiments
thank you email it could be to boost
brand awareness it could be about
promoting various pieces of content it
can help you in generating leads or to
promote or Market your products and very
important you can use it to nurture
leads
so what are the types of email marketing
there are a whole range of different
emails that you can send through email
Marketing Systems we'll talk about
welcome emails newsletter emails could
be a lead nurturing email a confirmation
email specific emails to specific people
invitations promotional emails or an
email to do a survey or seasonal
marketing emails so a whole range of
emails you have available that you can
use for different marketing purposes so
now that you understand the basics of
email let's talk about how you get
started with it it's not that
complicated first of all like with many
marketing activities you need to Define
your audience and establish your goals
why do you want to use email marketing
and then you start with one of the most
important aspects of your email
marketing that is about building your
email list and that is the most
important it's a very important aspect
because if your email list is not up to
date yeah there will be a lot of bounces
on your email and your email service
provider may get back to you say hey
your email list is not up to date so we
may actually block you because you may
be spamming your customers you then
choose the the email campaign type that
you want to run you make a schedule when
you want to send out the emails and then
of course you need to measure your
results marketing there is social media
there is
um what's it influencer marketing there
is advertising you name it so they had
to enrich their services and you will
see that when we go into MailChimp that
there is now a whole range of Regional
Services even down to developing your
own website that MailChimp can offer you
but at the core of
MailChimp is its email system so let's
go and have a look into how to use
MailChimp and how to set up your first
email campaign so if you go to
mailchimp.com
yeah you can see here a little overview
of what it does yeah then again we're
going to go into automations I'm going
to show you some of the analytics I'm
going to show you how you can segment
with um with MailChimp and how you can
synchronize with other applications in
MailChimp as well so lots of stuff that
you can do here is a little promotional
video and here is the pricing so you can
see that a free version gives you
limited functionality but it does give
you all the functionality you need to
send emails to up to 500 contacts per
month
yep and then it goes up to 11.70 and
then the premium version gives you all
the Full Features 299 dollars but let's
focus on the free version again that's
what I kind of like often of MailChimp
so let's go into my account yeah so I go
on to
doctor
let's have a look I'm logged in yeah so
here is my
audience
so here you see the features that
MailChimp has to offer
so first of all there is create you can
create campaigns
yeah that is where you run your email
campaigns and where you create your
marketing campaigns a very important
part of your MailChimp is your contacts
or your audience
of course if you don't have any emails
in your database if it were then yeah
then there's not many people that you
can send stuff to so contacts are very
important that you get an email list
that you can connect with your campaigns
there are automations that you can do
which basically means you can send
emails automatically there is analytics
there is website you can create your own
website and modules of it there is
content so that is sort of your library
of assets and then there are different
Integrations that you can do here you
see kind of your dashboard of the
campaigns and this is your audience
dashboard
so the very first thing of course that
you need to do when you are starting on
MailChimp that is create an audience
yeah and that's where you go into your
contacts so there is your audience
dashboard as you see here you can have
all an overview of all your contacts you
can create signup forms that you can add
to your website to capture people's
email addresses there are tags that you
can set to content so you can group your
content into segments and you can do
surveys and there is your inbox if
people send you messages
yeah so lots of functionality but your
first challenge will be
how to get your emails there's lots of
ways to do that first of all there may
be your existing customer database or
your existing customer list you probably
have them in a spreadsheet
yeah so what I'm going to show you in a
minute is how you can enter or
um import that spreadsheet into a
MailChimp yeah so that is one way second
you can actually set up on your website
a form that people can fill in to sign
up for your newsletter for instance
or you can run a campaign where people
go to a landing page and if they
download a certain piece of
documentation then they need to give you
their their email address yeah so
there's lots of ways another really
effective way if you're at an exhibition
for instance have a little box on your
uh your counter where people can leave
their ear their
um their business cards
yeah and then you can take all of that
information and put them in your your
MailChimp so the question here then is
of course how do I bring contacts into
my
MailChimp audience so let's go to all
contacts
yep and then you see I already have two
contacts in my my co
that's the name of my audience
yeah so I'm going to add additional
contacts I can get an overview of my
contacts I can add contacts manually I
can add a subscriber
yeah and then I can just put in the name
yeah so that is Mark at
uh
simplylearn.com and then it's Mark
there is
simply learn don't have to put in a
dress I can get phone number I can get
birthday I can get company name that
would be simply learn
I can add a tag so that would be
training
add or create a tag
yeah that could be training
there's my tag now very important what
SIM what the MailChimp wants to know
that you people that you have in your
database
that you that they gave you permission
to email them yeah they're a very strict
requirements these days for people yeah
that you need to respect your privacy
you need to have permission before you
send them an email
yeah but there's different ways that you
can ask that permission you can ask it
on the website before they fill in a
form you can ask it in your newsletter
yeah so make sure that you have those
permissions because if people get
unsolicited email through a commercial
email campaign yeah in principle that is
not allowed and you may be subject to a
fine the you may have heard of the gdprs
regulations in in Europe and there is
also regulations in the United States
there's regulations in Asia yeah that's
a real tightening of those privacy
regulations when it comes to email
marketing if this person for some reason
is already in my audience then I can
update it will update your profile so
let's click subscribe
let's see
there's probably one
field I ever got
phone number that is 075
yeah so this phone number was a required
item as well yeah and then I click
subscribe
so if I now go back to all contacts you
will see that Mark at simplylearn.com is
now has been added to my database so
that is one way to get emails in your
audience list
the next way is if you go to add
contacts you can import contacts
there are three ways how you can import
contacts you can import contacts from
another service
there's a way you connect with another
piece of software you can upload a CSV
file or a text file and you can even
copy and paste
yeah so if I import from another service
you can see you can import for
Salesforce from Squarespace from Shopify
and there's probably a lot more
Integrations that you can have
if you want to upload a file it will
then basically ask you to upload your
files so what we need to do we need to
create a spreadsheet that we save as a
CSV file so if I go to
Google Drive
and I'm going to actually I already have
a file here
yeah so let's open this file
so you see
that I have these names in there I'm
going to take them out very important
that you add first name last name
company email and all the fields that
are relevant for you yeah so let's say
telephone as well so then we're going to
say the first name is uh Jacob
last name is Jones
company
is Biko
and email is Jacob jones.com
telephone number is oh one two three
four five six seven
yep then the second name is
um Anne-Marie
Carol
and that is Carol
dot com
and that is n
at Carol dot prom and that is 987654
telephone number okay let's take out
that dollar sign
right yes so now I have the file and
this name is MailChimp or whatever
MailChimp one
so the first thing I'm going to do of
course is to save this I am going to
download this file as a comma separated
values file which is a CSV file
and MailChimp wants me to upload this
CSV file into
this field yeah so that's how I can
upload my contacts so I'm going to my uh
YouTube
downloads here is my MailChimp CSV file
yep so there it is I'm going to continue
to organize now the first thing that
MailChimp is going to do now if I'm
wearing any
existing contacts they will be updated
the first thing I can add a tag yes so
I'm going to let's say a member and I'm
going to continue to match that is what
MailChimp is going to do now remember
the first line of our spreadsheet was
sort of the field names first name last
name company name and telephone
MailChimp is going to match those
MailChimp things that the first line was
first name the second name was last name
so these are correct company it has
picked up it doesn't know what to do
with telephone yeah so what I can do I
can edit this column yeah and I can look
at the fields that they have
yes so is telephone in here
I don't hear phone number yeah and I'm
going to link it with phone number
so now it is okay and I can now see here
five columns will be imported and I'm
going to say finalize Imports
yep so now it has added two contacts to
the list so I'm going to say complete
Imports
and if I now want to view my contacts
you will see that my contacts have been
added to my email list
yeah so now I have two additional
contacts in my list
I could also
add a subscriber actually have done a
copy and paste
go back
add contacts import contacts I could do
a copy and paste
so I'll show you how that works continue
yeah so but I go back to the spreadsheet
and I would copy these just copy it
command copy
going back to my MailChimp and I can now
just paste them here just like this and
now
MailChimp is going to analyze this yeah
and it says okay this is what I think it
is and it goes back into that same stage
that we saw in um when we when we
imported the spreadsheet
yeah you see here first name last name
company name and then the telephone
yep now I'm not going to import this
again because we've already imported
these contacts but this is how you
import your contacts
okay
now a few tips on your database
yes very important
are you sure you want to exit this okay
yes so you may build up a list of a
couple of hundred contacts in your in
your MailChimp and that is fantastic
yeah the bigger your list the more value
that you will get from it a very
important aspect of this is to make sure
that your database is clean
yeah people may ask to be removed from
your database people change businesses
yeah make sure your database is clean
when you run a campaign
and you use your email list and there
are a lot of emails that cannot be sent
because there are a lot of wrong emails
in your list
yeah you will have what we call a high
bounce rate
and if you have a continuous high bounce
rate
MailChimp may come back to you and say
hey why do you have such a high bound
rate
and if you can't explain why you have a
high bound rate MailChimp may actually
block your account
because MailChimp wants you to work with
a clean database that is also the risk
if you buy an email list that you don't
know the source from
and if you import it and then run your
first campaign if you get a whole lot of
bounces on your emails yeah then
MailChimp May block your account so be
very careful make sure that your emails
are correct that your bounce rate is low
and never buy
email lists because you don't know what
the quality is of the list
make sure that you segment your mailing
list and then you can within one mailing
list you can send it to your different
segments it could be customers could be
prospects could be
suppliers or what have you
yeah constantly work on growing your
database make sure you don't spam people
always get
um people's approval yeah that they are
happy for you to send them
um emails and of course honor
unsubscribes as well if people ask you
to unsubscribe them from the mailing
list make sure you do that
okay just a few tips when it comes to
managing your database
so now that you have your email audience
set up your contacts setup let's look at
a campaign
let's
when you go into the campaigns here you
have an overview of all the campaigns
that you've run now we haven't run any
campaigns here is a draft campaign yeah
but what you're gonna do you're going to
create a campaign
yes when you click here on the top right
on the create campaign button you have
then did different types of campaigns
that you can order and create you can do
a regular email
you can actually create a landing page
or you can also create an embedded form
yeah that helps you in capturing context
that could be part of your landing page
campaign
but what we're going to look at is
regular emails
yeah so when I click on email I can just
side click here design email
yeah then there is a new email Builder
that you can use and since you're
probably new to Simply learn a new to
um to MailChimp I click straight onto
the new Builder because that is a lot
easier to work with
yeah so here you see it's time to design
your email
yeah I put this little icon already in
yesterday yeah so there's different ways
of doing that here you see sort of your
editor for your email here you can
preview the email here you see your
editing building blocks the layout The
Heading paragraph button Etc here you
can specify Styles and here you can
specify templates for your emails so
here you see an whole range of email
templates
yeah if you click on the creative
assistant that is beautiful but it will
drive you to a premium
account yeah so I'm not going to show
that I want to show you the free
features of MailChimp so let's say we're
going to go for a little design here
we're going to go for this one we could
do preview that's how it will look like
yeah and then we're going to click apply
continue with start with a clean
template
yes so this is how it will look like so
what you can then do start optimizing
the text and the images
so let's do that so here few this email
in your browser that is always good to
have you can change your image
yeah so if I click on that
yeah you see here replace logo yeah so
if I click on replays logo I can then
go to the content studio and I can just
upload different files here and this is
the image that I picked yeah so let's
stick with this particular image here
then I can add a photo so I can say add
a photo I can say upload an image
yeah so if I go to my YouTube I go to uh
thought I had an image somewhere videos
Banner
yeah so here I've added a banner as an
image I can align it left center right
full
yeah I can just line to the right I can
align it to the center left I'm going to
do a full alignment okay and then here
you see my text it's time to design your
email so here I can say
um welcome
to this week's newsletter
in this newsletter
oops and in this newsletter
we will
be talking
about
and then blah blah blah blah okay then
here you see a button and I've added
that I can then just click here first I
click done yeah so the buttons I can
bring in here through my
um
my
built units yeah and here I can change
the button text so I here is book now
for instance
so here I have my social media buttons
yeah and I can there put my own social
media onto that
I can do the same with my Instagram
and I can do the same for my Twitter
I can add another social link I'm going
to leave it like that here's my logo
again then here this will be picked up
automatically every email
will at the bottom have details about
your company about your address how can
people unsubscribe yeah and because
you're using the free version there is
this item grow your business with
MailChimp yeah that is a little bit of
MailChimp branding that will be added to
your email if you're using the free
version so keep that in mind
okay so then you click preview this is
how your email will look like
yep and then you're gonna exit preview
mode and if you're happy with this
you're going to save and exit now here
you kind of have your admin screen for
your campaign
yeah so you see here the name so I need
to type in the name
so I'm going to name it is MailChimp
demo for instance and I'm clicking save
then here I have selected all the
contacts so I can just go to my audience
I pick the audience that I've created I
can then have all my subscribers or I
can pick certain segments or tags in my
subscriber base I can personalize the
two Fields yeah and then I click save
here is the from so that is it's from me
or you can edit that have it from send
from somebody else you can add a subject
now your subject line of course is very
important in email marketing because in
the subject line people will when they
read the subject line people will decide
whether or not they will open the email
yes so the subject line always has to be
catchy so when it could be five reasons
why you shoot read our latest
email newsletter
newsletter
yeah or any other subject line but they
are they need to be short and sweet yeah
you could use emojis you need to in that
one line you need to give people the
reason why they shoot open this email
preview text appears in the inbox after
the subject line yeah so in today's
newsletter
we will talk
about
social media
and email marketing
for instance and you click save
so that is your subject that is your
content
yep and then here is part of your
contact you can send yourself a test
email
that is always useful to send it to
yourself and check it on your desktop
and check it on your mobile so I send
myself a test email send a test to any
email yeah so let me quickly check here
my Gmail
that is uh
to me
that is tube for Mark
okay so I'm going to send that email to
tube for Mark okay I can send it to
multiple people and I'm going to click
send test
email has been sent
so let's check the email so here we see
the email test five reasons why you
should read our latest newsletter
and then here you see the email and then
you check it on typos you check it on
the links that are in there yeah make
sure that your social media buttons work
etc
and if you're then happy with your email
you can then publish it
yeah and there's two ways of publishing
it you can schedule it
when you schedule it you can set a
delivery date and a specific delivery
time but in order to use that feature
you need to upgrade to Premium
okay so you can send it directly
so when you click Send it will go
straight to it
yep so very important or you can say
finish later if you don't want to share
your campaign you see here the link for
the campaign
yeah and you could change that
your default campaign URL yeah so
MailChimp generate randomly five reasons
why you should read our email if you
upgrade to premium you can turn this
MailChimp into your own URL
okay good and then you can track your
your campaign your email campaigns but
um we'll printable usually we'll cover
that in a in the next video on on
MailChimp when we go into more advanced
features okay so I'm just gonna click
finish later
and if we're now having our list of
campaigns then here you see we have our
MailChimp demo as a draft ready to be
published
so that is the so that is the campaigns
how to create a campaign on MailChimp
right now let's have a look at a few
more things so first of all a new
feature in MailChimp is the analytics
when you send out an email campaign you
will get basic analytics here in your
campaigns dashboard as well but
MailChimp now also has an analytics
dashboard
and here you see the type of data that
you will get in MailChimp and it is
using sample data so we can explore the
dashboard so here you see number of
emails sent whether it's up or down you
see the number of people or the
percentage of people that opened the
email
and very important the actual percentage
of people that clicked on the email or
clicked on the link in the email and
that is very important yeah so that's
where you can really follow through on
your email campaigns yeah on who opened
it who clicked it to the form the
phrases that needed to be filled in so
very useful information that you can get
out of your campaign and you can see
that from various periods yeah you can
even actually in the other reports you
can actually see who are the people in
my
mailing list in my audience who actually
clicked on the email and who are the
people who opened the clicked on the
link
and then you can approach them
separately
yeah so here you see engagements
email sent and the click rate
yep so here you see by email the number
of recipients the open rate The Click
rate the revenue that you made
if you had that set up so lots of data
that you can get on your email campaigns
open rates are very important and they
differ by industry yeah and general and
the open rate
anywhere between up to 15 percent and
higher are usually good open rates
okay so that is the analytics that you
can get and then finally what I really
like in MailChimp is that you can use
MailChimp to create landing pages so if
I'm going back to my campaigns
and I'm going to click create campaign
then I can also decide to create a
landing page
name of the landing page is Michael
select an audience Michael and I'm going
to click begin
yeah and here you see
a number of templates that I can use for
my landing page
yeah so very simple templates so let's
take this template
except
I'm going into the editor
yeah so here is the editor for the
landing pages I can add text I can do
box text I can add dividers images I can
change the text
yeah you see here band mates that is the
logo I can change the logo
yeah so I can replace the logo and I can
edit a logo and what hit you I'm just
going to stick with this text for the
time being and here is my email address
form yeah and the beauty about it when
people fill in their email address in
this form it will automatically be added
to my mailing list
in MailChimp so that is a very powerful
feature I can also create this as a
separate form
Okay so
so here you see the available fields
that I have email I can add first name
if I want to yeah I can add last name
and I can add phone number as well
yep I can then go to the settings
I can do the style different styles that
I can have so this is my sign up form
yeah the button text is subscribe I can
then also send visitors to a
confirmation message
I can preview the confirmation message
success you've been added to the
audience
yeah exit preview
yep and that is my sign up form and
again it will automatically be added to
my campaign email list and I click save
and close
yep and here is the full campaign
yeah and when I'm happy with it
I can click save and close
so here is my landing page
and it's now
here I have the page title and site icon
here's the social share preview here is
the URL of mic and my landing page here
is the contents
and I can then get my
finish it later or I can publish it and
as soon as I publish it
this URL will be live
yeah so click publish
so this landing page is now live
so if I now go to this landing page
yeah so here you see email address I'm
saying uh
Sherry
oh
Cherry at henry.com
com and that is
cherry
and I'd say subscribe
so now let's check the litmus test if I
go to my contacts and I'm going to all
my contacts
and here we have cherry Henry the famous
Arsenal football player who has just
joined my mailing list so that is the
power of MailChimp so if you're looking
to become a digital marketing specialist
then look no further than simply learn
postgraduate program in digital
marketing with this you gain all the
necessity skills in digital marketing
like website creation behavioral
marketing keyword research search engine
optimization search engine marketing
campaign management social media
marketing and more with knowledge of
tools like SC ranking hoot suit chat GPT
Google ads Google Keyword Planner Google
Trends and there's much more on the list
don't miss out on this incredible
opportunity take action today and enroll
in a course to unlock the digital
marketing success accelerator career and
gain the skills you need to thrive in
the industry ready to get started then
click on the link mentioned in the
description box and embark on your
journey to professional growth and
achievement imagine it's the year 2004.
this is Phil Phil's looking to release a
book and set up a Blog he's sure that
it'd be successful but he's only worried
about one thing he doesn't know how to
ensure that his book reaches the right
target audience who could enjoy his book
during that period of time however there
were only a few forms of advertisement
available like print ads Billboards
radio Direct Mail direct sales and the
television all of these options were
pretty expensive their effectiveness
couldn't be accurately determined and
they didn't let him advertise his
content to the appropriate audience
Phil's book would never find the
audience it deserved now let's have a
look at the same scenario in the present
day alongside traditional forms of
advertising Phil would have access to
digital marketing the form of marketing
that's a lot more lucrative inexpensive
and configurable marketing that would
enable marketers to advertise Their
audience digitally using channels like
search engines websites social media
platforms emails Etc among these types
social media marketing cotfield's eye
social media marketing would give Phil
the opportunity to take advantage of
social media platforms to advertise this
content to a highly targeted audience it
would help more people learn about this
book increase the interaction with his
audience It's relatively inexpensive
unless he goes into advertising and will
help him get Marketplace insights that
might help in understanding his audience
preferences better Phil started by
taking up a certification to learn about
social media marketing since he was
already familiar with the concept of
social media marketing his next step was
to learn about the different types of
content he could post on social media
some of the most common forms of content
that Phil could post would be images
text posts polls and videos
but over time Phil begin to notice that
not a lot of people were being exposed
to his content Phil needed to advertise
his content for that he would need to
use the advertising options provided by
the social media platforms like Facebook
Instagram YouTube LinkedIn and Twitter
most advertising platforms offer users
with a number of different options like
image ads these ads involve the use of
single or multiple images that are
attractive and have the optimal amount
of text they also have a call to action
that encourages user interaction Phil
could use images from his book advertise
websites that sell his book and more
then there are text and post ads these
ads could advertise posts or excerpts
from Phil's blog or his book further
garnering interest from an interesting
audience
he could also use video ads Phil could
use video ads that feature favorable
reviews and customer testimonials to
advertise his books Phil could also use
lead ads through which he could collect
information from users who are
interested in a Weekly Newsletter or
regular updates from his blog but that
wasn't the only thing Phil could do with
social media platforms he could create a
brand for himself and drive audience
interest to it engage with them create
an identity engage with content finding
content that works for him social media
platforms also allowed him the
opportunity to Target audiences based on
demographics like their age location
gender and much more and in time Phil
began to see an increase in the number
of viewers coming to his social media
page and by extension his blog he also
saw an increase in the number of people
who bought his book greatly increasing
his audience here are some things he
learned one to set goals that were
quantitative smart and follow a constant
deadline two to understand his audience
by engaging and connecting with them
three to set up a social media calendar
to plan competitions polls surveys
videos and more
4. using tools like buzzsumo IFTTT
buffer and more for lead generation
creating email lists setting buyer
personas and more
5. to perform visual storytelling with
the help of images and videos but how
did Phil get so good at Social Media
Marketing
before we find the answer to that
question let's have a look at a quiz
what can you do with social media
marketing
a create a brand for yourself
B engage with an audience
C Target users based on demographics
e all of the above choose the right
answer and have a chance to win an
Amazon voucher
now back to our question how did Phil
get so good at Social Media Marketing
Phil taken up simply learns digital
marketing course it was thanks to this
course that Phil had the skills and
training to get good at social media
marketing and now you can too by
clicking on the top right corner and
with that we've given you an
introduction to all the major concepts
of social media marketing okay so let's
have a look at what social media
marketing actually means what is it yeah
and we got to put this in the context of
the definition of marketing
yeah I studied Marketing in the very
early days in the 80s and my main sort
of Guru in marketing was Philip kotler
and over the years marketing has sort of
developed from traditional marketing to
online marketing but to basic concept
has not changed if you look at the
definition of marketing it's the
activity of creating
communicating
delivering and exchanging offerings
that have value for customers
yeah so you supply you deliver you
exchange products or services that have
a value for your customers
so two very important aspects here there
is value and there is customer and that
is what we capture in the marketing
concept you put the customer at the core
of what you do
yeah because when you do that you
automatically will look at what value
are we giving to the customer
yep so take social media marketing in
that context
then the second part of the social media
marketing
sort of term is the word social media
what is social media when I explain
social media I'm using the three C's the
three C's of social media marketing and
they are content they're community and
campaigns
content is the fuel of your social media
content is the
um the currency of social media if you
have really good content that you can
share on the internet
you're using various multiple multiple
social media channels like Facebook like
YouTube or like video or like Instagram
or blogging you name it yeah people will
engage with your content
and then when people start engaging with
your content they may come back for more
content that you supply and they will
then become part of your community so
Community is a very important aspect of
your social media definition
with really good content you can create
communities
and then you can push that process by
running campaigns
yeah and a campaign makes it relevant
for businesses
because when you run a campaign you have
a goal for your campaign you have an
objective you have a star date you have
an end date
yep and that is what social media
marketing is it's all about running
campaigns
to develop your communities with really
exciting content
and then you put it into the marketing
context you do that if it's a customer
in the core of what you do
yes so if I then take that to a
definition of social media marketing
is
very basic it says the use of social
media to develop a company's brand
increase website traffic and boost sales
that is what we call social media
marketing
yeah the most important aspect here is
that you need to have an outcome you
need to have a result which is customer
related
and that is where the sales element
comes in you do this to get the customer
to do something and in the end that is
buying your product or your service
yeah so social media marketing is not
the technical
combination of your social media
networks you had to
um to reach as many people that needs to
be a goal to it and when we talk about
marketing it comes down to selling your
product or service with a value
yeah so that HD
um kind of the call to action as it were
that comes out of your social media
marketing so keep that in mind
everything you do with your social media
marketing in the end comes down to
reaching your goals or achieving your
objectives of developing your company's
brand increasing website traffic or
growing your sales
now a big benefit that you're getting
these days in digital marketing and
social media marketing is data
is intelligence
is knowledge
in the early days of marketing the
biggest problem has always been how to
measure the success of your marketing
campaigns if I ran adverts in a magazine
how do I measure the effectiveness
if I do a PR campaign and they write
about me in the newspaper how do I
measure the effectiveness of that how
can I track that when somebody buys a
product it actually is as a result of
the pr campaign that I ran
so in the early pre-internet days yeah
we the only way to measure
customer engagement as it were were
through Loyalty cards or credit cards
yeah with a loyalty card you had some
basic customer data through credit cards
you could track transactions but it's
very difficult to relate it to your
marketing then the internet emerged and
all of a sudden I could track traffic to
my website
yeah I could see how many people visit
my website are these people that visit
my website for the first time are they
returning visitors what are the most
popular pages that they see how long do
they stay on my website and are they
actually buying my products
yeah so that was a major advancement of
marketing in the early 2000s and then
when social media emerged it all of a
sudden became possible to measure
engagement
how many people are having conversations
with us I could even measure sentiments
are people positive about my brand are
they negative about my Brands I could
track the effectiveness of my marketing
campaigns
I could measure the effectiveness of my
advertising campaigns that I ran online
so today's reality is that we can
measure everything we can measure clicks
we can measure transactions we can
measure engagements we can measure
return on investments
yeah and we can now even take that a
step further through artificial
intelligence that we can actually start
making predictions how people may
respond to campaigns that we're going to
be running
so now Having learned about these sort
of fundamentals of social media
marketing let's now have a look at how
do you put together your social media
marketing strategy how do you set it up
how do you develop it now with my over
40 years of experience in marketing
digital marketing and social media I
developed a simple five-step methodology
to set your business or to set up
yourself for social media and it's
called flirt
yeah and flirt is an acronym
flirt the first letter the f is for
focus
yeah and in the focus phase what you do
you look at various things the first
thing you do in developing your social
media marketing strategy is look at what
is your niche
what Market are you targeting
and the more you focus in your Market
your targeting your Niche the easier it
will be to reach them
yes so it's very important that you
focus on a very particular niche
once you've identified that Niche you
look at your positioning
why should they buy from you what is
your unique value proposition remember
the definition of marketing yeah the
value for your customer is key in this
and you put it in what we call a
positioning statement
you also look at your customers you
create customer personas
where you look at your customers and you
kind of map their interests their pain
points the typical questions that they
would ask so you get a good
understanding of your your customers
yes or you look at your Niche you look
at your positioning you look at your
focus I'm sorry you look at your
customers
yep and then you're going to ask
yourself why am I going to use social
media
yeah am I going to use it to build
awareness am I going to use it to drive
traffic to my website
am I going to use it to generate sales
am I going to use it to improve customer
service
am I going to use it to recruit new
staff am I going to use it to
communicate with my
um my employees
yeah so lots of reasons why you could
use social media and it's your challenge
to identify one or two objectives for
your social media
and then a very important aspect of your
social media marketing strategy even
your overall digital marketing strategy
what are the key words that you will be
focusing on
in other words what are the keywords
that you want to be recognized
recognized for Google wants to know
Facebook wants to know LinkedIn wants to
know and it's all about repetition the
more often you use those keywords the
more those social media platforms and
Google will associate you with those
keywords when people search for them
they will then show you how you're up in
the search results we call this search
engine optimization or search engine
marketing
yeah so keywords is like a whole course
in itself
but it's very important part of your
social media marketing strategy in the
focus phase
so that is the F for Focus think about
your Niche your positioning who is your
customers why are you on social media
and what are your main keywords
the next is the L for listen
listen is so important
yeah we tend to
talk too much
yeah where social media
can give you fantastic listening
opportunities
and when I say listen I mean read
articles online
listen on Facebook and on Twitter on
LinkedIn listen on Google
yeah watch videos listen to podcasts
there's dozens of ways that you can
listen online because when you listen
you learn and when you learn you get
better and you develop
so what does that mean from you some
practical tips when it comes to
listening first you need to listen to
where your customers hang out
are your customers on Facebook are they
on Twitter are they on LinkedIn and
later in this session when we go through
the various social media platforms I'll
give you an overview of what type of
people are on the various social media
platforms
the next thing that you want to know
when you listen is who are your top 10
bloggers or influencers in your Niche do
you know your top 10 bloggers do you
know your top Instagram influences
because you want to learn from them but
you may also want to build relation with
them
to use them in your marketing Outreach
you also want to look at the trends in
your Niche Google Trends is a really
useful tool that you can check to find
out what are the trends in your niche
and you're looking at your competitors
and your customers what are they doing
what are they talking about
yes so a very important stage and if
you're doing it properly you would
actually set up a social media listening
dashboard where you bring all your
listening channels together in one
dashboard
and then instead of having to go to all
those social media networks or websites
you let them come to you
Inno reader is a very good dashboard
online dashboard a free dashboard that
you can use for this
we're then looking at the I for
integration yeah so you know your
strategy you know where your customers
are you know which social media Networks
you're going to focus on then you're
going to integrate them you're going to
set up your social media Networks you're
going to make sure the branding and the
profiles are consistent you're using
your keywords you're going to create
your content calendar
and you're going to set up your blog
blogging is very important in social
media marketing because it is the
easiest way to start creating content on
your website
and to start sharing that content
through your social media channels that
will then drive people back to your
website
yes so that is part of the integration
stage and then once you've got that all
set up you're then going to reach out
it's very important that you reach out
because if you're not reaching out then
people won't find you people won't see
you yeah the whole essence of social
media marketing is that you create as
many touch points as possible on the
internet for people to find you
yeah where they start engaging with your
content going back to your website want
to know more about you want to know more
about your content and you start
building a relationship that may then
turn into a sale
so reaching out you're going to start
sharing your content you're going to
repurpose your content so turn your blog
post into a video or into a carousel or
turn your video into a podcast or what
have you
yeah you're going to share other
people's content there's nothing wrong
with sharing content from other people
and you're going to run
campaigns
campaigns to push your content in the
channels
yeah and campaigns nowadays are no
longer sort of just posts on social
media it is a combination of organic
posts
yeah where you just share your posts on
social media could be paid like
pay-per-click advertising or it could be
influencer marketing style
reaching out yeah so very important is
the reaching out stage and then of
course tracking is the icing on the cake
as it were when you track you measure
your online reputation you measure your
conversions you measure your social
media activity and engagement you're
meshing your Roi and you plan for your
next quarter so if you're looking to
become a digital marketing specialist
then look no further than simply learn
postgraduate program in digital
marketing with this you gain all the
necessity skills in digital marketing
like website creation behavioral
marketing keyword research search engine
optimization search engine marketing
campaign management social media
marketing and more with knowledge of
tools like SC ranking hoot suit chat GPT
Google ads Google Keyword Planner Google
Trends and there's much more on the list
don't miss out on this incredible
opportunity take action today and enroll
in a course to unlock the digital
marketing success accelerator career and
gain the skills you need to thrive in
the industry ready to get started then
click on the link mentioned in the
description box and embark on your
journey to professional growth and
achievement welcome to Simply learns
YouTube channel and in today's video we
are going to be talking about Facebook
advertising
we're going to talk about how businesses
use Facebook advertising how the what
are the benefits they can get from it
we're going to show you with a demo on
how to set up your Facebook advertising
and we will close today's session with a
few do's and don'ts of Facebook
advertising but before we go into that
make sure that if you like today's video
or if you like the simply learn Channel
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
below and if you liked the video feel
free to like it and share it with your
friends so let's get started
today's world has changed dramatically
when it comes to reaching your audiences
fact is that everybody is trying to get
the attention of the million of
prospects out there in the market
everybody is screaming try my product
try my product or try my product but
most businesses they now have to realize
that today's customer has changed yeah
today's customer is looking for instant
gratification they want a product now
wherever they are whatever their device
that they're using yeah and they can
prop they can Source their products from
everywhere in the world yeah but it is
your challenge to make sure that when
they are in the buying mode that you are
there to help them it's a new economy
out there it's a service driven economy
look at products like Uber or Airbnb
where a whole new ecosystem has
developed of people offering their
products their services to a global
audience in marketing terms we're using
a term called solomo standing for social
local and mobile
yeah when you bring those three elements
together of social media local marketing
and mobile marketing you stand a really
good chance to connect with your
customers at the right time
Google has summarized this in what we
call Google moments on average people
have a couple of hundred moments during
a day where they grab their mobile phone
to do a search on their mobile phone
they maybe want to buy something they
want to book something they want to
share something they want to learn
something all those little moments or
opportunities for you to connect with
your customer or your prospect and
that's your opportunity but that's also
your challenge to make sure that you are
there
when your customers are having those
moments when they scream I want your
products and there are plenty of
channels that you can use to reach those
customers yeah we know about social
media we know about your website there's
things like influencer marketing there's
email marketing and there's more and
more competition out there that are
trying to use those channels to reach
your audience but fact is there is one
channel that really stands out of all
these channels and that is pay-per-click
advertising
pay-per-click advertising is a well
established part of what we call the
digital marketing Trifecta and this
Trifecta consists the word triceps of
three components owned paid and earned
yes so the old is your own website are
your own social media profiles in your
social media pages
but owned is no longer enough you need
to supplement your own media with paid
media and this is what we call
pay-per-click advertising
and then the third element of the
digital marketing Trifecta is what we
call earned media and earned media is
where you can still use that powerful
um effects of public relations in an
online world or where you can work with
influencers to help you develop your
online presence and connect with your
audiences
but one of the best ways to start
getting to your audiences is to use
advertising
yep and there are various platforms for
advertising there is
um Google yeah there is Google search
advertising Google display advertising
and there is Facebook advertising now to
put these two in the context Google did
about 210 billion dollars of Revenue in
advertising in 2021 Facebook is about
half of that 115 billion dollars in 2021
and the most powerful models for
advertising are search ads and display
ads yeah so with search ads is in the
Google search which is what Google the
offers the display ads and video ads are
offered by Google and by Facebook
and we call this pay-per-click
advertising which means you're not
paying for showing your ad but you're
paying when people click on your ads
okay so let's have a look between uh to
this advertising in a bit more detail
you have Facebook advertising was
introduced on around 2007.
yeah so
um in 2007 it was launched by Facebook
yep so but it has grown drastically
since then in 2011 ads were being shown
in the news feed yeah Google a Facebook
called it sponsored stories in 2012 ads
came on the mobile yeah mobile ads are
now considered the most powerful
um forms of pay-per-click advertising in
2014 a Facebook introduced a three-level
advertising structure which was very
much introduced by Google as well where
you have campaigns you have ad sets and
you have your ads and when you go in
setup and you'll see that later your
your ads in Facebook you will have to go
through these three ad elements
campaigns ad sets and ads to set up your
advertising on Facebook
in 2016 in 26 sorry in 2016 Facebook
introduced chat Bots and ads in
messenger which became a whole new area
for advertising for Facebook yeah
connecting with
um customers on Facebook messenger and
offering that for advertising as well
and in 2018 there was a whole range of
AD formats available on Facebook from
videos stories messenger Carousel
slideshows collections so a whole range
of ads to choose from when you start
your face setting up your Facebook ads
now what is the future yeah what does
the future hold for Facebook advertising
as you may have read
um that both Facebook and Google are
having a lower Revenue in their
advertising given the whole world
economic uh situation we're slowly
moving towards a a recession even yeah
Facebook and Google and Microsoft all
the big Tech players are feeling the
impact in that yes so that is one
Element now one of the other reasons why
Facebook's Revenue has gone down in
advertising HD tracking capabilities and
a lot of businesses they track people
when they visit their website and then
you can Target them with ads we call
this retargeting in marketing terms now
Apple has announced
um earlier this year that on iOS people
can say which is on the iPhone people
can decide to not being tracked yep so
that has put a whole sort of kind of a
um a a a a
different set of Dynamics in Facebook
advertising on the iPhone and it is not
as effective as it was before that
announcement from um from Apple
so the future of advertising is all
about security it's about privacy and of
course in the end it all comes down to
how good are your ads how what is the
quality of the content in your ads are
you able to stand out from the crowd
yeah so those are the big challenges in
Facebook advertising now you have to be
aware that Facebook advertising is
completely different than Google search
advertising
you have to put it into a context Google
search advertising is what we call
intent based
yeah so when I have a question or I'm
looking for something or I need a
plumber I go to Google Search yeah and I
search for plumber near me and Google
will give me some ads with plumbers near
me
that is not the way Facebook advertising
Works Facebook advertising yeah is not
intent based it is basically it is your
challenge when you advertise on Facebook
is to stop the user from browsing and
click on your ads so it's more
interruptive you need to make sure that
they stop what they're doing which is
much more difficult
yeah so you'll see that Facebook is
therefore slightly more challenging to
actually generate leads yeah to get new
customers
Google advertising is much better for
that but Facebook advertising is much
better to reach a global audience very
targeted yeah and work on awareness
developing your proposition helping your
prospects to go through the buying cycle
yeah so Facebook ads they help spread
product and brand awareness in a news
feed or on Instagram or on messenger to
a very specific targeted audience
now another element which is important
to understand when it comes to Facebook
advertising is to do with Organic reach
when I have a Facebook post and I do oh
sorry when I have a Facebook page and I
do a post on my page the people that
will like my that have liked my page
will see my post on their news feed
that's how the theory
is yeah of course not everybody will see
those posts because that wouldn't work
because then you would get way too much
advertising in your feed yeah so
Facebook is very selective in the number
of posts from advertising from
businesses or sorry from businesses that
will show on your news feed
yeah and in fact that percentage of
people that will see your posts your
business posts on their personal news
feed is less than three percent so again
if you have a Facebook page let's say
with 10 000 followers and you do a post
on your Facebook page less than 300
people will see your post
now businesses are not happy with that
yeah they said hey Facebook why are you
doing that I want to reach my entire
audience and Facebook says well hey you
still can yeah but it's going to cost
you some money
and Facebook says you have to go and
advertise on Facebook to reach your
audiences so businesses Now understand
that Facebook is what we call
pay to play
you to reach your audiences you have to
supplement your organic reach with
advertising
and the beauty about Facebook
advertising is that it is a fantastic
way to reach your target audience
and that is the biggest benefit that
Facebook advertising can give you it's
all about the targeting there is so many
targeting options in Facebook and I'll
show you when we go into the short demo
on how to set up your ads so what are
the reasons why businesses go into
Facebook yeah what are the reasons what
are the benefits that they will get from
it and the first big benefit that they
get is that they get access to an
audience which is out there
yeah and it is not just a small audience
we're talking about Facebook at as of
today as close to 3 billion active
monthly users that there's a massive
numbers and most of these people they
check their profiles at least once daily
so it is a huge audience to reach and
there is no better social media Network
to reach a global audience than on
Facebook
yeah so that is one of the reasons why
you want to start advertising on
Facebook the second reason one why you
want to start advertising on Facebook is
that Facebook gives you a fantastic
platform to advertise your products to
People based on their demographics based
on their interests based on their
location based on their
um their history of browsing based on so
many different segmentation factors
which means that you can make sure that
your ads reach the Right audience
which is a really good benefit that you
will get from Facebook advertising
the next benefit that you get from
Facebook advertising is that it is very
cost effective
yeah you can just start with a small
budget you can slowly increase your
budget you can relate your budget to the
returns that you're getting from it so
it helps you spend less and achieve more
it is one of the advertising platforms
with the highest return on investment of
your on your money so very cost
effective to advertise on Facebook
here are some other reasons why
businesses use advertising on Facebook
it really helps them with increasing
brand awareness as I said earlier the
difference with Google search
advertising Facebook is not intent based
people are not searching in Facebook
looking for Content which could include
your ads they are actually browsing on
Facebook and it is your challenge yeah
to
um to be creative enough to make them
stop browsing and pay attention to your
ads so it really helps in increasing
brand awareness it's let it's an
opportunity for you to Showcase your
brand and to help them add value to
their lives so by doing that you
establish trust you establish
credibility yeah and you provide recall
value for your brand
so it is all about taking the customer
by the hand and helping them
in going through the buying cycle
yes so when the buying cycle is about
awareness is about building interest
yeah then building that trust that
they've then will turn into buying your
product
the second big benefit that you're
getting from Facebook is to Target
people that have already expressed an
interest in your service we call this
retargeting you may also have heard
about pixel targeting or pixel marketing
it basically means that if somebody
visits your website
yeah you can then retarget those people
within ads
from a technical element as a
perspective it means that you need to
put Facebook or give you a piece of code
that you need to put on your website
and then as soon as somebody visits that
website that triggers that code it
automatically connects with Facebook and
then Facebook will capture that user
data that you can then use to Target
them with a specific ads
so a big opportunity there for the
retargeting but things will be changing
here in the near future yeah Google has
announced that by 2023 24 it will stop
enabling third parties to leave cookies
on the um on on websites yeah to Target
people so that whole retargeting area
will go and will undergo some big
changes in the near future and then of
course Facebook advertising can really
help you increase Revenue as I said
earlier it is a fantastic way to to
connect with people and take them by the
hand through the buying cycle you can
educate your audiences about what your
product has to offer yeah and the more
people know about your products the more
likely they are prepared to make a
purchase and to share their experiences
so lots of benefits that you get now
let's dive a bit deeper into this and
let's look at the different type of ads
that Facebook has available so first
there is the single image ad
these are single ads single image ads
that have an option uh optional text on
the top and a link description that
links to your website and a call to
action that is very important to have a
good call to action in your ads the ad
images they need to be 1200 by 628
pixels
so that's where you have an opportunity
individual to stand out in the news feed
and make people stop and then click on
the link as you see here for instance
sign up
the next ads are the multi-product ads
they are usually carousels so it enables
you allow consumers to see all the
products or the services that you have
available they're very efficient they're
very Visual and they have lots of
creative options
um in them so they're very popular and
they're blocks being being used Lots by
by businesses so that's your
multi-product ads usually via a carousel
then of course you have your video ads
Now video ads are 30 seconds to two
minute ads and they are amongst
Facebook's most engaging most popular
ads they get about 10 to 30 percent more
views than other ads and not only views
also engagement why because people love
to engage with video when you engage
with video you have the opportunity to
touch emotions of people which is much
stronger in building trust building
relationships with your audience
and particularly video on mobile yeah
works really well so it's a high growth
area of video advertising and one area
that you definitely need to look at if
you want to be successful with Facebook
advertising
then you have the lead ads lead ads they
offer slightly different way to
advertise your products they let you get
usernames emails phone numbers actually
without leaving Facebook
yeah and that's what makes them really
powerful within Facebook advertising you
can actually create a sign up form or
you could even drive them through
Messenger and have a communication with
them to get their details through a
chatbot
so people don't leave Facebook you do
the whole process of lead generation and
lead capture within Facebook and it can
be easily synchronized with your
existing CRM system
then you have collection ads collection
ads blend video and product catalog
photos so they are really good if you
want to advertise multiple products at
once yeah if you want to do this so
collection ads work really well
okay so that's a short introduction of
Facebook advertising the benefits that
you get why people would use them why
businesses would use them and the
different type of ads so in the next
section let's go and have a look at how
do you create an ad what are the steps
to create a Facebook ads
so here you see I am on a Facebook page
and this is the page for Riyadh for
Russia which is a hotel in Marrakech and
I am the admin for this page
and what I'm going to show you on this
page is how to access the advertising
platform and how to set up your ads
yes so let me first before I do this
show you what Facebook is trying to do
everywhere whether it's your desktop or
your mobile to make sure that you go
into advertise creation mode yeah so
you'll see it everywhere promote
ad Center create ads create automated
ads boost post wherever you are you will
come to sections like boost post or go
please create an ad on the mobile it's
even more obvious yeah here is the same
page but then on the mobile device and
if I scroll down you see on the first
post immediately boost the post so
you'll see that Facebook is trying
everything to get you to advertise
yep and I think it is a bit annoying
yeah but it's also you need to be aware
that all the various places that
Facebook will try to to hook you into
advertising they lead to various
subsections of the advertising platform
yeah so if I click here on booster post
it will take me to a what I call a quick
and dirty boost advertising module yeah
so I say I'm gonna good morning from our
rooftop I'm going to turn that post into
an ad yeah it I can immediately suicide
what goal do I want for my ad do I want
to add a button what is the URL yeah do
I want to edit the image who is my
audience yeah and then what is the
budget what is the duration where am I
going to show these ads and how am I
going to pay Bang Bang
boost post now
yeah so it's looks very interesting and
very effective to do this but what you
see here is you will only get a
subsection of what Facebook advertising
can do for you
yeah and if you think hey if that's okay
with you that's fine but you're missing
90 of the other features to make your
ads as effective as possible
in other words my advice to you would be
don't click on the boost a post button
on your mobile or your desktop because
again it leads you to a limited
functionality of the advertising module
and the advertising capabilities that
Facebook can offer you
so back to the desktop the same applies
here if I click here on Boost post
yeah there's nothing wrong with
advertising for a post you can take one
of your most successful posts or for a
video and you can create additional
reach for that post through advertising
but don't do it through the limited
advertising functionality again this is
a quick and dirty module everything on
one page and it will you can click boost
now and it's an easy way to start
spending your money yes so that is
if you click the Boost post the same
applies if you go to the
create ads or create automated ads yeah
so let me show you the create automated
ads it takes you through a very
automated process of creating ads which
is great when you're a beginner
but again it'll only give you limited
functionality of what Facebook
advertising has to offer you
so my advice would be don't go to the
automated ads click on create ads that
again gives you limited functionality
gives it all in one page again you don't
want to do that
yep and then you click on the add Center
that gives you again a summary of the
advertising slightly more tools
yeah but it's all to lure you into spend
money in a very quick way
so then where do I go for my advertising
the place where you go ish to the
Facebook or how they now called meta The
Meta business Suite The Meta business
Suite gives you everything you need for
your advertising it allows you to manage
multiple advertising accounts
yep and it gives you access to the full
functionality of what Facebook has to
offer you so let's go there The Meta
business Suite
oh
so here you see
everything you need for your advertising
yeah so here you see it's your read for
Russia and it's not only for your
advertising you can manage your posts
here you can schedule your posts manage
your inbox your notification manage your
content manage your shop plan your post
now we'll cover all these areas in
future videos but for now we want to
focus on the advertising again even here
they have ads as a quick and dirty
method to create your ads again where I
want you to go click here on all tools
and now finally this is where you want
to go it gives you access to the full
advertising functionality to create your
ads to manage your ads to manage your
audiences to set up events when you want
to connect get data from your website
and where you can create your forms
this is where you want to go yeah so if
I click here on the ads manager
that takes me to the full advertising
platform
now here you see by the way turn off ad
blocker yeah which is important because
in your creation of your ads Facebook
will obviously
[Music]
simulate your your ads yeah but if you
have your ad blocker on the ads will not
show in the preview so it is important
that you switch off the ad blocker so
you create your browser environment
exactly as users will have in when they
they see your ads so let me go into
switching that off
which is more tools extensions you see
here my ad blocker is on so I'm going to
switch that off
yeah let me do a review
yes so here you have your account
overview you have your uh your desk is
your sort of your dashboard now you see
I haven't run any campaigns yeah so I'm
not gonna so there's not much to see
here in this and this this tool so let's
go here under my campaigns yeah and this
gives me the basic sort of structure of
your advertising on Facebook
yeah and remember we talked about
campaigns ad sets and ads
yeah those are the three elements of
your
advertising campaign on Facebook you
create a campaign and I'll show you what
you need to set up in the campaigns then
within a campaign you can have multiple
ad sets and those ad sets within a
campaign inherit the settings of the
campaign
and then within ad sets you have ads
yep and Those ads they inherit the
settings of the ad sets and the settings
of the campaign
all right so you see here we have three
or two campaigns or three campaigns
there is a new leads campaign there is a
page likes and there is a traffic
campaign so now I'm not going to show
you these campaigns I'm actually going
to show you how to create a campaign
so let's go into that here is create
if you have experience with advertising
in pay-per-click advertising you will
recognize this approach Google ads has
it as well it is what we call guided
campaign creation
yeah so when you start your Facebook ads
and when you start your Google ads you
can select do you want an awareness
campaign
do you want a traffic engagement leads
promote your apps or a sales campaign
yeah and basically once the campaign
objective that you select will
set a number of the settings yeah sort
of specifically for that campaign
objective so it makes it easier to align
it with your business goals and the
whole setup will be done easier
yeah so here you see an awareness
objective so that is too good for Rich
for brand awareness for video views yeah
so it's showing the ad to the month to
as many people as possible who are
likely to remember them
traffic is to send people to a
destination like your website this is
really good to get link clicks to get
views from a landing page or get people
get into conversations with people on
Messenger or Whatsapp engagement ads is
get more messages videos views post
engagements it's good for Instagram
first messaging apps good for video
views engagement on posts lead ads or
collect leads for your business or brand
they're good for instant forms on
messenger good for conversions and to
get calls here's to promote your apps
like in app installs app events and here
is sales that is for your catalog sales
for instance
yeah we're going to do a simple one I'm
going to set up a traffic I want to
drive people to a landing page yeah so
here I'm going to click on traffic yeah
and I'm going to click continue
so now I'm going into the campaign
settings so here you see the three
structures again the new traffic
campaign new traffic ad set new traffic
ads that I'm going to use
okay so here is my traffic campaign I'm
going to create a name which is I'm
going to stick with new traffic campaign
am I going to use any ads are there any
AD categories yeah so is it about
elections is it about politics is it
about employment about social issues
yeah I remember a few years ago there
was this Scandal when there was brexit
and the Trump elections or the in 2018 I
believe it was there was a lot of data
being sold by this Cambridge analytica
that they data they took from Facebook
and they sold it to the campaign teams
of the U.S election and of the brexit
yeah that had a big impact on privacy on
Facebook and on
um advertising for for elections and
politics shown and now Facebook has set
some extra sort of security guidelines
for specific ad categories
now what are the campaign details
here you see by default it is set as an
auction
pay-per-click works on an auction base
and this is not a pay-per-click course
but basically it means you will do a bit
on your ad how much you're prepared to
pay for a click yeah and that will then
go into an auction and that will
determine the position of your ads we
want to get more traffic
do you want to do a b testing yes and we
want Facebook to do that yeah or you
switch that off and what is your budget
do you want to create distribute your
butt set across ad sets yeah if you want
to do that you can switch that on and
then you have your campaign budget so
we're going to set a daily bug chat of
20 pounds yeah so go back to the
phone setting yeah and then what is your
campaign bit strategy I just want the
highest volume and there's more options
you can schedule your ads so you can set
it at specific times my advice is to run
the ads all the time yeah particularly
in the learning phase when Facebook
launches your campaign it goes into
learning mode and then Facebook will see
by itself when your audience will
[Music]
will will respond and they will adjust
the ad scheduling accordingly so there
is your traffic campaign
details then we're going to your traffic
ad set where do you want to drive your
traffic to your website to an app to
messenger we want to drive it to the
website
now Dynamic creative is an important one
yeah do you want to want Facebook to
create your ads or do you want to do it
yourself when you want Facebook to do it
you provide creative elements like
images and headlines and then Facebook
will automatically generate the best ads
for you yeah so I kind of like that yeah
so I always switch that on on here you
see the schedule when do you want to
start
yeah so do you want to send an end as
well so that would be then let's say
November the 22nd and then here is some
more options you can set at spend limits
and here is where the real meaty
sort of stuff happens in Facebook
advertising this is where you can select
your audience you can save specific
audiences
in the audience manager yeah so you can
have a number of audience if you have an
office in one country or another country
you can just hear select select the
audience for that particular country or
you can just create a new audience
okay so you can exclude audiences you
can set a location you can set the age
location let's look at that if I click
here on edit people living in or
recently in this location
people living people recently people
traveling in this location so this is
really powerful if you want to Target
people who are visiting a uh an event
like a football match or what have you
and you can include and this is where
you can search location you can in
search by City let's say London
yeah so London England or I can say
let's do prisons reading in England
yeah and I can even say uh give me
yeah so I can search location give me uh
rg7 I can do by postcode yeah so I can
actually people doing in the reading
area by postcode and I really like this
so if I say for instance
rg76 yeah so here you can see how you
can Target a specific area yeah and this
is particularly for your local marketing
is very important
yep so that is the uh the local
targeting is really good so you can and
then by the way here you see your
estimated audience size and when your
audience get bigger you see estimated
daily results as well
and then you can do more you can search
by
um where was this you can search by
detailed targeting by demographics by
interests and behaviors yeah so if I
want to people who like reading
Football Club
yeah so here is the reading FC soccer
team yeah so here are I can now sent an
ad targeting specifically people in that
particular area who lie and we have the
UK as well yeah so uh in reading and
that particular area who like football
who like Reading Football Club yeah or I
can
um other at other areas as well there's
also the suggestions if people like
reading they may also like these type of
things Neymar soccer or maybe they like
Manchester United yeah so this is just a
tip of the iceberg the whole
segmentation in Facebook advertising and
the targeting is extremely powerful
okay here are your placements for your
Facebook ads best is to let Facebook
decide where to place your ads but to
show you where your ads can be shown on
Facebook if you click on the manual
placements you see here they can show on
Facebook they can show on Instagram on
messenger and on the Audience Network
now what is the Audience Network Google
has said as well yeah in the display ads
which are ads that show on millions of
websites that Facebook has an agree or
that Google or in this case Facebook has
an agreement with so it shows your
Facebook ads outside Facebook
or millions of websites okay so that's
the Audience Network then if you look at
it here is the feeds where your ad can
she can show
your ads can show in stories and reels
your ad can show in stream videos
overlay and post Loop ads on reels on
Facebook search on messaging in article
apps inside so there is tons of places
where your ads can show but the best
thing is to let Facebook decide where
your ads are going to show
okay so these are your ad set settings
so let's now look at the ads
so here you see the Facebook page and in
our case it is the Riyadh for Russia
page
there you go yeah we'll make it you can
opt in for Branded content tools you can
look at the ad setup we can do manual
upload you can get data from your
product catalog and here you specify
what type of AD you want to show is it a
single image or a video or is it a
carousel
yep and then here you have your ad
creative
and your media and the select images
select videos and then here you have
your primary text headline description
your website URL this is where you can
do your url parameters when you want to
track your campaigns
yeah here you see the ad previewed at
preview is off and now it's on yeah but
of course I need to select media
so let's see
find images so here we're going to say
go to my website
and create an image for me approve
yeah so now it will actually show me
some images
select images yeah so here you see
images from my reacts
yeah that it picks up from my react or
from my website here's the website yeah
so let's take uh
let's take this image and we'll say
continue
yeah so
so selected destination link for your ad
let me see where we're going to put that
one
[Music]
there you go yes from now because I put
in the destination link you will see how
the ad start building but this is the
photo that I selected yeah now I'm not
going to show you the details of and I'm
not going to use as an example here I
just want you to show you the fields
where you can play and create your ads
yeah and then you see here in the ad
preview whether you see it in the feeds
there is a mobile preview as well
yep so you see here the feeds you see
here the stories and the reels how they
would look on Instagram the in stream
app and here in the search in article
and on apps
yes so there you have it that is your
traffic ads so we've now done our
campaign we've done our ad set we've
done our traffic ads and then basically
what you're going to do is you're going
to publish your ads
now when you're going to publish
yeah you can then go back to view the
details
and then you see that the ad is
um done and it is actually in review by
Facebook so if I now go back to my
campaigns
yeah let's close this one
you see here is the new traffic ads yeah
and you see here it's processing and
then here you see immediately the
details that you can get from your
campaign yes so you see the processing
you see the ad set name the bit strategy
the budget you see attribution setting
so basically attribution is how you
track the results of your ads
and then you see here the results in
number of Link clicks how many people
reached how many Impressions what is the
cost per result what is the quality
ranking the engagement ranking the
conversion ranking the higher these
rankings the better Facebook considers
your ads and the more and the better the
positions for your ads here you see your
amount spent and here you see the end
date of the campaign
yes so that is how you set up your
Facebook ads as a kind of introduction
to the Facebook advertising
yeah so if I now go back to all my
campaigns
campaigns yeah so you see here let me
see if I have some now you see there's
no none of these ads actually run or did
run in the past yes so I can't show you
the the results but we'll go into more
details at a later the later session on
on Facebook advertising for now this is
I think the best overview I can give you
yeah and if you want to get more than
details then we'll go in a more in-depth
session of the Facebook advertising
okay now that is all clear let's look at
the do's and don'ts of Facebook
advertising
what should you do and what shouldn't
you do with your ads
so there are various dues to first of
all make sure you continuously test your
ads
and the good thing is that Facebook will
do this for you yeah you can tell
Facebook please test my ads you can give
Facebook a collection of creative
materials a collection of headlines yeah
and it will actually mix and match those
headlines and it will use the ones that
will give the best
um the best conversions so it's very
important that you continuously look
yeah at your performance and see if
minor changes to your ads will lead to a
better performance
second make sure that your images and
that your videos are engaging remember
there is no intent in Facebook
advertising you have to be very creative
to stand out from the crowd and you can
only do that by making your ads
engagement or them by making your ads
engaging
in images and videos
so the not only the images or the videos
but it's also the messaging that you use
use a message that will stay with your
audience
yeah so it's the combination of the
visuals and the key message of your ad
that will make people stop
if by looking in a split second at your
ad yeah they get it
then they will stop and they will
click on the call to action so make sure
you use a message that is
powerful and effective
also keep it simple or we say kiss keep
it simple and stupid make sure that
people easily understand
the message that you're trying to convey
with your ads don't make it too
complicated don't use complicated
visuals don't use complicated messages
keep it simple
and make sure that you reach the Right
audience
yeah Facebook's biggest benefit is the
targeting you can Target
micro or micro level targeting people in
very specific areas
yeah so that is the dues and of course
there are don'ts as well so the first
thing is be sensible with your budget
don't spend your whole Budget on one
single campaign
yeah so start small and basically grow
your budget based on the results that
you're getting
yeah if you have to use visuals and
messages that are appealing then of
course don't make sure that you put too
much information in the ads again keep
your ads simple don't clutter them with
too much text and too many visuals
make sure that you proofread your ads
don't have typos in your ads there's not
a lot of text in your ad so please make
sure that you double check the quality
of the ads when it comes to the language
and the um the Cramer yeah so don't
forget to proofread your ads
be sensible in the activity level that
you have on your Facebook page yeah up
until a few years ago it was
it was actually promoted by Facebook to
do as many posts as you think are
relevant for your business people did
four or five posts a day nowadays it is
not about the quantity it is about the
quality so don't do too many posts on
your Facebook page be sensible think
from a customer perspective also when it
comes to your ads yeah so too many ads
or showing the same ads to the same
people all the time yeah may have an
adverse result
and then finally make sure that your
image relates to your product so don't
put up an image that doesn't relate to
the advertised products
it's literally content marketing uh okay
what is it so content marketing Is Not A
New Concept it's been around for over a
hundred years in fact one of the classic
Foundation stories of you know the birth
of content marketing goes all the way
back to the Michelin Brothers in France
and the Michelin Brothers you know in
case you haven't done your history
that's okay you know a little refresher
right now
were two brothers who made pneumatic
tires and they were trying to sell them
along with an Innovative product at its
time called the automobile
in an era where the roads were horrible
in a place France where frankly people
didn't like to get outside of Paris and
into the provinces because my God what
was worth going out there for you know
or Paris that's all Happening Here
and what the Michelin Brothers realized
is if they wanted to sell more tires
they had to get people to drive farther
and farther
than use them
so what did they come up with
the concept that really is the birth of
content Marketing in my book
was the Michelin guide
and the Michelin guide was unique in
that it reviewed restaurants not just
restaurants nearby in Paris but
restaurants out there in the provinces
and the Michelin brothers are the ones
who came up with the one two and three
star rating system to say this
restaurant I know it's way out there
it's you know bad roads but guess what
to die for the Ratatouille oh you you
gotta have it this is a three-star
restaurant you you it's worth making the
trip
and oh by the way and since we're going
to give you a guide and you have to get
out of Paris in order to get there we're
going to tell you where you can find
gasoline along the way uh which hotels
uh you might want to stay at overnight
and oh by the way just in case you have
to
how to repair a flat tire particularly
if it's a Michelin tire because it's a
Pneumatic and you know what it's quite
easy to repair
and guess what that put Michelin on the
map why they weren't trying to sell you
more tires
they weren't telling you about the
features and benefits of round
or tire repair I mean that was in there
but it was only a how-to article not
necessarily a feature and benefit
what they were doing was they were
speaking to Their audience about what
Their audience was truly passionate
about which in Paris in 1900. was food
and by creating content
they got the audience to get into their
new Innovative automobile and drive all
the way out there into the provinces for
that absolutely remarkable three-star
restaurant
people got more Flats people had to
replace their tires but it was worth it
and oh by the way
Michelin sold my tires
so that that's a great story every time
you sort of
you know hit a pause and like well we're
doing content marketing and we need to
come up with a concept
back to the Michelin guide it's it's a
great Foundation
let's go
to a modern definition where are we now
in the 21st century
when it comes to content marketing
well you can read the slide here and
read the definition and some people like
reading definitions I'm not going to
read it to you
but I am going to highlight a couple of
words in the definition that I think are
absolutely critical to any definition
of content marketing
the content that you create needs to be
relevant
and it also has to be valuable
now if it's not relevant then you're not
actually meeting my needs or interests
you know and why would I be interested
in them and we've gotten way too tired
of screening out the commercial that
comes on
um you know trying to sell out snow
tires and pardon me we live in Florida I
don't use those tires what the what the
heck is this commercial doing
you know interrupting what I'm watching
so relevance is important
relevance means that this content isn't
going to get screened out
and the valuable the valuable can can
work in a lot of different ways it can
be interesting
it can be useful
you know value is an interesting
proposition all by itself
but that's the key to content marketing
uh it's not just creating more spam
it's not just throwing more trash over
the fence and hoping something happens
this is something where if you've
created valuable and relevant content
you know what your customers will find
you that's a whole different kind of
proposition
I know there's some Skeptics they're
just saying oh come on come on come on
content marketing is just a fancy new
name for social media marketing right
and the answer is well there is some
overlap and we're going to deal with
that in module three
but let me just be clear here
social media content is part of what
content marketing needs to create
but it can also create content for your
website and that's not the social media
it can also create content that your PR
people can share with uh reporters or
bloggers and that's not normally
considered uh social media content and
by the way all of that content can be
optimized so maybe he it actually is
part of SEO not social media marketing
in fact that's the other place that
content marketing really overlaps
and it's not coincidental
it so happens that around February 2011
when Google rolled out the first of its
multiple versions of the panda update
all of a sudden even seos started to pay
attention to content marketing why
because Google changed the rules and
what Google basically said is if your
content isn't valuable or relevant
you know what it's not going to rank
very well in our search animal who are
them
and all of a sudden people who had been
used to like putting keywords in the
right places
realized content matters you know I've
got to actually tell stories that are
interesting I've got to create
information that's valuable uh
yeah you can make it relevant that's the
optimization part
but you know if you're trying to
optimize a piece of boring irrelevant
trash
God bless you good luck
so yeah content marketing
has grown it's like tripled in terms of
web search interest since the panda
update
and then we're talking about panda one
of course there was Panda 2 Panda 3
Panda 4. I mean come on
Google is driving us in this direction
and so content marketing is pretty
relevant today
now one of the other things that people
in content marketing struggle with is oh
but you don't understand I do B2B
content marketing or I'm a small
business or pardon me I'm an Enterprise
and so content marketing has to come in
flavors right
well possibly maybe on occasion
so let's just question that assumption
for a second
you know content marketing has been
around now long enough and enough people
have done it but some research has been
conducted
and it's been conducted against b2c
marketers and B2B marketers and small
business marketers and Enterprise level
marketers
and when they start asking key questions
like okay
we're going to try to determine what is
the difference between an effective
content marketer and an ineffective
content marketer
let's see the results
well first of all
the most important thing to Be an
Effective b2c content marketer
is you need a documented content
strategy
okay all right I mean people who are
winging it aren't as effective as people
who actually have thought about this and
written it down got it okay
no great Insight but you know
interesting to note
secondly they're going to have somebody
in charge who oversees content marketing
oh Lord does that mean we have to have a
reorg or maybe we just have to designate
somebody who reports to somebody else
whatever but guess what it really helps
if somebody is driving this process
third they've got to be using more
content marketing tactics than their
less effective peers
and this is not an argument more is
better this is just pardon me that's the
way the data falls out the people who
are actually more effective are doing
more different kinds of things
a broader range of tactics
and who knows maybe it's that broader
range that's part of the success formula
same thing is true with social media
platforms
the effective content marketers are
using more than the ineffective ones and
last but not least and this may be a
sort of a result of the first four
by gosh effective content marketers
generally have greater percentage
of the overall marketing budget in their
organization
wow okay
that's the b2c marketing for it but you
don't understand I I'm not a b2c
marketer okay
so let's take a look at the B2B content
marketing formula
guess what
you need to have a documented content
marketing strategy to Be an Effective
B2B content marketer you need to have
someone who oversees content marketing
strategy it helps if you are using more
tactics
and more social media platforms and
guess what you spend a higher percentage
of your overall marketing budget
on content marketing well that's similar
to the b2c content marketers but you
understand B2B is different yeah there's
a couple small differences but guess
what overall the top five criteria
are similar and when you get the small
business here's what you're going to see
same five criteria
and you're in an Enterprise I know the
world is different for Enterprises
actually not so much
so four different data points let's net
it out there's a pattern
and the pattern is I don't care what
flavor of content marketer you are you
can be b2c B2B you can be small business
you can be large Enterprise at the end
of the day there are five things that
you've got to focus on
if you want to be effective
we've already covered these and are
there differences between small
businesses and large Enterprises between
B2B and b2c well sure
but they're all at the margin
what's the downside if we don't do this
you know is anyone going to come in and
like wakas
and the answer is
um maybe not inside your boardroom
but it may happen on the next sales call
that one of your sales people makes they
may encounter someone I like to call the
man in the chair
and the Man in the chair actually refers
back to a classic McGraw-Hill ad
campaign from I think the 1960s
but basically the guy in the chair asks
theoretically some questions from quote
maybe your sales person okay I don't
know anything about you I don't know
about your company I don't know about
your company's product I don't know
about your company's you know reputation
or anything about you and so what was it
you were going to try to sell me
and that's the downside of not having a
Content marketing program
content marketing has been around for
over a hundred years
but in the online world
customers are behaving in lots of new
ways and they're consuming content on
various kinds and types of devices
and that changes things content
marketing is now about creating content
that consumers will engage with and act
upon not just read or listen to or watch
so in this introductory module we're
going to provide you with an
understanding of how content marketing
affects the decision-making process when
people are on the customer journey to
making a purchase and with a solid
content marketing strategy your
customers buying decisions
can actually happen faster you can
basically
shorten the decision-making process
and you can reach and expand to new
prospects
so one of the things that we hope that
you're going to learn after basically
taking this module you should be able to
do the following first of all you can
Define content marketing and other
related Concepts secondly you should be
able to explain why content needs to be
relevant and valuable in order for it to
be effective
third you need to describe the overlap
between content marketing SEO social
media marketing
fourth you need to name five traits of
effective content marketers
and last but not least you need to
explain the benefits of content
marketing these are our objectives and
hopefully they're going to be your
learning outcomes
so content marketing Is Not A New
Concept it's been around for over a
hundred years in fact one of the classic
Foundation stories of you know the birth
of content marketing goes all the way
back to the Michelin Brothers in France
and the Michelin Brothers you know in
case you haven't done your history
that's okay you know low refresher right
now
we're two brothers who made pneumatic
tires and they were trying to sell them
along with an Innovative product at its
time called the automobile
in an era where the roads were horrible
in a place France where frankly people
didn't like to get outside of Paris and
into the provinces because my God what
was worth going out there for you know
or Paris that's all Happening Here
and what the Michelin Brothers realized
is if they wanted to sell more tires
they had to get people to drive farther
and farther
and use them
so what did they come up with
the concept that really is the birth of
content Marketing in my book
was the Michelin guide
and the Michelin guide was unique in
that it reviewed restaurants not just
restaurants nearby in Paris but
restaurants out there in the provinces
and the Michelin brothers are the ones
who came up with the one two and three
star rating system to say this
restaurant I know it's way out there
it's you know bad roads but guess what
to die for the Ratatouille oh you you
gotta have it this is a three-star
restaurant you you it's worth making the
trip
and oh by the way since we're going to
give you a guide and you have to get out
of Paris in order to get there we're
going to tell you where you can find
gasoline along the way which hotels you
might want to stay at overnight and oh
by the way just in case you have to
how to repair a flat tire particularly
if it's a Michelin tire because it's a
Pneumatic and you know what it's quite
easy to repair
and guess what that put Michelin on the
map why they weren't trying to sell you
more tires
they weren't telling you about the
features and benefits of round
or tire repair I mean that was in there
but it was only a how-to article not
necessarily a feature and benefit
what they were doing was they were
speaking to Their audience about what
Their audience was truly passionate
about which in Paris in 1900
was food
and by creating content
that got the audience to get into their
new Innovative automobile
and drive all the way out there into the
provinces for that absolutely remarkable
three-star restaurant
people got more Flats people had to
replace their tires but it was worth it
and oh by the way
Michelin sold more tires
so that
that's a great story every time you sort
of
so if you are looking to become a
digital marketing specialist then look
no further than simply learn
postgraduate program in digital
marketing with this you gain all the
necessity skills in digital marketing
like website creation behavioral
marketing keyword research search engine
optimization search engine marketing
campaign management social media
marketing and more with knowledge of
tools like SC ranking HootSuite chat GPD
Google ads Google Keyword Planner Google
Trends and there's much more on the list
don't miss out on this incredible
opportunity take action today and enroll
in a course to unlock the digital
marketing success accelerator career and
gain the skills you need to thrive in
the industry ready to get started then
click on the link mentioned in the
description box and embark on your
journey to professional growth and
achievement welcome everyone this is Rob
Sanders from Simply learn and today
we're going to talk about affiliate
marketing so let's jump right into it
and take a look inside an office
environment right now we have Chuck here
Chuck's doing a little bit of pacing
John walks in the office hey man what's
with all the pacing everything all right
Chuck responded hey I'm just worried
that I might have exhausted every way we
can advertise our product I mean I've
done SEO I've done paid search I've done
email I've done social man nothing's
working I gotta come up with something
new ASAP well John responds hey don't
worry I think I've got your solution for
you man hang tight relax take a load off
here's my solution affiliate marketing
first off before you ask the question
what's affiliate marketing let's talk
about why we need affiliate marketing so
let's dig into affiliate marketing so
John's just taking over now and he's
gonna let Chuck know everything there is
to know about affiliate marketing so the
first question John answers for Chuck
what is affiliate marketing so affiliate
marketing is a form of digital marketing
that involves a merchant it involves a
merchant paying commissions to a website
or other entities so if I'm selling a
product basically somebody else sells
that product for me I'm gonna pay that
person a commission for selling my
product it's that simple that's what
affiliate marketing is okay so basically
what these margins are doing or other
entities they're advertising your
product so they're advertising your
product with a referral so they're
passing on their own customers to you so
that they can buy your product and again
The Exchange is you give that website or
other entity a commission that's more or
less what affiliate marketing is so
John's gonna have us take a look at each
of these components of affiliate
marketing in detail take it away John so
John says first we have the merchant AKA
The Brand the seller the Creator the
founder the owner the inspiration the
innovator hey this is the person who
came up with this brilliant idea This
brilliant idea has to get out there
we're the merchant we're trying to get
this brilliant idea out to the masses so
this is the component of affiliate
marketing that creates the product the
merchant could be anyone okay so it
could be startups to large multinational
companies International companies
non-profits for-profits individuals
independent contractors Freelancers a
group of people who have a passion for
something okay it could be anybody
there's no limit the affiliate aka the
publisher so the affiliate is basically
that third party website or entity which
promotes the Merchant's products and
tries to convince potential customers of
the merchants products value so this
affiliate's going to represent the
merchant on their behalf and try and get
their clients to basically purchase that
particular Merchant's product so the
affiliate could be incentivized based on
you know registrations email sign ups
sales and subscriptions so it doesn't
always come down to you know sales you
know if I'm just trying to get you know
build my email list then hey I can
incentivize that affiliate to push email
signups if I'm got this big you know
offline you know promotion that I'm
doing at this particular mall and I want
to get people there well I can get an
affiliate and incentivize that affiliate
to drive and help me drive registrations
for this event so it doesn't always have
to be sales per se so in effect you the
merchant and the affiliate work out some
type of commission deal based on what
you're incentivizing so the relationship
between the affiliate and the merchant
is made possible with the help of an
affiliate Network so that's the third
component here we need somebody to bring
the two together that Merchant who has
This brilliant idea and the affiliate
who has potential customers that could
potentially Drive registrations sales
signups Etc to the merchant so the
affiliate network is the one who brings
the two together so the affiliate
Network in effect acts as the middleman
the person in between the merchants and
Affiliates it allows Merchants to find
and collaborate okay with not just any
affiliate but the affiliate best suited
for their particular brand and product
because you want to find somebody who is
going to be passionate who's relevant
who has your prospective customers in
mind because they're the ones that are
going to help those protective customers
purchase your product so that's what the
affiliate network does it helps bring
the merchants and Affiliates together so
that the affiliate can help advertise
and sell on behalf of the merchant so
with the affiliate Network Merchants can
use tools for tracking and Reporting and
processing payments for Affiliates so
really that affiliate network is the
glue that holds it all together they're
not just one to introduce a merchant and
affiliate they offer it all so as a
merchant you want to be able to manage
your Affiliates so you're not going to
have one affiliate you're going to have
multiple Affiliates so you want to be
able to use the appropriate tools
available to you in the affiliate
Network to see and track how how sales
are going and when sales happen okay or
commissions happen you want to be able
to use that affiliate Network to
compensate that affiliate appropriately
and then finally the customer customer
aka the consumer is the most important
component of all of this take it away
John so the consumer is the final and
most important component without
customers to buy products the merchant
would not have any revenue and the
affiliate would not get any commission
did
[Music]
we will understand how Google analytics
works
how we can use it to measure the
performance of our website we'll also
understand how to set up goals and
create events that will help us keep our
website on track
next we will look at Google tag manager
and towards the end we will unlock the
mystery of how to rank at number one
position on Google it's it's not that
hard as you think it is
we have Rob with us who has more than 15
years of experience in digital marketing
and analytics and he will take us
through these topics over to you rob
welcome everyone this is Rob Sanders
with simply learn and today we're going
to talk about Google analytics I'm very
excited to be with you today because
Google analytics is one of my favorite
Google platforms and my favorite topics
so let's talk about what we're going to
cover today I'm going to start out with
how to set up a Google analytics account
and so we're going to talk about
everything that entails including
creating your Google analytics account
we're going to talk about setting up a
property in your account and what a
property is we're going to talk about
setting up a reporting view in your
property and we're going to talk about
installing the tracking code so those
are the series of steps we're going to
go through today in terms of setting up
a Google analytics account so let's get
right to it and so really the Bruin
prerequisite here when it comes to
setting up a Google analytics account is
to have a Google login and ID so when
you actually go to Google analytics you
need to be able to sign up or sign in
and so once you actually sign in then
you're gonna go walk through a series of
steps but really that's really all you
need to get the account going is a
Google ID and login so if you have a
Gmail account or an other email account
that you use for other Google products
then you're good to go that's all you
need to do so when you actually go to
sign up for Google analytics you're
going to be asked to set up a new
account and these are the series of
steps you're going to walk through or go
through to set up a new Google Analytics
account so you're going to choose an
account name and then you're going to
choose a property name okay so the
account name can be anything you want it
to be to name your company your your
name whatever you want to name it the
property name is really the website name
so what website are we talking about so
here I'm going to set up a fictitious
website name for now it's called demo
simply learn so the URL for this website
demo simply learn is going to be
demo.simplylearn.com so that's the
property when we talk about properties
in analytics we're really talking about
what websites we want to measure and
then you're going to be asked to choose
an industry category and so for simply
learn we're in jobs and education but
you have a number of different
industries that you could choose from
this is important go ahead and choose
the most relevant industry that your
particular business is associated with
okay and I'm gonna talk about why that's
important here in a minute and then
you're going to choose your time zone
and the time zone is also important
because that's when the day starts in
analytics and the day ends based on that
time zone so so the data that Google
analytics collects starts and ends with
that time zone so very important to
choose the time zone your business is
located in okay and then you have some
additional options here okay so you have
some settings and so the first setting
is to allow Google products and services
so if you opt into this then basically
what Google's going to do is share some
products and services with you via email
I would go ahead and opt into that
that's of course recommended by Google
it doesn't hurt to hear from Google on
related products and services that may
enhance your business the second is
benchmarking so benchmarking to me is
something you should opt into so going
back to that industry and category we
chose jobs and education so by opting
into benchmarking basically what Google
is going to do is share your data that
it collects on your website in this case
demo.com simplylearn.com it's going to
share that data anonymously with others
in the industry in this case jobs and
education and because you've opted in
it's going to do the same exact thing
for you it's going to share Anonymous
data on other websites in the same
industry and the benefit of that is we
get to see what other websites or how
other websites are performing compared
to ours what's the Benchmark in our
industry and so the benchmarking to me
is important and I'm going to go over
that in a few minutes when we go over
the different reports but to me I would
always opt into benchmarking because
this is the only report Google provides
in analytics about how others in your
industry is performing versus your
website okay so it's a way to compare
your website performance against others
in the same industry the other options
here technical support and account
specialist I would also recommend man
you opt into those because then it
allows you to basically Google allow
Google access to your account and
they'll be able to help you if you occur
or run into any issues so these are the
options in setting up a Google analytics
account it's very simple very easy to do
you're just entering in a few Fields
note that we talking about a website
right now so I'm talking about
demo.simplylearn.com but just know that
if you want to track a mobile app Google
analytics will allow you to do that as
well you just choose the option mobile
app so we're tracking a website we want
to know how users behave when they get
to my website and that's what Google
analytics is going to allow us to
measure and look at we just need to do a
couple more steps in the process so once
we fill out these fields here we're
going to click get tracking ID now I'm
going to accept the terms of service I'm
going to accept another terms and
service and relate relation to data
protection I'm going to click accept
once I accept I'm going to be able to
get some tracking code the tracking ID
is the ID associated with your account
and so this number is going to be
associated with your account so your
account ID starts with UA and it's going
to be this number here now the dash one
is the property you set up so in this
case I set up
demo.simplylearn.com if I wanted to
track multiple websites under that same
account then I can certainly set up
multiple properties just know that every
property I set up in that account is
going to have a dash 1-2-3-4
Etc depending on how many properties I
set up so by default I set up one
property so my first property ID is dash
one if I set up a second property the
same account number is just gonna have a
dash too and that's important because
that ID that account and property ID is
going to be associated with that
particular property or website so again
once you finish setting up the account
settings then you're going to be asked
to add some tracking code to your site
and that tracking code is going to be
related to the account and the property
so notice my tracking ID up here notice
the tracking ID in the snippet of code
now this snippet of code needs to go on
every page of your website that you want
to track and you don't have to put it on
every page but if you want to track
website behavior on every page or
website then it needs to go on every
page of your website so if you're using
a you know platform like Drupal or
Joomla or even more popular platform
like WordPress adding the tracking code
site-wide is as easy as maybe adding a
Google analytics plugin to Wordpress for
example and then just simply plug in in
the ID now there's an alternative to
adding the Google analytics tracking
code to your site and that's Google tag
manager so Google tag manager is the way
I would recommend going so if you're not
familiar with Google tag manager I would
recommend watching the YouTube video we
have on Google tag manager you can just
go to YouTube Type in simply learn
Google tag manager and this will give
you a nice overview of you know what
Google tag manager is and how it works
but basically this is the way I would go
and I would recommend that in addition
having Google analytics you set up a
Google tag manager account and then that
way you can put the tracking code in
Google tag manager so if I go to Google
tag manager and I just go into an
account on tag manager I can just simply
put in the Google analytics ID right
into tag manager and so if I have it in
tag manager then tag manager is going to
be the place that holds the code and
fires page view when somebody comes to
my website so that way I don't have to
add the tracking code to my website if I
do it in tag manager so that's the
recommended method for me is to add the
Google analytics ID associated with tag
manager if you can associate it with tag
manager then that's the easier route to
go versus putting code on your website
okay so again take a look at the video
we have on YouTube for Google tag
manager that's the route I would go now
once you do get the tracking code on
your website whether that be through
Google tag manager or through a Plugin
or you know just simply adding the
script to your site to pages on your
site then what's going to happen is
you're going to start collecting data so
that's ideally the way it works you need
to add this code to your website now if
you're not ready to do that and you
simply want to basically understand how
Google analytics works then I would
recommend getting access to Google
analytics demo account and so if you
just type in and search Google analytics
demo account basically what you're going
to do you're going to choose the first
listing there and you're going to go to
demo account so if you have a Google
analytics or Google login then all you
need to do is click on access demo
account and so what Google's going to do
is put this demo account into your
account and so it's going to look
something like this so if I click on
demo account here it's going to add to
my Google analytics account so I'm going
to have then access to the demo account
from Google and Google analytics so I
would recommend going this route here if
you're not familiar or you're not sure
what you're getting yourself into so
think of the demo account as kind of a
test drive you're test driving Google
analytics before you even add any code
to your website so again all you need is
a Google account and if you have a
Google account and you add the demo
account to your Google analytics account
you're going to be able to see how
analytics works okay and so that's what
I would also recommend so if you're not
ready to start adding code to your
website then what you can do is just
simply add the demo account and then
once you add the demo account you're
free to peruse around Google analytics
to see the different types of reports it
has to offer now when you do actually
set up a Google analytics account you're
going to have some settings that you're
going to want to pay attention to so
when you set up the account you have the
account name and then you have a
property so under each property you have
by default you're going to have one View
and so here you can see this view here
so if we look at the account we set up
we set up a demo simply learn account
property is demos simply learned so
that's associated with the website we're
going to track and then again by default
under each property you're going to have
a view and so by default the name of the
view is going to be called all website
data and so in that view is where all
your analytics data is going to be
stored so you can see my screen here
there's a lot of different settings you
have you have settings under the account
you have settings under the property and
you have settings under the view so
we're going to talk more about these
settings and future webinars for
advanced Google analytics users but for
now know that there's a bunch of
settings that you have that you can play
around with when it comes to Google
analytics anything from adding users to
your Google analytics account your
Google analytics property or view you
can actually set up goals you can set up
filters you can set up segments you can
link up Google ads you can you know set
up remarketing list there's a lot you
can do in terms of the settings as it
relates to Google analytics but so know
those settings are there they're located
right down here in this little sprocket
icon that's the admin icon so if you
need to get to these settings at any
time you could simply just click on the
sprocket or the admin icon and then
you'll be prompted to choose any one of
these settings here that you want to
edit or alter so now let's take a look
at some Google analytics reports so once
you've actually set up your account you
have a number of different reports that
you have available to you in Google
analytics so we're going to take a look
at you know customized reports we're
going to look at real time audience
reports acquisition behavior and
conversion so these are all the
different reporting buckets if you will
that you have available to you in Google
analytics so if I'm in admin and I'm
looking at the Google demo account let's
start out by looking at real time so if
I click on the real time report and I
just click on overview so basically what
this is going to do is show me at this
point in time how many users I actually
have active on the website okay so
that's why they call it real time
reporting because it allows you to see
the behavior of users who are currently
on your website and so this is the
overview report under real time and you
can see here I can see that 79 percent
of my users are coming from desktop 18
20 are coming from mobile and then
approximately three percent are coming
from tablet here I can see how they
actually came to the website so this is
the referring Source if they came from
say search or social I can see the
source there and I can see what pages
they're active on and then here I can
see what locations where they're located
and so if I want to see a breakdown of
everything in the overview I can
certainly do that if I go to locations
under real time I could see a majority
of my users are coming from the United
States okay where are they coming from
I'll just click on traffic sources and
here I could see the different sources
and mediums medium is the means in which
the traffic was driven so if it's Google
it's either paid search or organic
search so I can see here it's organic
then I can actually see what contents
they're looking at on my website so I
could see currently I have three active
users on the home page two active users
on the Google's women's white t page so
forth and so on now most importantly if
you have a vent tracking set up so if
you taking a look at our Google tag
manager webinar you know that you could
set up event tracking in Google
analytics to measure engagement on your
website whether that be a form
submission or somebody clicking on the
play button of a video so if I click on
events I'll be able to see what events
are firing so here I can see we have
event tracking set up and I can see how
many different events are firing on my
website in real time so here I can see
e-commerce somebody clicking on the
quick view click some a couple of users
clicking on add to cart a couple of
users clicking on the promotion click
and as these events are fired you're
going to be able to see them highlighted
so if something gets fired it's going to
get highlighted and I could see that
these are the current events that I have
currently firing on the website and
that's what's currently fire now if I
want to look at the events that have
happened in the last 30 minutes I could
just click on this link here last 30
minutes and it's going to give me an
overview of the events that have
happened over the past 30 minutes okay
so that's event tracking and then more
importantly we can also look look at
what conversions are happening in real
time just by clicking on conversions and
so now I can see I had one active user
who entered the checkout so that's goal
number four so in analytics you can have
up to 20 goals and so here I can see we
have goal number four has already had
one active user and so if I look at the
last 30 minutes I can see I still have
only one goal over the last 30 minutes
and that was somebody who entered the
checkout so that's real time reporting
in summary it just gives you an idea of
what's currently happening on your
website and so for me ideally if I'm
launching a campaign or let's just say
you do a new website redesign and you
want to see how users performing and
behaving then real time is a good option
for you so you could see how things are
happening in real time now let's jump
down to audience reporting so if I click
on audience this is just right
underneath real time I'm gonna see a
number of different reports available to
me under audience and so let's click on
the audience overview report so audience
reporting basically allows us to get a
sense of who is coming to our website
when I say who is coming to our website
it doesn't necessarily have to be a
specific person in fact Google doesn't
allow personally identifiable
information in Google analytics personal
identifiable information such as a
specific name uh social security number
credit card information
Etc however we can still paint a nice
picture on who is coming to our website
meaning what country city or state did
they come from what language what device
do they get to our website from how old
were they okay were they male or female
or other what interests do they have
what browser do they use so we can paint
a nice picture based on all this
information that Google analytics is
providing us under audience so if I go
to audience overview here I can see I
have all these different options
available to me to get a basic
understanding of who is coming to our
website so for example I could see a
majority of the people coming to our
website speak English and are from the
United States okay in fact that
represents 61 of the users and so Google
analytics does a great job of giving me
an overall percentage so if I have a
hundred percent of the users I could see
61 percent of those users represented
English-speaking users from the United
States seven percent represented English
speaking users from Great Britain and so
when it comes to analytics we have users
and users are broken down into two
categories they're either returning or
they're new so when you add the Google
and Alex tracking script to your website
what's going to happen is if a user or
when a user goes to your website they're
going to get cookied if it's the first
time they've been to your website what
Google analytics is going to do is store
a cookie in the browser so when that
same user comes back another day in the
same browser analytics is going to
recognize that that cookie is in the
browser and so then analytics is going
to categorize that user as a returning
user okay so that's how analytics is
able to differentiate new versus
returning so if that user doesn't have a
cookie in the browser then analytics is
going to recognize that store the cookie
and then count that user as a new user
and so when you're looking in analytics
you're going to be able to see a
breakdown of new versus returning so
here I can see over three quarters of my
traffic over the past week here I can
see April 6 through April 12th three
over three quarters are new users to the
website here I could see about 23 24 are
returning users okay so I can get a good
breakdown of what type of users are
coming am I driving new traffic am I
driving traffic that's been to my
website before what language are they
speaking okay I can also paint a bigger
picture how old are they are they what
gender are they do they come from mobile
so let's take a look at some of these
different reports under audience and so
if I skip down now to demographics I can
click on overview and when that report
loads I can see now under demographics
overview I can see the breakout of age
ranges and so here I can see the
majority of the traffic coming to my
site again over the past week now if I
want to change this date range I could
simply do that I can change the date
range just by clicking on the date range
and then maybe going say the last 30
days and I can even compare it to the
previous pair period or the previous
year I'm going to choose the last 30
days I'm going to click apply now I'm
looking at data over the last 30 days
and again you can change the date range
to any range you want you can only go
back as far as when you actually created
the Google analytics account you can't
go prior to that so here I'm looking at
the last 30 days and I can see almost 47
of my users were in their age range of
25 to 34. now when it comes to gender I
can say 66 percent represent males so I
can get a breakout of gender and age as
well as interest and click on interest
and look at the overview there and see
what the interest is of the users who
are coming to my site based on in-market
segments or Affinity I can also choose
language and location so if I want to
know exactly where my users are located
located when they're coming to my
website I can click on location and here
I can get a breakout 43 percent of the
users of the last 30 days were from the
United States more importantly I can
align my audience with goals and we'll
talk about goals here in a minute but
here I can see if I have an e-commerce
website I can see of those 43 percent
0.29 percent of those converted or
purchased something and that equates to
94 transactions so I can get a good
sense of not only how many users are
coming from a specific country but are
those users converting if I click on
mobile and mobile to me is one of those
reports I tend to spend a bit of time on
because I want to know what devices
users are coming to my website and so
for my website here or this is the
Google demo website I can see mobile
represents approximately 27 percent of
the traffic so desktop still represents
a majority of the traffic so for you you
want to keep an eye on mobile because
mobile is definitely a majority of what
people use nowadays that's how people
start their day that's how they transact
Via Mobile whether that's purchasing
something communicating or searching it
all starts with mobile so you want to
keep an eye on mobile and more
importantly you want to keep an eye on
Behavior so Google analytics is telling
me that yes I have approximately 27 of
my traffic of the last 30 days came from
mobile how are they interacting with my
website so if I look across this report
I'm going to be able to see different
metrics so if I'm measuring specific
metrics against my dimension in this
case the dimension is what we're
measuring and in this example we're
measuring mobile I can see that the
bounce Ray is approximately 48 percent
and bounce rate means that if a user in
this case for mobile landed on a page
they left the site without going any
further so they consider it a bounce if
they don't go to another page if they
leave the site from the page they landed
on and they don't go any further that's
considered a bounce so bounce rate is
the percentage of people who come to the
site and leave the site without going
any further so in this case we have 48
bounce rate that's almost half of our
users who come from mobile leave the
website from the page they landed on so
is that good is that bad well it's open
to interpretation is definitely
subjective but you want to keep the
bounce rate as low as possible you want
to keep people on your site especially
if you have an e-commerce website you
want people who come to your website to
purchase and so here we can see 4 38
mobile and desktop it's a little bit
lower at 41 now if I look a little bit
further at engagement I can see how many
pages on average do mobile users look at
so versus desktop it's a little bit
lower you can see 3.86 on desktop it's
4.5 now if I look a little bit further
in engagement I want to be able to
measure how long somebody from mobile
stays on the website if they're bouncing
at 48 percent but they're also looking
at 3.8 Pages 3.9 almost four pages per
session then that means in this report
analytics is telling me they're spending
about two minutes on the site and
interestingly enough I can see that
mobile of the last 30 days had more
transactions so 51 transactions versus
34 transactions from desktop and
interestingly enough the e-commerce
conversion rate is at 0.29 percent
that's higher than desktop at .07 it's
lower than tablet but it's higher than
desktop and mobile has the most
transactions and since they have the
most transactions they have the most
Revenue at 2 380. so yes the engagement
isn't exactly as great as it is as
desktop but we can see that people are
still purchasing with their mobile
devices so it's something to keep an eye
on and mobile is something I definitely
look at in fact since it's such an
important report one thing you can do in
analytics is if you actually like a
report and you think you're going to
look at that report multiple times then
you can simply just go ahead and click
save at the top here so if I click save
I'm going to enter a name for this
report I'm just going to call it mobile
report and click OK and then what's
going to happen is it's going to be
located under save reports and save
reports is low located under
customization customization is located
above real time okay so if I close that
up you can see audience real time
customization if I click on
customization if I click on Save reports
I should be able to see my save report
here and I do so here I can see mobile
report if I click on it I can simply go
to the report I was looking at before I
saved it so save reports to me is a good
feature in analytics because it allows
you to quickly access a report that
you've saved in the past so let's take a
look at one more report under audience
and let's go to benchmarking so remember
when we're setting up our analytics
account we had the option to opt into
benchmarking and I recommended you do so
and so if you did I actually opt into
benchmarking then you're going to be
able to see how your site compares to
others in the same industry so if I
click on benchmarking and then click on
channels what I'm actually able to do
now is compare my website with others in
the same industry so if I go back to say
jobs and education and I choose
education all education as my industry
vertical I should be able to see
websites that are in the same particular
industry and how I compare with those
websites so I'm choosing all countries I
can narrow that down if I wanted to I
can just search for the United States I
can choose a specific State and then I
can choose a particular site size so
here I'm choosing sites by daily session
so these are sites that have an average
of 5 000 to almost 10 000 sessions a day
and so in this vertical education in the
United States sites that have five
thousand to
9999 sessions per day that means that
they're approximately 310 web property
is contributing to this report okay
based on this criteria I chose now if my
site is similar meaning if I'm in the
United States if I'm in education and
I'm receiving 5 000 to 9 999 sessions
per day then I'm able to compare my site
against 310 other websites now Google
sharing this data anonymously from the
other websites and they're doing the
same with your website to those
particular websites benchmarking reports
okay so it's a shared data anonymously
in particular Industries and verticals
and so now I'm looking at a channel
report so if I want to see how I compare
to others in my industry then I can go
ahead and see by channel for example in
my driving as much traffic as others in
my industry and you can see I'm not in
fact I'm 76 77 worse in terms of the
amount traffic being driven from organic
search so anything in red is going to
show as a negative result a negative
comparison whereas something in green is
a positive comparison so if I look at
engagement I can see that I might not be
driving as much traffic but I can see
that the pages per session are better
than the site average or the industry
average I can see if I go over again
looking just at organic search I can see
the bounce rate is better than the
industry average so the channel report
under benchmarking allows you to measure
how you compare to others in your
industry and you could do so by looking
at location and devices so if you opted
into benchmarking when you set up your
account then you'll be able to compare
your website against others in your
industry in your country region and
based on the size of your website in
terms of how many visitors or sessions
you're getting per day so let's go from
audience to acquisition so if audience
is who is coming to your website
acquisition allows us to see how the
traffic was driven to your website so
how do these users get to our website
and so under acquisition if we click on
overview we'll be able to see an
overview of how users whether they're
returning are new came to our website
and so what analytics does by default is
they have a number of default channels
and when we say channels we mean
analytics is grouping different channels
based on how users got to your website
meaning how did users get to our website
did they come via organic search meaning
do they type something into Google and
find you in the organic listing
analytics also groups users based on
whether they came to your site directly
meaning did they type in the URL
directly into the browser or did they
bookmark your website site and come back
via the bookmark so they're grouping
users under direct they also group users
under referral meaning do they come from
another website they group users by
social do they come from a social media
platform like Twitter or Facebook if
you're running paid search meaning if
you're running paid search on say Google
then do they come from Paid search ads
now if you're running display ads on say
Google's Network Google's Display
Network that's a default channel so
analytics for group users there so if
they don't recognize a channel then
they're going to group it as others so
by default Google analytics groups users
and how they came to your website via
these default channels and so I can see
how many users came to the site from
each Channel now if I want to drill down
on this report I can click on all
traffic and then if I click on all
traffic I can go to channels I can look
specifically at the channels report it's
so so now I can see organic search again
over the last 30 days is the number one
channel driving traffic and they
represent approximately again you can
see this number here in parentheses next
to the raw number of users I can see
that number's about 56 percent so 56
percent of my traffic over the last 30
days came from organic search and so
those are the number of users again as a
metric you're also going to have
sessions and you'll see sessions a lot
as a metric so users are broken down
between new and returning so every time
a new or returning user comes to the
website basically what they're doing is
initiating a session so you can have a
user who can come back multiple times
every time they come back to the website
it's a session so session is simply the
start of somebody coming to your website
and the session ends when they leave the
website and and so just like we looked
at with the audience reports when it
came to mobile we can also look at
engagement by channel so just like
mobile we looked at bounce rate pages
per session average session duration we
can do the same thing here with our
Channel report more importantly in
addition to behavior we can see
conversions and since we're running an
e-commerce platform we could see what
the conversion rate is by channel so
organic search did drive the most
traffic and they did have the most
transactions over the last 30 days and
the conversion rate in this case is 0.17
okay so how Google determines the
conversion rate they basically take the
number of transactions and divide that
by sessions so that means that over the
last 30 days organic search drove 38 123
sessions and of those 38 000 123 64
actually turned into a transaction which
equates to 0.17 which also equates to 3
000 in Revenue so I'm able to determine
not only how users are getting to my
website by looking at the channel report
I can actually see if they're engaging
and if they are converting and notice
when you look at a report in analytics
you can look at it by Channel you'll
also get a summary so here I can see a
summary or a total based on my date
range so I could see over the last 30
days I've had 54 000 users 49
000 of them were new okay that meant
that out of those four fifty four
thousand users I had 70 000 sessions I
could see my average bounce rate was 43
percent the pages per session were just
over four and the average session
duration how long did somebody stay on
my website on average about 2 minutes
and 50 55 seconds the average conversion
rate was 0.14 and I had a total of 97
transactions totaling 5500 okay and
that's all over the last 30 days so any
report you look at in analytics is going
to have a summary and note that any
to allow you to save it so if it's a
report you think you're going to go back
and look at at a future date then you
simply just have to click on the save
button conversely if you don't want to
save it you can simply just export it so
you can export it as a PDF if I click on
PDF it's going to allow me to export
that as a PDF now you have other options
available to you as well you can do a
Google sheet you can export it as an
Excel or you can export it as a common
delimited file so here you can see I can
save it as a PDF if I want to and if I
click OK it's going to save to my
desktop or location of my channel using
and then I can go back and look at it in
that format at a later time so that's
the export feature available to you in
analytics again if you you could save it
as well or you can export it okay some
other reports under acquisition if
you're running Google ads note that you
can connect Google ads to analytics and
this is key because now I can see how
many people are coming from Google ads
to my website and are they converting
now this is important because with
Google ads I'm actually paying for the
click so you can see here I'm running a
report based on campaign data so I could
see what campaigns are driving traffic
how much a pain per click and you can
see on average I'm paying 34 cents per
click and then more importantly I want
to be able to see if they're converting
so you can see I've spent 810 dollars
over the last 30 days and received 850
58 dollars in Revenue so you want to
make sure that you link up your Google
ads account to your Google analytics
account for this very reason you want to
be able to see how your Google ads
campaigns perform once the users get to
your website and so I want to see if
they're engaging and I want to see if
they're converting so they're all sorts
of reports under Google ads so you can
look at it by keywords by search queries
by hour of the day if you're running
display campaigns you can look at
display targeting says all sorts of
reports under Google ads you just have
to link it up and you link it up under
the admin now there are other reports
that you can look at so if I go to
campaigns I can look at all campaigns so
if you're running all sorts of different
types of campaigns whether that be on
Facebook whether it be email whether
that be you know other types of
advertising let's just say Twitter or
Instagram you're going to be able to see
those campaigns here and that's under
all campaigns and again you'll be able
to see the campaign name and you'll be
able to see metrics associated with
those campaigns and more importantly
you'll be able to see your e-commerce if
you're running e-commerce platform or if
you have goals set up so you'll be able
to look at how your campaigns are not
one not only driving traffic but two are
they converting let's go from
acquisition reporting to behavior so
Behavior reports are going to actually
show you how users behaved once they got
to your website once they landed on a
page on your website how did they behave
so when we looked at audience we got a
sense of who is coming with acquisition
we get a sense of how the traffic got to
our website did they come from organic
direct social Etc the behavior reports
allow us to actually measure how that
traffic behave once they landed on a
page on our website and so if I go to
overview under Behavior now I'm looking
at this graph here it's showing me how
many pages I've had and a page view is
simply once a page is viewed it's
counted as a page view so if a user
comes to my site they're initiating a
session and if they look at a page then
that page is going to have a page view
okay so a user can look at a page
multiple times in a session and every
time they look at that page it's going
to count as a page view so here I can
see in this graph how many pages I've
had again over the last 30 days and if I
look further at my overview report I can
see the specific pages and how many
pages they've had and I can also look at
some other metrics okay the average
bounce rate the average time on page I
can look at the exit rate which means
how many people actually exited or the
percentage of people who exited from
that page so I can dig deeper into my
behavior reporting so if I click on site
content and I click on all pages then
I'm going to look at a report by Page
this is my Dimension this is what I'm
measuring my page and now I can see how
many page views each page had over the
last 30 days now note you also have
something called unique page views so
unique page use is equivalent to one per
session in other words if a user came to
my site and looked at the home page then
the home page is going to have one
unique page view and one page view now
if the user in that same session looks
at other Pages then every page that user
looks at it's going to have one unique
page view however if the user goes back
to another to the same page in the same
session then it's still going to be one
unique page view but in this case the
home page if they look at the home page
a second time then the home page is
going to have two page views if they
look at the home page five times in one
session then the home page is gonna have
five total page views and one unique
page view okay so that's why unique
pages is equivalent to one per session
where pages is an accumulation of how
many times the page was viewed in the
same session so in other words you're
always going to have more page views
than unique pages okay so this gives me
a sense of how my pages performed so
again I can look at total page views and
then engagement so ideally what you want
to do with a report like this is if a
user is not engaging on the page then
that should tell you something about the
page itself if they're not engaging if
the bounce rate's high if the time on
page is low if the exit percentage of
exit rate is high then you probably want
to do something with that page now these
are all pages but if I jump down to
landing pages my landing page report is
showing me how many people people
actually landed on that page and so here
I can see under my landing page report I
can see the home page had 36 000 17
sessions in the last 30 days that's how
many people landed on the home page so
here I can see 71 percent were news
sessions meaning that I had a lot of new
users who landed on the home page in
fact 25
000 or 52 percent of the people who
landed on the home page were new I could
see the bounce rates about 42 percent
but of those who didn't bounce they went
on to look at about 4.5 pages per
session and spent about three minutes on
the site and the one thing I like about
the landing page report is they can also
see whether that particular page in this
case the home page did it help
contribute to a goal or conversion and
in this case I can see of those 36 000
sessions I had 20 32 transactions
totaling 1200 in revenue and that's an
e-commerce conversion rate of 0.06
percent so the home page over the last
30 days contributed to point zero six
percent of the revenue so this gives you
an idea of when somebody lands on your
website and they land on a page is that
page helping to move that person along
meaning are they not bouncing and is
that page helping to move people towards
converting and so that's what the
landing page in effect allows us to
measure is the engagement and in this
case we're measuring transactions okay
so analytics also gives us some other
reports under Behavior including site
speed so site speed to me is an
important report to look at just like
the mobile report to me site speed is
important because with Google analytics
does is they take a sampling of pages
and in this case you can see if it
allows 30 days they sampled
2835 page views and of that sample they
came back and said the average page load
time is about four seconds now ideally
you want to keep it as quick as possible
I would say even under three seconds
okay now there are other factors
involved with page load time the browser
you're using the country that you're
actually browsing that page from might
know how to have the best infrastructure
you may not even be on the best internet
Network meaning you're on a cell network
or the Wi-Fi is not that gray or you can
be on a page that just has a lot of
images or a lot of code that may slow it
down so there are other factors involved
and so what Google analytics does is
show you what those factors are so here
I can see by browser what the average
load time is if I want to look at
Country I could see what country is
contributing to the load time now the
great thing about about the site speed
report is if I go to speed suggestions
okay what speed suggestions is going to
do is it's going to show me the page
load Time by Page and then it's actually
going to provide a link where I can
actually click on to get suggestions on
increasing the page load time so for
example I can look at this particular
page here this Google redesign shop by
brand slash YouTube page line number
five if I look at line number five I can
see the average load time of this page
is eight seconds almost nine seconds
okay that's an eternity to some people
now notice this link next to it so
Google's recommending seven total
suggestions so if I click on seven total
what it's actually going to do it's
going to open up a new window and it's
going to open up another Google report
called page speed insights and Page
speed insights is going to give me some
information about what I can do to
create foreign
correct the page load of that particular
page so look at the site speed report
it's important because there is a
correlation between site speed or page
load time and user behavior of that page
and there's also correlation between
page load time and a page ranking
organically on search so page load time
is very important it's so important that
I'm even going to save it so I'm going
to click save and click on speed site
speed suggestions as my name and click
OK and now that report is going to be
saved under customization under save
reports let's jump from Behavior to
conversions now conversion reporting is
arguably the most important section in
in Google analytics because what the
conversions reporting allows us to do is
see how people are converting or if
they're not converting on our website
and so in Google analytics we have the
opportunity to set up goals now you have
the opportunity to set up 20 goals in
your Google analytics View and so to set
up a goal okay so you're going to click
on admin and Under The View you're going
to see goals and so if you don't even
have goals the first step is to create
goals and so you have four different
goal types in analytics so you have
pages per session so how many pages per
session is so if your goal is set to say
three or two if somebody actually looked
at two or three pages per session it's
going to count as a goal okay so if I
look here I can see I have pages per
session set at 10. so that means that if
a user came to the site looked at more
than 10 pages per session then it's
going to count as a goal another goal
type is destination so destination means
that if somebody actually went to a
specific page then it it's going to
count as a goal and in this case I can
see here that the goal is set to this
particular page here and so when
somebody actually lands on that page
it's going to count as a goal now there
are two other goal ties we can look at
one is duration so just like pages per
session in our previous example is
somebody looked at 10 pages per session
it's going to count as a goal but
duration it's based on time so in this
particular case if you set up a duration
goal and the duration is set to say one
minute and 30 seconds then that means if
a user comes to my website and they
spend at least one minute and 30 seconds
then it's going to count as a goal okay
and then the fourth type of goal in
Google analytics is an event based goal
so when you set up event tracking you
could turn that event into a goal so if
somebody clicks on say the submit button
of a form you can turn that event into
to a goal so here you can see the
category equals contact form so you can
always verify if a goal works just by
clicking on verify this goal and in this
case this event is turned into a goal so
anytime somebody fires this event it's
going to count as a goal so you have
four different goal types in Google
analytics you have pages per session
destination event and duration and so
once you've set up a goal then you can
measure goals under conversions so now
if I look at goals overview I can be
able to see how many total goal
completions I've had so if I want to
look at it by goal I can just choose the
goal option here so if I want to look at
for example goal two engaged users this
was the pages per session I can see that
I had a conversion rate at 10 meaning
that I had 7 000 of all the users that
came to the website 7000 in goal
completions meaning
7106 users looked at 10 pages or more on
my website and so that's how you want to
be able to measure whether users
wherever they're coming from whoever
they are whatever Pages they look at you
want to be able to look at the
conversion reports to see if they're
actually converting based on the goals
you've set up whether that's pages per
session duration destination or event
goal conversion tracking reports can
help you measure who is actually
converting and the great thing about
Google analytics here is that I can
actually see by segments so the default
segment in a segment is just looking at
a specific user set so the default
segment is always all users however I
can choose a different segment so if I
want to choose instead of all users if I
want to choose Mobile Traffic I can
select Mobile Traffic hit AI so I'm
actually now looking at a subset of data
I'm looking at mobile traffic so if all
the mobile users have come to my site I
can see 1400 engaged or looked at 10
pages or more okay and that's a seven
percent conversion rate so the great
thing about Google analytics is you have
the opportunity to set up four different
goal types okay based on those goal
types you can go to goals overview and
look at the conversion rates of each
goal but you can also change the
segments of that particular goal to see
who exactly converted okay another
report I like under conversions is the
multi-channel funnel report so if I
click on multi-channel funnel basically
what this allows me to do is see how
different channels work together to
convert so remember the channel
reporting we looked at under acquisition
here I can see now how different
channels work together to drive the
converter version so if I look at three
channels direct organic and referral I
can see all three together drive two
percent of the conversions if I look at
direct and referral twelve and a half
percent if I look at direct and organic
12.24 so I can see how different
channels work together and so if I look
at top conversion paths as an example I
can actually see what channels how
channels work together to drive the
conversion so in this example I can see
over the last 30 days that my top
channel grouping was direct times two
meaning that somebody came to the
website directly meaning they typed in
the URL in the browser or they
bookmarked it and came to the site okay
they came the first time but didn't
convert but then they came back a second
time via direct and then converted so
that combination is my top conversion
combination over the last 30 days my
second best conversion gen grouping is
organic search and direct meaning that a
user came to the website via organic
search first did not convert and then
came back via direct the second time and
converted so basically what analytics
does is give credit to the last referral
meaning if you came to the website via
referral or referring website and
converted then the referring website's
gonna get the credit for the conversion
but analytics does a good job of showing
you how different channels work together
so a channel may drive a lot of traffic
like organic search but that traffic may
not convert the first time around for
number different reasons whether it
could be brand recognition Price
shopping reading content whatever the
case analytics is able to measure if
that channel actually did contribute at
a later point and in this case we could
see organic search drove traffic that
didn't convert art but that traffic came
back a second time via direct and did
convert so that's our second best
Channel grouping and so the
multi-channel funneling Report top
conversion pass to me is a good report
to look at so you can actually see not
only have channels work together but you
can see sources and mediums and
campaigns and how all that all those
different campaigns from different
sources work together to convert so
that's just a good report to look at
there are so many different reports
available in analytics there's so many
that we haven't even gotten to yet so my
advice if you look at the demo report
you can get a feel for each of these
reports under each section whether that
be audience acquisition Behavior or
conversions take a look at these reports
see what makes sense to you see what you
can use to improve your website
performance for this particular webinar
we're gonna jump into Google analytics
Direct play and spend all of our time
there because it's about learning
practical applications so goals are
important goals uh let me just say this
goals are in analytics something that
should be aligned with your business and
we call goals that are align with your
business kpis or key performance
indicators so it's very important as a
precursor that you know how to set up
goals in Google analytics because if
you're using Google analytics you want
to measure everything against the goal
so without further Ado let's jump right
into Google analytics so if I go to
Google analytics and I log in okay what
I want to do is go down to admin click
on admin here and admin will take you to
basically a screen that looks like this
where you have an account column you
have your property column and then you
have review column now The View column
is where you're going to go to set up
goals okay so every view in every
property has up to 20 goals okay so by
default in analytics you're going to
have at least one view for your property
so if I have a property I'm gonna have
at least one view but if I happen to set
up multiple views like you see here then
I know for every view I set up I have 20
goals to work with so where are those
goals so Under The View I'm going to
click on goals and now I could see I
have 20 at my disposal now you can see
here by clicking on the recording column
I can see I have in this particular
property this particular view I have
five goals that are active so you can
use up to 20 but you don't have to have
20 active Okay you can have one active
two active my recommendation is at least
have one one goal again when you set up
a goal you're going to measure
everything in analytics against that
goal okay so in this case we have five
particular goals we're measuring so we
have five active out of 20 total so if I
don't know no longer want to use a goal
I could simply just turn it off if I
want to continue using it just turn it
on okay it's that simple you could turn
on and off goals so here I already have
five set up so if you want to set up a
new goal the one thing you need to know
in Google analytics is in order to set
up a new goal okay you need to have edit
access at least the view level I would
say at the property level so you want to
make sure whoever's in charge of Google
analytics for your organization or if
you're in charge okay you simply just
want to go to user management and user
management you want to make sure the
email address you're using to log login
to Google analytics has at least edit
permissions so you're going to need edit
permissions to add new goals so I have
edit permissions I'm going to go to
goals and I want to set up a new goal
but before we jump in and set up a new
goal what is it that we want to achieve
that's really the question we want to
ask ourselves what is the goal of the
website well if it's somebody
downloading something okay are you
measuring that download via an event
okay are they filling out a form
submission before they download so if
they submit that form submission is that
the goal or do you have any Commerce
site is somebody purchasing something so
these are things you want to ask
yourself before you actually set up the
goal what is it that I'm trying to
measure now when you actually do go to
set up a goal you're going to click on
the red CTA button that says new goal so
analytics actually has some templates
that up for you okay you can see them
here okay if you're somebody's
registering online or creating an
account or reading review downloading
something sharing something you could
choose all of these options here what I
normally do is choose custom 99 of the
time I'm just going to choose custom it
doesn't really matter if you use the
template or not it's just a template is
basically some free pre-filled
configurations but my recommendation is
always just go with custom you want
total control over how to set up your
goal so we already have in mind what
type of goal we want to set up so for
example if somebody goes to fill out a
form submission and they go to a thank
you page after that well what's the URL
of that thank you page we want to be
able to track how many people go to that
page because we know if somebody does
type in or fill in a form submission
then goes to that page we know that they
filled out the form and so for example
if I go to continue I'm going to name my
goal first so I'm going to say thank you
page as an example notice analytics is
assigning an ID so notice this is goal
ID 15. that means that that's the next
available goal there are 20 goals
available in analytics and so what
analytics does is they group goals
together so one through five six through
ten eleven through fifteen sixteen
through twenty into goal sets so for
example goal 16 through 20 is part of
goal set for and why does Google
analytics combine these goals into
different goal sets well because it's
easier to measure and look at data by
goal sets so for example if I jump into
any report here if I go to all traffic
channels and I want to measure how many
goals by Channel I can look at it by
goal set so if I have goal set one
selected then I know any goal I have
active in there between goal ID one
through goal id5 I'm gonna be able to
see those goals and goal set one and now
I'm going to be able to measure every
goal I have active and goal set one
against the channel so if I choose goal
set two whatever goals are active there
goal set three Etc notice I don't have
any goals 16 through 20 active that earn
goal set four therefore I don't have
that option available to me so back to
admin the bottom left navigation again
goals okay we want to measure somebody
going to the thank you page we have
added access we're going to choose
custom as our goal setup we're going to
type in a goal name I'm just going to
say thank you okay this is goal 15. now
this is the important part Google
analytics has four different goal types
destination in duration pages per
session or screens per session to
screens per session is related to mobile
because Google analytics measures mobile
app activity and then you have an event
so we're going to cover all four of
these but for the sake of this simple
example I'm going to choose destination
why because if somebody goes to that
thank you page we're going to go ahead
and put in the thank you page as the
goal the goal URL so for example
destination is my choice I'm going to
click continue now this is where I'm
gonna put the URL so if my URL is just
simply thank you.html I can just go
ahead and put thank you.html or if it's
just thank you then I can just do thank
you depends on the website depends on
the URI structure so whatever that URL
is that's what you're going to put in
and when you're done you can verify it
so what Google analytics does is
actually will verify over the last seven
days if anybody's actually gone to that
particular page so if we click verify we
can see zero percent conversion rate so
that tells us that if this is the
correct URL then we've had zero percent
people go to that page this is just an
example however if you didn't see a
conversion then you might want to make
sure you check the URL here that you put
in and if you do see a conversion rate
then you know it's working so Google
analytics actually has options so we're
saying thank you is equal to so the
destination URL is equal to thank you or
thank you.html or thank you dot ESP or
whatever that thank you page is okay you
do have options so if you have a long
URL you could say it begins with and you
could say it begins with say thank you
so this is the logic we're going to say
hey if anybody goes to a URL that begins
with thank you then count it as a goal
or you could say equals to so if anybody
goes to a URL that equals two thank you
then count it as a goal you have one
more option Here regular expression so
Google analytics understands the
language of regular Expressions so
regular expressions are just special
characters used to communicate with
Google analytics in order to hone in on
exactly what you're trying to track so
we can always say you know starts with
or ends with so we can you know use
characters like the dollar sign ends
with or begins with so we can always do
that so you can use regular Expressions
as well if you're familiar with regular
Expressions if you're not then you don't
have to use them but there are special
characters where that you can insert in
that are used as regular expression so
if you're not familiar with regular
expression don't choose that option you
can choose the other option of equals to
or begins with now note that on all
three of these options I didn't put the
domain so if my domain is Amma Dash
foundation.org and then thank you I
don't need to put the domain because
analytics is already knows what domain
we're tracking so you don't have to put
in the domain here when you're entering
in in this case the Google URL so you
can omit the domain so when you put in
that URL you know that you have three
options to work with and then you always
always want to verify that goal URL you
always want to verify it because if you
see zero percent conversion and in this
case of the last seven days then that
should tell you something either your
goal is not set up correctly or you just
don't have any conversions either way
you want to double check that now when
it comes to the destination URL goal you
do have an option here for funnel so if
I turn on funnel then that means I have
the ability to track how people went
through my funnel so if I have a cart
and I want to be able to check how many
people go in and out of the cart then I
have the option of adding specific Pages
as part of the cart so we could say you
know step one which is basically cart we
could say step two is billing
information that could be slash billing
we could see step three is shipping
information slash shipping and then step
four could be you know confirm and that
could be slash confirmation so whatever
your url structure is for your cart and
it doesn't necessarily have to be a cart
basically all I'm doing is putting a
series of steps with URLs as each step
and why do I want to do that because I
can then track how many people go
through my funnel that I've created okay
so here I could see this is my funnel
that I've created for this particular
goal okay and the funnel is only
available for the destination URL so the
funnels available if you want to see
traffic through the goal okay and how
people go through the funnel and where
they drop off now you have an option
here to make the first step required so
if you make that first step required
then that means you're measuring the
funnel through the first step only now
if I turn that off then I'm measuring
the funnel through each step meaning
that I can measure people as they drop
in and out of the funnel where if it's
required the first step then I'm only
measuring traffic as it enters in the
top of the funnel so you have that
option available to you the funnel and
then for all goals you do have a value
so if somebody did actually convert Okay
Google analytics is going to count it as
a conversion and you can assign a value
so if you're not an e-commerce website
then you may want to think about
assigning value if you are an e-commerce
website then analytics has the ability
to track e-commerce revenue for your
website so you don't need to add a value
but in this case let's just say your
non-profit organization and you're
collecting donations
and on average over the past year every
donation that somebody contributed was
equal to five dollars well you can just
go ahead and put five dollars in there
as the value for that goal so that means
that if somebody did go to in this
example slash thank you and convert
analytics is going to count it as a goal
and then assign five dollar value
alongside that goal so if you're
non-ecommerce if you're say a non-profit
like this organization or your B2B and
you want to track some value then you
have that option there so with the
destination URL goal you have the option
of adding a funnel with all goal types
you have the option of adding a value
all goal types and we're going to go
through the rest of them you have the
option of verifying that goal so that's
the structure of setting up a goal
destination URL is just one goal type
we're going to talk about the other
three goal types because in Google
analytics there are four goal types
again destination is one of them with
destination as you do have the option
with all goal types is you have to be
able to choose your logic here so we're
going to cover that with the other three
but just know when you set up a
destination URL goal you have the option
of adding a funnel now when you actually
do set up a funnel what's going to
happen is analytics is going to measure
traffic as it goes to the funnel so
where do you look for that funnel in
information well you want to get out of
admin you want to go to the left side
navigation you want to click on
conversions then goals then funnel
visualization So based on the funnel you
set up you're going to be able to see
traffic as it goes through the funnel so
notice on this particular funnel we
don't have the first step required why
because I could see traffic as it goes
in and out of each step of the funnel so
let's go through this funnel and see how
people react so here I could see the
first step is the storefront page so
over this particular period of time I
had 84 sessions enter the storefront
page so out of those 84 I can see 21
left the storefront page 63 went on to
the next step in the funnel which is the
cart page I can then see 24 people went
on to the cart page directly and 5
exited the site altogether okay so that
gave me 87 total and from 87 I saw that
82 went on to the next page for the next
step what analytics does is they give
you a percentage so in the first step we
had 63 move on to the cart page out of
84 that's 75 percent so from the cart
page to the create your account page we
had 94 move on so we didn't have anybody
enter in the create your account page we
didn't have anybody leave to create your
account page so if 82 82 create your
account and then we have 82 move on to
the payment page so that's a hundred
percent okay we have one exit so we have
81 that proceeded to be on the payment
page which was purchase so 81 of 82 is
and we started with 84. so that gave us
Plus plus the 24 that we accumulated
along the way so that gave us a 75
percent funnel conversion rate so 75
percent of the people who entered in the
funnel went on to purchase okay so don't
be confused with the overall e-commerce
conversion rate so 75 is the funnel
conversion rate the overall conversion
rate for this particular goal is
18.45 percent over this particular
period of time why because that takes
into account all sessions that have won
to the website so 18 of all traffic went
on to convert but those that did go into
the final 75 converted so that's a look
at the funnel so if you set up a funnel
that's what it's going to look like you
have the option to measure everything
from step one and Beyond or measure as
traffic goes in and out of the funnel so
the purpose of this is we're going to be
able to see see where traffic drops off
how effective our funnel is what pages
we need to address in that funnel okay
so that's the whole point of the funnel
and the funnel is available with the
destination URL goal so if I go back to
admin if I go back to goals Under The
View I can actually see what that funnel
looks like so here we chose regular
expression so this is what the URL is
okay you can see our funnel in each of
the steps we have set up notice we're
using regular Expressions here and then
if we verify this goal we could see over
the past seven days 19 conversion rate
so that tells me something's working in
this particular with this particular
goal because we do have a conversion
rate okay so that's the destination URL
goals let's now talk about the other
three types of goals so the next goal
type we're going to talk about is pages
per session so if you're you're not sure
what type of goal to set up for your
website at the very least you should try
and set up either duration related goal
or pages per session related goal so
let's talk about the pages per session
so basically what this goal is going to
allow us to measure is for example if we
set the goal to three pages per session
then we're going to be able to measure
if how many people went to the site and
looked at three pages per session so
let's take a look at that goal so if I
open up the goal here I can see three
pages per session is what we're naming
it so basically what we're asking
analytics to do is anything greater than
two pages which would be three and
Beyond count as a goal so if anybody
comes to the site looks at more than two
pages three pages or more then it's
going to count as a goal and so here we
can verify it so if we verified over the
last seven days we could see a 4.12
conversion rate and that tells me that
four percent of my traffic over the last
seven days looked at at least three
pages or more so you're probably asking
yourself well what number should I put
in for the actual variable so in this
case we see two well what you want to do
is you want to look at on average let's
just say year to date you want to make
sure you have statistical significance
so you want to look at a period of time
so if you go to analytics go to audience
okay and then if you go to overview and
if I change my date range to year to
date I could see on average right now I
have 1.21 pages per session so that's on
average
so we don't want to make our goal one
page we don't want to make our goal two
pages we want to make it three so we
want to be able to basically measure at
a higher rate okay why do we want to
measure at a higher rate because if 1.21
is the average then two pages per
session really isn't moving the needle
so what we really want to do is get
people to stay on the site longer look
at Pages more during their session so
look at more pages and so we want to be
able to see what segment of the audience
is looking at more pages what channels
driving traffic that's looking at more
pages what pages are contributing to
more pages per session so the whole idea
is you want to hone in on what your goal
is and see what's working and then see
what's not working so you can make
adjustments the whole idea be on Google
analytics is to improves website
performance and so if our average is 1.2
then if we change it to just 2 it may
not be good enough so in this case you
know we want to up the bar a little bit
so we're going to choose three now you
can choose four or five that's perfectly
fine just know if your average is 1.2 I
wouldn't choose one page per session as
my goal and I probably wouldn't choose
two so I'd set the bar a little bit
higher now the third goal type available
in Google analytics is also engagement
related and that's duration so just like
pages per session we can measure how
long somebody stays on the website and
we could set up a goal for that so in
this case I have a goal set for one
minute 30 seconds so my goal type is
duration so if I click continue then
basically I'm asking analytics in this
case anybody who stays more than one
minute and 30 seconds on the website
count it as a goal and so so before you
actually put in the number of hours
minutes and seconds you want to look at
that average so if you go back to
audience overview here I can see a
minute and seven so do we want a minute
and 30 maybe we could do that maybe we
can go with two minutes so again the
whole point is you want to set the bar a
little bit higher than what the average
is and so here I could see over the last
seven days if I verify this particular
goal I can see eight percent of my
traffic over the last seven days stayed
on the site at least one minute and 31
seconds okay they stay greater than one
minute and thirty and so the whole point
is you can hone in because this is a
goal I can go in this is goal okay this
is a goal here and so I could see that
this is goal 13. so now I can go to
acquisition as an example I can go to
channels as an example since this is I
go this is goal 13 so that would be in
goal set three so I can actually see
what channel is basically driving that
goal okay in other words what channel is
driving traffic that is staying on the
side at least one minute 30 seconds and
so that's the whole idea behind goals so
likewise for pages per session we can go
into channels and here I can see we have
a over this period of time year to date
pages per session we have three percent
conversion rate and here I could see for
example organic search has a 13
conversion rate here I could see social
media has a ten percent so I could see
that or people coming from organic
search are staying on the site longer or
they're looking at more pages than any
other channel so just like duration or
destination or any goal you set up you
can measure that goal against any
Dimension just because his engagement
doesn't mean you can't you absolutely
can and so the whole point of Engagement
related goals is to figure out what's
driving traffic the site but what
traffic is engaging so you want to be
able to pinpoint that so you can improve
website performance now the fourth goal
type available in Google analytics is an
event so if you click on new goal
include custom click continue you have
the option to choose an event so an
event is something that you can measure
on your website that analytics can't
measure by default so if you want to
measure PDF downloads or clicks on
buttons or clicks on play buttons on a
video or click on a submit button or
click on an external link I mean you can
measure pretty much anything with an
event then you want to be able to turn
that event into a goal so let's quickly
summarize what an event is so again we
want to be able to measure a particular
event that happens on the website so in
order to do so we need to identify that
event so if I go to for example this
particular website here and I want to
measure how many times somebody clicks
on the Donate Now button well if I met I
can measure that as an event so when you
set up an event in analytics you have to
actually assign a category and an action
for that event so that's the first thing
you need to do when you identify an
event or let it go first you need to set
up the event in order to set up the
event you need to assign a category in
action okay so once you identify what
you want to track as an event on your
website you're actually going to go on a
tag manager or have your web Master go
on a tag manager and set up a tag and in
that tag they're going to assign that
particular category in action and so
here you can see we have this set up our
category is named donate now and our
action is click and that's what we want
to do we want to measure how many people
click on that donate Now button so
anytime somebody does that then the
category donate now is going to appear
in analytics with the action click so
when you actually do set up an event you
can go into analytics and you could test
that event so if I go to the website and
I click donate now Okay the reason why I
have this as an event is because I'm
taking to a third-party website to
handle the donations so here I can go
into analytics and now I can see a
category is being fired for header
donate with the action click so that's
my category and that's my action so that
category in action is what is firing
after somebody clicks on the Donate Now
button so if I want to turn this event
into a goal I can easily do that now
that I've set up the event now that I've
identified the category in action I want
to go back to admin and set up the event
with these parameters in place so just
turns out we already have the goal set
up so let's go through how this goal was
set up so first we chose custom we chose
event we gave it a name so has the best
practice when you actually set up a goal
as an event or turn an event into a goal
I would add the prefix event colon to it
and then that way when you're
identifying goals in your reporting you
know it's an event so I'm going to click
continue and now that I've actually have
set up the event already in Google tag
manager I giving it a category give it
an action okay see here you can see we
have a regular expression set up so
anything with the header donate or
donate is going to fire this goal so
over the last seven days I have a 0.81
conversion rate okay I could have easily
put in equals two and put in whatever
the action what or the category which is
donate now or I could have put action
equals click I could have done that as
well so let me show you another example
here so if I do this custom continue
events donate now here's my goal ID it's
going to be an event so all I need to do
is put in the category in action so
donate now and then click so that's all
I have to do and that's my goal so I can
verify it okay to see if anybody's fired
it and basically that's what I need to
do to turn that event into to a goal
okay so you need to set up for an event
first you need to identify the event set
it up and Google tag manager which is
another platform and once you've done
that then you have your category in
action once you have your category in
action you're again going to go into
analytics and then simply put in that
category and action into the appropriate
fields to set up your event related goal
now all events don't have to be turned
into a goal if you actually do set up an
event and you're not worthy of a goal
meaning it's not a kpi or a dozen align
with your business goals well don't fret
you can always just go to behavior okay
you can always go to events you can
always go to overview and measure your
events that way so here you can see all
of our events that are fired now we do
have this one turn into a goal so if
it's important for a business then we
want to make sure we we convert that
particular event into a goal okay if
it's not important for example
somebody's just clicking on a social
button then you don't necessarily have
to turn that event into a goal if you
don't want to know that it's sitting
here under events under Behavior so the
point I'm trying to make here if it's
important to your business and you're
already tracking it as an event via
Google tag manager then feel free to
turn it into a goal all you need is a
category all you need is that action and
so so one final note on that event
related goal just like any other goal
you can add a value okay so if I have an
event set up I can choose to add a value
here or in Google tag manager if I've
assigned a value to that event so if I
go back to the actual event and Google
tag manager you can see I have a value
set up for one dollar then I could just
go into analytics and say you know what
I already have the value added so go
ahead and use the value added in Google
tag manager okay so I'm going to choose
yes now if I choose no I have the option
to add the value here just like I would
with any other goal so just keep that in
mind you can add a value to any goal
type with an event related go you can
add the value right into the tag in
Google tag manager just as I've done
here so remember when you actually set
up your goals whether it's a destination
pages per session duration or an event
you can just go ahead and choose that
goal set that it's in and measure any
Dimension against that particular goal
so here I can see e newsletter sign ups
by Channel I can go into another goal
set here I can see contact form
submissions okay I can see what
particular channels driving contact form
submissions okay so just know that you
can align a goal against any Dimension
so if you have e-commerce you don't have
to set up for goal for that that's
separate but if you want to take a look
at your goals and analytics and on its
own you can just go to conversions goals
overview here I can actually get a good
sense of how my goals are performing
over a period of time so again if I
choose for example year to date now I
can see based on the goals I've set up
how many total goal completions value
which takes into account the value we've
added into these goals okay the total
conversion rate and here I could see it
broken down by the goal I actually have
set up and I can see it by Page or I
could see it by Source a medium so I
could see Google organic is driving the
most gold completions then Google CPC
direct and then I could see some others
in here as well out contributing to
goals now I do want to point your
attention to another report in Google
analytics that does take into account
goals and that's multi-channel funneling
so again under conversion goals
multi-channel funnels if I go to
assistant conversions I can actually see
what channel in this example is
assisting with the conversions I've set
up and so what do we mean by assistive
conversions well that means that if a
channel let's just say organic search
drove traffic to the website and that
traffic didn't convert when it arrived
at the website and left but it came back
a week later via another Channel let's
just say email and when they came back
via email they did convert during that
session well what analytics does is they
give an assist to organic search because
they help Drive the traffic to the
website so it's similar to the game of
basketball if I have the ball and I pass
it to my colleague and my colleagues the
one who scores because they had the ball
last well they get the credit for the
point I.E the conversion but I get an
assist and so analytics works the same
way they're always going to give credit
to the last click or direct conversion
but they will give credits to the
channel in this case that assisted with
the conversion so that's under assisted
inversion and that's based on the goals
you have set up you can highlight any
particular goal here if I want to hone
in on say the Donate clicks only then
I'm going to be able to see what
contributed to that particular goal so
there's another report in here top
conversion pass that I think is
important so after you set up your goals
you can actually see what channels in
this particular example help to Drive
conversions again this is year to day so
I can see all the different combinations
of channels that work together
to contribute to a conversion so again I
can choose a specific goal or I can
choose all my goals so those two reports
are under multi-channel funneling
there's also another report that I think
is good that's time lag meaning how long
did it actually take somebody to convert
so here you can see most of our
conversions 265 year-to-date happen on
the day somebody arrived on the website
but I could see I did get some
conversions a day later two days later
Etc so you have time lag top conversion
pass assistant conversions they're all
under multi-channel funneling and
they're all available after you set up
at least one goal and so if you're not
sure what goal to set up okay don't fret
you can always at least set up an
engagement related goal so that's
available to you duration pages per
session you also have destination and
event tracking and they're all available
to you you have 20 available per view
now if you're not quite sure exactly
what type of goal to set up there is an
option available in analytics and that's
the gallery so you can always import a
goal from the gallery so in other words
we could take a look at what other
people have set up in terms of goals so
you just have to click on the button
import from gallery and it'll take you
to the gallery and you'll be able to see
what are the goals others have set up
today we're going to talk about how to
set up event tracking in Google
analytics so let's get started so many
of you out there have a website similar
to the one I'm looking at now this is a
non-profit that I work with I'm a
foundation and like this website and
probably like your web website you
probably have some interactivity on
there that needs to be tracked for
example buttons uh if you have buttons
like this one that says donate or
newsletter sign up or there's a PDF
download or a video that needs to be you
know tracked based on the amount of
people who click on the play button so I
mean all sorts of inter activity on a
website have you ever wondered how to
track that well there is a way to track
that because by default Google analytics
can't track interactivity and engagement
on your website like you probably want
to have your website tracked so if you
have buttons and videos and things of
that nature that you want to attract but
you're going to need event tracking and
if you're in analytics and you're always
wandering around the data and you happen
to find yourself under events well if
you want events on your website and you
want data to populate under Behavior top
event events you're going to need to set
up event tracking so event tracking is a
two-part process and we're going to talk
about that two-part process the first
part of that is to identify what you
want to track okay so if we go back to
our example website here I'm a
foundation again we noted there's a lot
to track here we gotta donate now Bob we
got a newsletter sign up we have some
social icons okay we got a donate Now
button here we got a play button here
got all sorts of interactivity you know
we got a button here that says you know
purchase tickets for an upcoming event I
can go throughout the website and find
different buttons and things to to track
let me just say this there's no shortage
of what you can track on your website
with event tracking so event tracking is
just basically in layman's terms
tracking engagement on your site because
Google analytics by default is only
going to track page view data meaning
how somebody got to your website what
page they looked at how long they stayed
on that page what page they left from
more or less they're timing how long
somebody stays on the website and what
pages they look at so there's more to a
website than just how long somebody
stayed on a page and so in this example
we want to be able to track everything
here not just the Donate now but
everything because once you get the hang
of event tracking then it's very easy to
set up okay so step one identify what
you want to track okay so there's a lot
we want to track we're just going to use
one example to start off with and that's
going to be this donate Now button okay
so this donate Now button we want to
track now we have a newsletter sign up
we have Facebook and and that's fine you
could track all that but for the sake of
going through a step-by-step process
today let's just focus on the Donate Now
button what's focused on the donating
Now button then we'll come back and
start tracking these other things but
this is what we want to track to start
out with okay so step one identify what
you want to track now when it comes to
tracking events on a website you want to
identify those events so we did that by
choosing this donate Now button now once
we identify what we want to track we
need to assign two parameters for that
event so with event tracking you have
three parameters but one is actually
optional so you have two mandatory
parameters that you have to assign to
everything you want to track on your
website and that's the category and then
the action so event label or label is
the third parameter but again that's
optional okay so basically when we
identify an event on our website we want
to assign it a category and an action
okay so why do we want to assign it a
category in an action because when we're
in analytics under Behavior under events
top events we could see we have
different categories here and we have
different actions we have different
labels so if I click on any one of these
Dimensions I'm going to be able to see
some of the parameters I've entered in
for previous events I'm tracking okay so
the whole idea is you want to be able to
group different events together into a
category and assign an action and assign
a label to it that's really what you're
doing you're just grouping and
identifying the events you're trying to
track and so in this case I have this
donate Now button sitting in the header
okay in fact I have a lot of things
sitting in the header so if I wanted to
and I want to track all these buttons I
can create a category called header and
then if I track all these buttons all
these buttons can sit in that same
category if I wanted to or I can create
a separate category for each of these
buttons it's up to you how you organize
your categories because basically all
you're doing is giving a name to what
you're trying to track and the name is
equivalent to a category so in this case
the Donate Now button is very important
I'm just going to call it category head
or donate now I need to give an action
to each category and so in this case I'm
just going to say click because that's
what the action is doing it's it's
somebody's taking the action of clicking
now if it's a video and it's a play
button I can assign an action of play
it's up to you whatever you name these
parameters you just need to be organized
and methodical about what you name it
that's all and so in this case header
donate and then click okay and so that's
our category in action and so that's
clearly step two so step one identify
what you want to track step two assign a
category action and or label but
remember label is optional so if we go
back in analytics here I could see some
categories and if I click on action I
can see some actions that I've named now
step three so we've identified in step
one what we want to track we've assigned
a category in action so step three is
going into Google tag manager to set up
the event okay so if you're not familiar
with Google tag manager then you can
easily just you know do a Google search
for Google tag manager and basically
you'll have all sorts of information on
it there's a good video overview of tag
manager here that you can watch so tag
manager basically is what we want to use
to set up event track and now tag
managers use for a lot of different
things but the main thing we're doing
here is setting up an event for our
website and so I'm logged in to the same
email address I'm using for analytics
okay so now I'm in tag manager and I
want to set up my event for this donate
Now button so what do I need to do well
for every event I want to set up I need
to set up a tag okay so if I go to tags
I can see I already have some tags set
up and some of these are events and so
when you actually set up a tag I
recommend having a naming convention so
here you can see any event we set up we
start out by calling it GA Dash event
Dash whatever it is we're trying to set
up and so in this case we want to set up
a new tag for the Donate Now button on
our website so we're in Google tag
manager because tag manager is what's
going to fire that event so if I click
on new okay and I click on tag
configuration I'm going to choose Google
analytics and then I'm going to choose
event as my track type so we want the
data to show up in Google analytics and
we're tracking an event we're not
tracking a page we're tracking an event
and so now remember in step two you
identified what you want to call that
category you identify what you want to
call that action action and you have
some optional parameters like label so
first things first header donates the
name of our category and our action is
click and if you want to add in a label
and a value so if you want to sign a
value you can if you want to add in a
label you can okay those are optional so
you just need to focus on category in
action and then the last setting here
that's probably worth mentioning is a
non-interaction hit okay so this is
automatically set to false and why is it
set to false because it's a
non-interaction no that's false we want
this event if somebody clicks on the
header donate to be an interaction so
for example if I land on this page here
and I click on that donate Now button
that I'm tracking as an event and I
actually leave the site because I have
my settings set to false I want that
click to be an interaction then
analytics is now not going to count a
bounce if I change it to true so from
false to true then that means it is
going to be a non-interaction if
somebody lands on the page and if
somebody clicks on the button so I don't
want it to be a balance I want it to be
an interaction so my advice is leave it
set to false we're going to choose
Google analytics as our setting here
this is our variable for Google
analytics so in other words that
variable is set to our analytics
property ID and more or less that's what
you need to do to set up the tag okay
you need to in step two identify the
category in action and or label and or
value now value can be anything you want
you're signing a numerical value so if
you just assign one anytime that event
fires in analytics it's going to have a
value of one okay and so we have our
non-interactions at the fall so anytime
the event fires it's going to account as
an interaction and therefore not count
as a bounce if somebody landed on that
page so that's more or less all you need
to do to set up the tag in the Google
tag manager now if somebody else is
setting up the tag for you then again
you want to revert to step two you want
to be able to give that person the
appropriate category action and or label
and or value why because you're the one
that's going to be going into Google
analytics and you're the one that's
going to have to go to behavior events
top events and look for the particular
at category in action and or label so
you need to be able to communicate that
information to whomever is setting up
the tag now if it's you great you
already know what it is because you're
entering that information into tag
manager so in this case I'm going to go
ahead and choose a variable for my label
parameter and why do I want to do that
because in tag manager I have something
at my disposal called variables and
variables allow you to see specifically
things that are being tracked so in this
case I chose pagepath okay so pagepath
is a URL and why did I choose pagepath
as my variable for the parameter label
because if somebody does click on the
header donate button and the header
donate button on our website is on every
page so if I go to the children's page
I'm still going to see that header
donate button and so for me I want to be
able to see what page somebody clicked
on that hit or donate button and so this
allows me to actually see in Google
analytics what page somebody clicked on
the header donate Now button and so now
if I go back to GTM Google tag manager I
have a category I have an action and I
have a label which is a variable okay so
note that in Google tag manager you have
a lot of different variables at your
disposal and variables are there to help
you identify specifically what is being
tracked so take a look at all the
variables at your disposal and tag
manager in this example I'm using page
path so now once you set up your tag
pretty straightforward again tag types
Google analytics track type is event you
are assigning the category action and or
label and or value you're changing or
leaving the default in place for
non-interaction hit and then you're
choosing the variable for Google
analytics which is your property ID so
once you've done that you have a tag the
second part of setting up a tag is to
assign a trigger to that tag so tag
manager needs to be able to know when to
fire that event and so here I'm going to
look at a trigger I've already set up
for the this particular event and so if
I click on it I'll be able to see that
what it is it's a click on some links
not all links but some links I'm
actually saying Hey Google tag manager
fire this event when the click ID equals
header donate button now it just so
happens that if somebody did click on
this donate Now button they're gonna go
to another website in this case
networkforgood.com so in tag manager I
could have set the trigger to equal URL
equal instead of Click ID I could have
said URL equal
networkforgood.com so that could have
been my Logic for my trigger in this
case I decided to go with the click ID
and so in this case that button has an
ID associated with it called header
donate button so if you wanted to use
click ID for your event for your button
you could simply just go to the website
you can right click on that button and
click inspect element and so when I
actually inspect the element I can see
now the button here you can see it's
highlighted in the upper Pane and in the
lower pane I can see where it's linking
to it's linking to networkforgood.com
but here you can see if I hone in a
little it I could see ID equals header
Dash donate dash button so that's the
click ID notice there's also a class I
could have set the trigger to equal this
class or again I could have set the
trigger to equal the URL or the page
that this button is pointing to I could
have chosen any one of those but I
decided to go with the ID so this is the
ID I chose and that's the ID I have in
my trigger okay so that is what's going
to fire that event so if somebody clicks
on a button that equals header Dash
donate dash button it's going to fire
that event which is going to equal
category header donate action click and
then the label is going to be page path
so now that we've set up our events we
want to test to see if it actually works
so there's two ways to go about testing
an event and the first way is through
Google analytics so if we go to Google
analytics and then we go to real time
okay we can go to events and here you
can see one is already fired so let's go
ahead and go to and test this and go to
the website so if I go here for example
and I click on omagar alumni okay so if
I click on that you can see I'm under
our family and if I click on that button
then go back to analytics and look at
real time I should be able to see this
event fire so if I click on it I'm going
to go to network for good now if I go
back to analytics here in real time
under real time under events per second
I can see that event firing category
equals header donate the action equals
click now if I click on the category
here I can see the label the label
remember was page path and here you can
see this event fired on the our family
page which was the page I was just on so
that's one way to test to see if your
event works and in this case analytics
recognize the event so it works it fired
and so therefore it's going to show up
under Behavior under events you can go
under overview or top events okay and
what am I going to look for in this case
I'm going to look for header donate okay
if I click on hit or donate as my
category I'm going to be able to see my
action and if I click on action I'll be
able to see my label in this case home
page and then later on when the data
propagates in analytics I'll be able to
see under label the page that I clicked
on that header donate button which is
slash our family okay the second way in
which you can test to see if an event
fires is if you preview so if I click on
preview in tag manager okay I'm going to
go into preview mode okay in preview
mode allows you to see in analytics and
tag manager and on the website what tags
are firing so here I could see I'm in
preview mode now so I'm going to go to
the website and I'm going to refresh and
in my browser same browser I'm using for
tag manager I can see the tags that are
being fired on this page already okay
because I'm in preview mode so here I
could see remarketing I could see page
views I could see Google optimize I
could see some tags that are already
firing on this page now if I click on
this button here by holding down my
shift command and then click on that
button I'll be able to see that the tag
fired in preview mode there's my event
header donate and I can see it fired so
now I can see it fired in the preview
mode so in addition to Google analytics
in preview mode I could see that that
tag is fired and I know that it's
working so there you have it you have
two ways to test to see if the event
fires again you have real time in
analytics okay so in real time if you
just go up to real time all you need to
do is go down to events go to your
website click on the button if you see
it firing in real time then you know it
works the second version or second way
to test your event is through the
preview mode okay if you see it firing
in preview mode then you know it's also
working okay so let's rehash our steps
first step is we want to be able to
identify what we want to track okay so
it could be this newsletter sign up it
could be click on a Facebook it could be
anything we want to be able to track an
image a click on a CTA button whatever
we want to track identify it second step
identify the category action and label
because that's what's going to show up
in Google analytics remember label is
optional variable or excuse me value is
optional third step go into tag manager
actually set up your tag and your
trigger so if you set up a tag and it's
an event name it GA Dash events that way
you can see in your list of tags and tag
manager what event tracking you have
already set up so when you set up your
tag you set up your trigger your trigger
is based on logic that can be a URL it
can be a click ID it can be a class ID
whatever you want to use to fire that
event and then once you do that you want
to test it you could test it in GTM or
you could test it in Google analytics if
it doesn't fire you want to tweak your
trigger if it does fire then great and
then one thing I would recommend is if
you're setting up various events for
your website as a best practice what I
would recommend is set up a spreadsheet
and in that spreadsheet you know you
want to put a note what's firing what
are you doing to fire it could be in
this case someone somebody clicks on the
Donate Now button in the header you want
to put the tag name in here the type
okay then you want to record your
category action and label and then the
great thing about events is you could
turn those events into goals and that's
as simple as going back into analytics
okay so if I go in analytics and I go to
admin and I go to go goals if you set up
a new goal okay all you need to do is
choose custom click continue you're
going to choose event as your goal name
and then from a naming perspective in
Google analytics for your goal I would
definitely put event first and then
click on header donate okay so if I
click now continue what is my category
it's equal to head or donate my action
is click and so I can verify to see if
this is working and here I can see in
analytics that the goal would have a
0.22 conversion rate so that tells me
that the goal is working and I can turn
this event into a goal and when you turn
something into a goal in analytics then
you can measure it across all dimensions
that's what I would recommend if the
event is equal to a kpi or business goal
or it's of importance it's something you
really want to measure okay it's just a
click say on a Facebook button I
wouldn't recommend setting that up as a
goal okay so once you've set up your
event you recorded it in your
spreadsheet it's firing you want to be
able to then go back into Behavior back
into events okay you can go to top
events okay so top events tell you by
category as a default what events are
firing or what category is firing the
most okay so if I choose my date range
here I can just go to here to date so
here I can see my enter donate button
fortunately for me has the most total
events now notice in analytics you also
see unique events and so the difference
between unique events and total events
is that unique events are equivalent to
one per session where total events means
that somebody can come to your website
initiate a session and click on that
button multiple times in the same same
session so if I go to the Yama
Foundation website okay I can click on
that donate Now button three or four or
five different times in the same session
so what analytics is going to do is
actually in that session count it once
but accumulate the number of clicks as a
total event for that session so you're
always going to have more total events
than unique events because in some cases
users May click on the button more than
once in the same session and so here I
can see total events unique events and
if I added a value to that event I
should be able to see it here so if I
added a dollar as an example to this
particular event because it had 164
unique events I should be able to see
164 as my value but since I see Zero
that means that I did not assign value
and so average value basically is just
giving me how much average I have have
per event so it's taking into account
the number of or the value the total
value divided by the total number of
unique page views or sessions and so
because I don't have value I'm not going
to have average value but here you can
see because value is optional here I can
at least see how many events or how many
clicks I receive for a particular button
again it could be a video if I clicked
on this video as an example I can see
how many people actually started it I
could see the unique and the total
events and if I click on label if I have
a label assigned then I'll be able to
see what page triggered that event so if
we go back again to our header donate
button back to category if we click on
label as our primary Dimension here we
can see the home page had the most
unique events been followed by the
children's page the contact form Etc so
what you you can do in analytics you can
also look at the pages that have driven
events so here I could see the home page
has accumulated the most total events
followed by the contact us so that's how
you would look at the data in Google
analytics under Behavior under events
and then under top events or overview is
where you can start analyzing your event
tracking so first you need to do
identify it assign a category action
enter label set up that tag and Trigger
once you do that once you test that it's
working this is where you're gonna go to
analyze the data let's start out with
why GTM so let's just say your Sam and
you have your own e-commerce website you
want to understand how people are
interacting with your website well Sam
today's world of websites contain a lot
of interactivity everything from videos
to PDF downloads to commenting to form
submissions uh to all sorts of chat
functionality interactivity going on
throughout the website so there's just a
lot that you need to track outside of
just page views and so really what GTM
does is they help you track all these
things I just mentioned everything from
somebody clicking on the play button of
a PDF to somebody clicking on the submit
button of a form to somebody entering in
something on a chat function so that's
what GTM is so why GTM because it helps
us track all that interactivity so all
GTM is is really allows you to really
place a piece of java code which is just
script and the script that's added to a
web page to collect information so
that's really what a tag is it's just
some script that gets put on a web page
in order for you to collect information
like page views clicks Etc and they they
send it to third-party tools okay so
that's what GTM does it basically allows
you to take all these tags that collect
information and you can use them in GTM
so if you want to for example collect
how many people you know enter a chat
functionality and start chatting well
you're going to take that script and
you're going to put it in GTM and GTM
will then allow you to start tracking
that information so that's really what
GTM is it just allows you to put tags
into a container or think of it as a toy
box you have all these toys and you want
to track well you can put all those
those toys or tags in a toy box or
container and we're going to talk a
little bit more about that but before we
get into GTM let's just say you know
you're communicating with your developer
and there's a new user request on your
web page and you want to update the tag
well your developer are considering it's
probably a small update your website is
probably gonna not
um hesitate and is going to go ahead and
turn around and do it normally and so
normally what happens is the developer
is going to go to the website and update
the tag well what if you have a few
things that you want to track all those
things I mentioned before from downloads
to clicks to you know somebody checking
out to watching a video well your Web
Master your web developer is going to go
well hold on a second now all these
requests are going to take time I need
to put them into the work queue so to
speak well what happens is when they go
into work queue usually it's going to
take some time and in some cases you as
a marketer need to launch a campaign and
you want to get that tracking uh added
to the website in time for the campaign
launch so you want to go ahead and
quickly turn around the tracking for
that particular campaign let's just say
you're launching a campaign and you're
sending people to a landing page that
has a form submission and you want to be
able to track how many people click on
the submit button of their form
submission well if you need to turn that
around your developer's like well I need
to put that in a work queue the timing
isn't going to always work out between
you and your developer is my point and
so that's where GTM comes in because
there is a solution to update your tags
faster and that's Google tag manager so
when we say GTM that's what GTM stands
for Google tag manager it's a place for
you to add tags quickly and easily so
tags remember are just Snippets of code
that allow you to track things on your
website interactively interactive
actively and basically when you have GTM
you can bypass the webmaster and do it
quickly and easily so that's what GTM is
all about so why GTM because we just
identified two benefits one you could
track all the interactivity on your
website and two you can bypass your web
web developer or webmaster and so that's
the benefit of GTM so the benefit you
get those tags updated very quickly via
Google tag manager okay so that's what
tag manager is so what we're going to
talk about today is specifically what
tag manager is and what it does we're
going to list some of the benefits of
tag manager we're going to show you how
it works and then we're going to show
you how to get started with tag manager
tag manager if you're not familiar with
working with webmasters and dealing with
JavaScript and tags and all this jargon
is just new to you today okay well don't
fret sit back we're gonna take it slow
this is an introduction into Google tag
manager again let's start out with what
is tag manager so we've already
introduced it to some degree because we
already introduced it as a tool where
you can put all your tags into a toolbox
toy box or container so to speak right
and we already already mentioned that
hey you can bypass your webmaster so
you're probably thinking well if I'm if
you're not familiar with tag manager how
can I bypass my webmaster well first of
all it's a free tool and it's a Google
tool hence the name Google tag manager
and it helps you really that's the main
point it's deploy and track tags on your
website bypassing your webmaster so
that's tag manager and so examples of
tags that can be deployed vehicle the
tag manager are numerous these are just
some examples like Google analytics
Facebook's pixel tracking or Google ads
There's No Limit into the number of
texts you can track and tag manager
there is no limit you can add any number
of tracking tags and tag manager okay so
some of the benefits well again I we
just listed two you can put any tag into
tag manager and track that onto your
website and we know you can bypass your
web developer or webmaster and what it
also does is it also allows you to test
test and deploy your JavaScript codes
quicker so remember these JavaScript
codes or Snippets of codes are just
there to track certain things on your
website whether that be a page view or
somebody clicking on a play button or
tracking somebody who converts or even
just goes to your website so the biggest
benefit is you can take that snippet of
code let's just say Facebook let's just
say you're growing Facebook marketing
and you want to put that Facebook pixel
on your website so that you could track
people who come from Facebook and
convert well you don't need to put that
Facebook pixel on your website you can
go right to tag manager and you can put
that snippet of code right in tag
manager really quickly and the other
benefit here is all tags are managed in
one place and that's that to me is
really a good benefit because when you
start adding tags on your website and
you have some tags and tag manager it
just gets very confusing so ideally all
the tracking codes you have on your web
website needs to be in tag manager think
about that all the tracking so if you're
doing Bing or you're doing Facebook or
you're doing Twitter or you're doing
LinkedIn and you're doing Google you're
doing all this type of marketing on all
these different platforms you're gonna
have tracking code for all these
different platforms and instead of
putting all that code on your website
return gonna slow down the slow time of
your web page and website you want to
put them all in tag manager so they can
be organized and you know exactly what
you're trying to track and the other
great benefit of tag manager is there's
a versioning control so let's just say
you have added tags to your website via
GTM for the last six months well and
let's just say you add another tag
yesterday if you added that tag
yesterday and something doesn't work
well you can just roll back to a
previous version It's that simple so you
have versioning and that's that's a good
thing when you have versioning you can
control what gets published and if
something doesn't work after it gets
published then you can roll back to a
previous version so it it's a a peace of
mind so to speak just because you've had
code to your site there's no guarantee
it's going to work and so you can always
control what version you're dealing with
in tag manager and we'll talk a little
bit more about that so the biggest
benefit here to me with tag manager is
you have event tracking and so we talked
about some of the things you could track
on your website from videos from play
buttons to somebody clicking on the stop
on the video or pausing it all the way
to somebody again chatting or let's just
say somebody clicking on that purchase
button on your website okay and you want
to track all these different things
these different interactivities and
buttons well event tracking is what
you're going to use to track all those
buttons and to me this is the biggest
benefit of tag manager and I'll show you
some examples as we go along and if we
didn't mention it already I'll mention
it again it is free tag managers free
there's no limit so once you have tag
manager going you can add as many
tracking codes as you want there's no
limit on the number of tracking codes
you can add to tag manager okay so it's
free and you can use it to its fullest
Advantage okay so it's also high
security meaning that it has different
levels of permissions okay so you can
have uh somebody just go in and look at
the different tags and tracking codes
you have in GTM or you can ask somebody
who is very familiar with tag manager it
can go in and add the tracking code to
tag manager and then publish that
tracking code when it gets added so
those are all the benefits let's talk
about how it works now specifically how
does tag Manager work because you're
like Rob okay again a lot of jargon you
know you you got tags and JavaScript and
and versioning and Publishing and all
this other stuff well I know I'm
throwing a lot at you at once but just
bear with me here okay so let's start
talking about how it actually works so
you have a website okay whatever that
domain is you have a website and there's
chances are on your website you have
some form of interactivity whether that
be a video whether that be a Blog
whether it be a form submission you have
a website with some interactivity and
let's just say you're even thinking
about getting ready to launch some type
of campaign on maybe Google or Facebook
and you want to drive traffic to your
website fair enough you're joining the
millions of other websites that are out
there that have interactivity that also
Drive traffic to the website so incomes
Google tag manager and so tag manager is
important because again we know we want
to track people coming from that
Facebook campaign or that Google
campaign and interacting with our site
so if you are running Facebook and you
are running Google analytics well guess
what you want to put that tracking code
in tag manager so Google analytics being
a Google product works very nicely with
tag manager Facebook has its own
tracking code and but you still want to
be able to track people who come from
the Facebook campaign into your website
so you're going to get that tracking
code from Facebook and put it in tag
manager that's generally how it works so
here information from your website is
shared with another data source through
tag manager so think about that if I add
Facebook tracking code to tag manager or
let's just say I Google analytics
tracking code to tag manager tag manager
is the one that's pushing out and doing
all the heavy lifting they're the ones
that are controlling what code gets
fired and what code doesn't so if you're
putting the code in tag manager tag
managers controlling the code think
about it that way and let's show you an
example of what that looks like so here
I am I'm in tag manager I just went to
tag
manager.google.com and here I could see
a list of tags so in our conversation
we're talking about tracking Facebook
and we're talking about tracking Google
analytics well Google analytics is easy
because it's a Google product so here if
I look at all the different tracking
code I have on my website through root
tag manager let's just take a look at
Google analytics so if you're going to
use Tag manager you might as well put
the Google analytics code in here so
here I can see I have Google analytics
as a tag in tag manager now for Facebook
if I'm running a Facebook campaign well
I can take that pixel tracking and put
it in GTM as well and here I could see
Facebook pixel that is that code is
added to GTM I just basically took what
Facebook gave me and put it in the
Google tag manager so you can see I can
add Facebook and Google analytics and
again I can't stress it enough any
tracking code from any platform I can
add to Google tag manager in order to
track the behavior from those sources so
let's take a little bit deeper dive into
how tag manager works so I just showed
you an example of how you could take
Facebook and Google analytics code and
put it in the tag manager but if you're
not familiar with tag manager then how
do I do that well let's talk about the
structure and how tag manager works so
when you have a tag manager account you
have a container remember I mentioned
Toy Box earlier you have a bunch of toys
if they're they're code and you're
tracking different bits of code from
different platforms like Facebook think
of those as toys and you have a toy box
okay well that's what this code is and
that's what a container is the code is
the code and that's going to go into the
toy box or container and so the way tag
manager works is you have tags triggers
and variables so if I take my Facebook
tracking code and put it into a
container I need to set up a tag and a
trigger okay so let's take a look at
what that is so first if I go back to
tag manager I'm going to have an account
and if I have an account I'm going to
have a container so here I'm just going
to click on an account with a container
and a container is nothing more than
what website you're adding the tracking
code code two okay that's all the
container is we're just letting tag
manager know this is the website we're
adding all this code to so you have tags
triggers and variables that's the
structure of tag manager so tags are
just what it says tags what are we
trying to quote unquote tag well if it's
Google analytics that's easy here I
could see I have Google analytics added
so if I click on Google analytics here's
my tag and if I take a little bit of a
deeper dive there since Google analytics
is a Google product it integrates
already with tag managers it's pretty
easy I can just choose Google analytics
then I'm going to check page view and
that's my tag now every tag needs a
trigger okay so I need to tell tag
manager how or when to fire the Google
analytics tracking code so in this case
I'm going to tell tag manager to fire on
all pages so if I get somebody a visitor
to my website analytics is firing on all
pages so whatever page that visitor
lands on Google analytics is gonna fire
so that's really what it comes down to
is I have a tag and I need to tell tag
manager when to trigger that tag that's
really what the structure of tag manager
is it's tags triggers and variables and
variables we're going to talk about here
in a couple minutes but you have a piece
of code you're going to go ahead and put
that into tag manager you're going to
tag it and then you're going to fire
that trigger so let's take a look at
another example here if I go back here
you can see Facebook well here's my
Facebook pixel okay that's my tag so
when is it gonna fire well it's gonna
fire on a specific domain or subdomain
that's basically what we're doing we're
trying to tell GTM when to fire that
particular tag so those are the three
main component it's a tag okay which is
going to contain the JavaScript code
that you get from say Facebook the
trigger so you're going to go into tag
manager and tell tag manager when to
fire that code that's the trigger and
then you have variables and so variables
are basically just additional
information that tag manager may need
for your tag and Trigger to work so
that's what a variable is it's there to
get the tag and Trigger to fire so
variables are divided into built-in and
user-defined variables so common used
variables include say page path or page
URL or hostname or click class again
they're there and these examples I just
gave you are there to get your tag and
Trigger to work think about it that way
they're just that's a component and if I
go into tag manager here and here on the
left side I can see variables so
remember I have built-in and user
defined so a built-in means that tag
manager already built these for me so in
case I need to get my trigger to work
with my tag I can use a variable so
those are built in and then I have user
defined so these are what I Define these
are what I created and again the
variables are there to get the tag and
Trigger to work okay so that's the job
of the variable the job of the tag is to
host that JavaScript code okay in the
case of Facebook or analytics that's
where we're putting our code so here if
I click on AdWords remarketing again
it's a Google product so I don't really
need to even deal with code I'm just
going to select Google AdWords for
marketing okay so you can see GTM
integrates nicely with some of the other
Google products but let's just say you
have a Facebook pixel tracking code
you're going to choose custom and you're
going to put the code here so that's
part of the tag and then the trigger
again is there to get the tag to fire so
you're telling GTM when to fire the tag
and the variable is there to help you
make sure that that trigger and that tag
work together so that's how all three
kind of work together you need the tag
to put the code you need the trigger to
tell GTM when to fire the tag and code
and the variables there to help you
define when that tag and Trigger should
work or how it should work so again
review tags are they're just small codes
of JavaScript are tracking pixels on
your website and so tags are allowed to
manage events like scroll track and
remarketing clicks downloads files play
buttons you name it even clicks on
external links for example let's just
say you have a click uh or a Facebook uh
icon on your site and when somebody
clicks on it they go to Facebook you
want to maybe track that you're going to
create a tag okay the trigger is there
because you need to tell GTM when to
fire that tag so it's a certain
condition whether it's you know fire the
tag if the URL equals facebook.com or
some other condition so the tag cannot
be created until the creation of the
corresponding trigger so tags and
triggers go together you can't just
create a tag and not have a trigger
otherwise your tag will never fire and
then the variable is there again it
stores the information when defining a
trigger or transferring data to tag so a
variable has a variety of data okay so
you pick and choose the variable you
want to use with that trigger okay so
you're making sure that by defining a
variable you're making sure that you're
telling GTM how that trigger should be
fired so let's take a look at another
example here of how all three play
together if I'm in this account I'm in
this container if I look down here I can
see Google optimize that's another
Google product so what I'm doing here is
I just chose Google optimize as my tag
it's already integrated so what does
that mean I don't even need to deal with
any code I'm just going to select
optimize well we have the tag Google
optimize but we need to tell GTM how to
fire that and so here we're going to
tell GTM to fire it on all pages so
that's basically a very simple example
because we're firing it on all pages so
if I want to look at something specific
again Facebook here's my tag here's my
code what's my trigger well my trigger
is it's going to fire on specific Pages
how do I know that well if I look at the
trigger here I could see the trigger is
a page view but I'm telling it to fire
on this particular hostname so the tag
and Trigger go hand in hand
[Music]
so how to get started with tag manager
so first things first you have to create
that account so you're going to go to
tagmanager.google.com or you can do a
search for Google tag manager and you're
going to create your account and then
when you create your account what's
going to happen is you're going to set
up a container and when you set up a
container you have choices so you could
set it up for your website for an app on
iOS or maybe Android or you can even set
it up for amp Etc an accelerated mobile
page so most people by default are
probably going to set up tag manager for
their website and so when you do that
when you actually select website what's
gonna happen is you're going to get some
Google tag manager code in return and so
the whole idea here is you're going to
do a swap what you're doing is basically
you're saying Okay Google I'm going to
take this Google tag manager code and
I'm going to put it on my website I'm
going to put it on every page in my
website so notice tag manager has two
scripts one goes in the head as high as
possible the other goes into the body
tag as high as possible and so what
you're doing is you're making a deal
you're putting this tag manager code on
your website and in return every code
you deal with whether that be Facebook
or analytics or optimize or remarketing
or whatever it is is gonna go in GTM
okay it's going to go into the Container
you created so you need the tag manager
code on your website in order for tag
manager to work okay so when you add
this code to your website then you're
free to start adding all sorts of tags
to your container but if you don't have
this tracking code on your website then
none of the tags you add to your
container are gonna work so that's the
idea behind the container and then one
thing I wanted to mention on the account
is it's a Google account so when you
create your account then make sure it's
the same account you use with say Google
analytics or some other Google product
that's a good best practice is always
use the same email address when you set
up your account so that it integrates
nicely across all the different
platforms meaning you can go from say
Google analytics right to Google tag
manager in one browser without having to
log out or log in okay so when you
create the account you're going to
create your container if you choose web
then you're going to be asked to place
code on your website and when you place
that code on your website then you are
free to start using tag manager and that
means you're free to start adding tags
so if you want to know more information
about installing Google tag manager then
what I would recommend is visit the
quick start guide website of GTM so
again if you're curious as to where that
code is located in Google tag manager
well when you create an account account
and you create a container that
container is going to have a specific ID
so if I click on that specific ID here's
where I can get my code okay so again
when I'm logged in to tag manager I'm
going to click on workspace but in the
top navigation I'm going to see my
unique GTM ID if I click on that that's
where my code is going to be located and
so again your code needs to go in the
header and there's another script that
needs to go in the body and if you're
not sure how to add the code to your
website well you can always click on the
quick start guide here okay and that'll
take you to a quick start guide page a
reference page related to Google tag
manager so let's talk about creating a
tag so once you get tag manager
installed I'm sure you're excited to get
going and create that first tag so let's
talk about how to create a tag in tag
manager so when you're in tag manager
all you need to do is basically you're
looking at all your tags if you click on
tag in the left side navigation you'll
see all your tags and there's a new
button there so you just click new and
so basically what you're going to do is
you're going to create your first tag
and so what I would recommend once you
get tag manager installed on your
website I would recommend setting the
first tag up as Google analytics so that
will get you going with tracking page
views on your website when some when
somebody visits your website okay so
ideally that's what you want to do you
want to get Google analytics as your
first tag and tag manager so what I'm
going to do is because analytics is a
Google product it's already integrated
nicely with tag manager so I'm just
going to click on Google analytics it's
going to be a page view that's what I'm
tracking and now I have to set up a
variable and so what it's going to do
it's going to ask me to set up a select
active variable and so what you're going
to do is you're going to select new
variable and what you're going to do is
you're actually going to go and add your
tracking ID here that's going to be your
variable so where do I get my tracking
ID and analytics well if I'm in
analytics I'm going to go to admin and
then under property settings I'm going
to see my tracking ID and all you need
to do then is go to tag manager and
paste copy first you get a copy over
that tracking ID then you're going to
get a tag manager I'm going to paste it
and then that's going to create a
variable for you and then when you
create that variable you're going to see
it in the drop down here so I've already
created it and basically that's your tag
with a variable then what are you going
to do you're going to set up a trigger
so see I have some triggers already set
up you're going to see a default trigger
already set up for you and that's going
to be all pages so ideally what you want
to do is you want to select all pages in
order for analytics to fire on all pages
so that's what we're doing we're setting
up a trigger we're basically telling tag
manager hey if I get a visitor to any
page on my website then I want you to
fire Google analytics so that's
basically in summary how to set up your
first tag and my recommendation is your
first tag should be Google analytics and
when you set up analytics you're going
to have to set up a variable for the
tracking ID and so you get the tracking
ID again from admin property settings
copy and paste that tracking ID over
save it you have your variable that
variable is going to be included in with
the tag and your trigger is going to be
all pages and there you go you have your
first tag you have your first variable
you have your first trigger so that's
basically what you want to do and once
you've added that tag once you've added
that trigger then the only thing you
need to do now is basically publish the
tag and so anytime you save a tag you're
going to go ahead and submit it so that
way it gets published so again what
you're going to do is let's take a step
back here you're going to choose new tag
you're going to choose analytics from
the drop down menu you're going to
choose page view then basically you're
going to add your tracking ID so you can
set up the variable and then basically
that's what you need to do okay you're
going to add that tracking ID and then
voila that's your tag with a variable
and then once you've done that then
you're going to click submit so when you
click submit you're basically saying Hey
I want this tag to go live now this tag
and Trigger and once you've done that
then analytics is ready to go and
anytime somebody goes to your website on
any page tag manager is going to fire
Google analytics so the great thing here
is you have something called Google tag
assistant and that's an extension that
works with chrome and so when you've
actually add a tag manager to your site
or are you have analytics running in tag
manager you can confirm if those tags
are firing properly so let's take a look
at how Google tag assistant works okay
so if you just do a search for Google
tag assistant you're going to see here
that it's basically just an extension
that works in Chrome and unfortunately
it only works in Chrome browser it
doesn't work in any other browser so go
ahead and install that extension into
Chrome and when you do that you're going
to see this nice icon here in your
browser and now if you go to any website
and I click on Google tag assistant and
I click on enable Okay so basically I'm
loading Google tag assistant and now
once I refresh the page I can see that
this particular site has Google tag
manager installed and not only does it
have tag manager installed I can see
that it's also has Google analytics
running I have also Google optimized
running and I have Google ads remark tag
running and tag manager so that's what
tag assistant does it allows you to see
if one tag manager is on the site and if
it is great what other tags are firing
on this particular site so tag
assistance telling me I have these
particular tags firing on that site and
they're firing within tag manager so tag
assistant is a great way to confirm if
one tag manager is on the site and two
what other tags are firing on the site
now another way you could confirm if tag
manager is firing on the site is you can
go into preview mode so even before you
submit and publish your tag and Trigger
you can click on the preview mode so if
I click preview in tag manager so
basically that's going to put me in
preview mode and so what does that mean
well that means that now I'm free to go
to my website and see if those tags are
firing and so let's take take a look at
what that looks like so if I go to the
website and just click refresh then
what's going to happen is tag manager is
going to load in preview mode just as
you see here okay so that's going to
take a second couple seconds to load up
and now what can I see in preview mode I
could see that I have GTM firing but I
also have some other text fine on this
page remarketing I have Google analytics
I have Google optimize I have some other
tags firing as well and so the preview
mode shows me what tags are firing on
any given page and I can also see what
tags did not fire okay so here I have a
number of tags already in GTM but they
didn't fire on this particular page so
let's just say I clicked on the Donate
Now button I'm still in preview mode so
I'm gonna be able to see what tags fired
now I could see I have a couple of tags
that have fired on this particular page
and then I can see what tags did not
fire on this page image okay so that's
the preview mode you can use the preview
mode before you even submit a tag and
Trigger to see if it fires and that's
the great benefit of tag manager so if
you're not sure if something's going to
fire or not then you can always go into
preview mode
um and if you are sure it's gonna fire
then you can go ahead and submit it so
you can leave preview mode and just go
ahead and submit that particular tag and
Trigger so here I'm going to leave
preview mode and now once I'm done and
I'm sure the tag is going to fire and go
ahead and submit all my changes that
I've worked on in terms of setting up
tags and triggers so that's really GTM
in a nutshell so I have my tags okay my
tags are just Snippets of code that I'm
going to put in whether that be Facebook
or vet tracking or any other Google
product like optimize or page view then
I have my triggers my triggers are there
to tell GTM when to fire that tag and
the variables are there to help those
tags and triggers work together so
remember that particular variable we set
up for Google analytics okay so here it
is right here because we want to tell
GTM what property to specifically fire
in Google analytics so that's why we set
up that variable but there are all sorts
of variables Google tag manager has
built in or variables already created
for you or you can specifically Define a
variable so variables are there to help
the tags and triggers work together so
when you set up a tag you set up a
trigger you use a variable you can
always go into preview mode preview it
by going to the website seeing if it
fires if it fires then voila you can go
ahead and click submit and that will
publish the tag and Trigger and you're
good to go that's pretty much how tag
manager works and again I can't stress
that there is an unlimited number of
tags you can add to tag manager there's
no limit so you got everything from
anything from Google to non-google to
event tracking okay to Facebook to
anything that you want to track you want
to be able to put into tag manager and
again there's versioning that's one of
the great benefits of tag manager so if
I want to go back to an older version I
can simply do that so here you can see
I'm on version 32. that's how tag
manager works and I can't stress that
you know tag manager is there to help
you track interactivity on the site
because if you have a site that's
interactive that has a video that has a
download button let's just say you know
you have all sorts of newsletter
sign-ons Facebook YouTube buttons on
your website just like this website does
and you won't be able to track how many
people click on that particular button
well you're gonna need tag manager and
when you have tag manager you're going
to be a able to track all of these
button clicks and interactivity on your
website but that tag manager it's going
to be hard to do that so that's an
introduction to tag manager so if you're
looking to become a digital marketing
specialist then look no further than
simply learn postgraduate program in
digital marketing with this you gain all
the necessity skills in digital
marketing like website creation
behavioral marketing keyword research
search engine optimization search engine
marketing campaign management social
media marketing and more with knowledge
of tools like SC ranking hoot suit chat
GPT Google ads Google Keyword Planner
Google Trends and there's much more on
the list don't miss out on this
incredible opportunity take action today
and enroll in a course to unlock the
digital marketing success accelerator
career and gain the skills you need to
thrive in the industry ready to get
started then click on the link mentioned
in the description box and embark on
your journey to professional growth and
achievement in the age of digital
marketing it is very easy to get lost in
the sea of information if you are a
beginner you will probably spend a lot
of time reading and researching even if
you are an expert you will still need to
keep up to date and know what's going on
in the marketing world but how do you
find the time to do that how do you find
the time to stay on top of Trends and
Innovations we have compiled a list of
20 plus digital marketing tools to help
you make your life easier
some of these tools might sound familiar
to you and some might sound new and
interesting we believe all of them have
some value in your life and can assist
you in staying on top of trends hey
everyone I am tusha badiwal welcome to
Simply learns YouTube channel in this
video we will understand 20 plus digital
marketing tools to grow your business in
2022 but before we begin if you enjoy
watching Tech related content consider
subscribing to our YouTube channel and
hitting that Bell icon to stay tuned
so without any further delay let's get
started with the plan for today's
session first we will look at the
research part next we will explore tools
to build or host the website content is
king So next we will have a look at some
of the best content creation tools to
grow your business
moving forward we will discuss designing
and Graphics tools once designing is
done it's time to promote and hence we
will look at the best promotional tools
after that we will discuss some great
email marketing tools user behavior and
competitor analysis tools and finally we
will end the session by understanding
the communication tools that will help
your business operate smoothly
research research is one of the most
essential parts of getting your business
to the next level it's what turns an
idea into a real business however it is
hard to do research without the right
tools luckily there are many tools out
there that do the job perfectly here are
just few that you need to know about
Uber suggest Uber suggest is a free tool
that produces fresh keyword ideas it is
among the best free tools available on
the market however it has a Premium plan
for advanced features but it is best if
you are starting out and it has some
good features like you will get the
search volume for free keyword ideas and
content ideas
Keyword Planner it is one of the best
free tools and the best part is that
it's a Google product so that the data
can be trusted you can use Google
Keyword Planner to do keyword research
Google Keyword Planner will show you the
monthly search volume of keywords and
phrases the average cost per click in
your selected country and how difficult
it is to rank for the keywords some of
the best features are you will get the
custom time based keyword data and get
to know the competition on that keyword
hrefs hrefs is one of the most advanced
tool available for keyword research it
is also used for competitor analysis
rank tracking and site auditing href's
main features are geared towards
marketer but you can also use it to find
keywords for Google YouTube and Amazon
the tool is paid but suitable for
businesses looking for in-depth
information it has some features like
rank tracker that will help you know
your existing website ranking and the
second one is alert you will get
important information or stats by mail
after doing the research part you need a
website for your business let's have a
look at how to do that the first step in
creating a website is to find a place to
host it there are many options out there
and depending on what your site will be
used for you may need different tools
web hosting tools have evolved to meet
the online communities need better it
can be challenging to select the right
one through many options here are the
few of the best tools available on the
market
WordPress it will help you create your
website by just drag and dropping no
coding is required also it has a lot of
plugins that can be used according to
your website needs blogger you can
create a beautiful blog using blogger
for free and it is also has free themes
which you can use
still it is always recommended that you
use tools like WordPress to build your
website because businesses need a
website with lot of functionalities and
WordPress makes this process easier
the website requires hosting as the next
tool we have is hostinger you need to
purchase a domain and hosting to host a
website there are other companies also
available that you can use to host your
site such as GoDaddy HostGator Etc
hosting job provides automatic backups
that will ensure that your website data
is secured it allows you to create
unlimited subdomain which is also
necessary for a business website
for free hosting and free domains you
can use Infinity free but for a business
website it is always recommended to go
with the paid hosting because this will
give your customer a good experience
when they visit your website but for
beginner just wanting to learn how
website hosting works you can use
Infinity free
every Business website and its social
media platform need content and content
is the oxygen of the internet there is
no surviving without it but meeting the
demand of a Content hungry World often
means that you are forced to pull your
hair out only to throw more into the
fire
from research to Creation to
distribution content is now 24x7 job
requiring many internal resources or
costly outsourced help
if you are looking to cut down the cost
and streamline your efforts here are
some content creation tools to take your
business to the next level
headline it is an AI tool that will
create a landing page automatically no
writing designing and coding is required
you need to give information about the
product and it is also has built-in
templates to use it became famous
because of this feature but now it is
upgraded and you will see a lot of other
features that will help you create
excellent content it is a paid tool but
you can try its free version
pepper type it is a One-Stop AI solution
tool for all content needs and the best
part is you will get 10 000 word limit
to try out this fantastic tool the
specialty of this tool is that it allows
you to create content for specific
social media platforms and long form
content
grammarly grammarly is a free online
tool that find mistakes in your writing
and suggest improvements as you write
grammarly will underline any mistakes
you have made and offer suggestions on
how to fix them
additionally it has a plagiarism Checker
and a punctuation checker
however for additional features you need
to go with grammarly premium
the best way to create excellent content
is to have good visuals this is why we
have listed the best designing tools
that you can use to get stock images and
videos canva you can design your website
using canva for free it is the best tool
to make your website content more
engaging
it is a simple drag and drop tool that
allows you to create beautiful Graphics
Flyers infographics social media post
and more you can also use it to create
more engaging images for your post
furthermore it gives you free templates
and allows you to collaborate with your
business team using team functionality
pixabay pixabay is a free website or a
creative community that shares copyright
free photos illustrations music and
videos
all pixabay content are licensed under
the pixaby license you can use them
without asking for permission or
crediting the artist even for commercial
purposes
you can download these stock images
videos musics and illustration without
signing up
Shutterstock although it also comes with
the same feature the key difference is
that it is paid you might wonder why to
use this shutter stock since we already
have a free tool like pixabay well it
depends on your business needs there are
some images and stock footage that you
will only find on certain stock in
addition such a stock has powerful
editing tools and custom size options
that attract people
now we have a better understanding of
the content part in order to attract
more visitors the content needs to be
promoted the following tools will help
you promote your business Drive traffic
to your website convert visitors into
leads build brand awareness Etc
Google ads Google ads are a powerful
tool that can help you reach your target
audience it is small but significant
step towards online Success Through many
people believe that Google ads are not
as effective as they used to be there
are still more benefits than drawbacks
the only thing you need to know how to
use it your website can be advertised
via Google ads and your product and
services can be promoted on YouTube it
has an excellent feature lead form
extension that allow user to provide
their contact details directly through
the ad without visiting your landing
page additionally Live Events targeting
for example graduating from a college is
also a great feature since it helps you
reach the correct type of audience
Facebook ads manager it allows you to
run Facebook and Instagram ads and it's
an excellent way to promote your
business a feature like Facebook
analytics will give you a good grasp of
data feature like audience Insight will
better understand who is interested in
your product and services
Google ads and Facebook ads require you
to spend money on ads by setting up a
daily or a custom budget
is a Content marketing tool to help you
find the best ways of engaging creating
and spreading content across social and
search channels two of the best feature
is finding an influencer that will help
you to find the right influencer and a
Content Discovery feature which will
help you to discover new content ideas
email marketing tools are the most
effective means to stay in touch with
your customers you can nurture leads
rearrange with your audience and build a
subscriber base through email businesses
today recognize the importance of email
and marketers are investing heavily in
email marketing tools however in the
overwhelming sea of email marketing
tools finding the right fit can be
tricky we have selected some of the best
email marketing tools to help your
business get started and grow through
MailChimp MailChimp is a comprehensive
marketing platform that lets you keep
track of and communicate with your
clients customers and other interested
parties but it is popular because of its
email Services there is a free plan of
MailChimp the free plan is often more
than enough for small businesses up to
2000 subscribers can be added and 12 000
emails can be sent a month it supports
multiple integration to integrate other
third-party softwares and MailChimp also
allows you to update or remove the
subscriber profiles which is also one of
the best feature of MailChimp send in
blue it is very similar to MailChimp
both have excellent and similar features
when it comes to email Services one
unique feature of sending blue is that
it has the option of a drag and drop
Builder that is accessible by mobile
analysis and optimization businesses
need to analyze and optimize their
processes to grow furthermore you should
analyze the data to develop a solution
to the problems in your industry several
tools can be beneficial here let's
discuss that
Google search console this tool will
help you understand how your website
performs on Google searches by ranking
on top you will have higher chances of
attracting more visitors the index
coverage report will help you understand
which web page have problems moreover it
has a very useful URL inspection tool
which gives information about Google's
indexed page version
vid IQ many YouTubers majorly use it to
analyze their performance on YouTube and
optimize their Channel if you are
looking to rank your video on YouTube
you need to optimize the title
description and tags this tool helps you
to do that
the tool includes a thumbnail generator
that lets you create customized
thumbnails that generate good views and
it has Trend alerts which will notify
you by email of popular content
Google analytics using Google analytics
you can track the traffic on your
website and find out where your visitors
are coming from it also allows you to
track your sales performance and traffic
sources
Google analytics is a tool that will let
you know if your website is performing
well and also if you need to make some
changes to improve its performance
it has outstanding features like funnel
analysis and smart goals a funnel is a
method for determining which steps are
necessary to achieve the desired
outcomes and with smart goals you can
identify and count the most engaged
users on your website user Behavior user
Behavior tools help you understand user
behavior on the website user Behavior
tools are very effective tools used in
digital marketing to track the behavior
of visitors and make the business more
effective
below are the sum of the user Behavior
tools used in digital marketing
hot job hotja is an inside tool that
lets you analyze your customer behavior
and get feedback to understand them
better and come up with new business
strategies to grow your business
this tool gives you visual feedback
which you won't find in other tools and
it also offers surveys which is also a
unique feature of Orchard smart look it
is mostly similar to hot jar but it has
some additional features like
customizable dashboard and conversion
funnel which means the visualization of
how people follow the path
competitor analysis many businesses
start their competitive study when
planning their digital marketing
strategy and then abandon it
it is essential to make adjustments
after competitor analysis and use great
tools here are some of the best
the tool is completely paid you can use
this tool to improve your PPC campaign
as it gives you insight into what your
competitors are doing keywords can also
be imported as well as downloaded social
blade it is used for social media
monitoring and influencer tracking for
example you can get lot of information
about the performance of other
competitors and how they are doing on
YouTube and other social media channels
the best part is that many features are
available in the free plan
similar web it is also an excellent tool
to analyze competitors website traffic
and you can also get the Google Play and
Apple App Store data
href we already covered this in the
research category but we wanted to
mention it here because href will also
be viewed as one of the best tools for
analyzing competitors
communication
starting and building a successful
business require better communication
within your team we must ensure that our
task has been clearly communicated to
the team so that we will be able to
perform the work as we intended thus one
needs a tool to accomplish that so now
let's check out some of the best tools
for communication
slack the app is a chat room that brings
together all of your team's
Communication in one place meaning there
is a no longer a need to use email Skype
or multi-chatroom apps slack can be used
with both work and personal accounts and
it can benefit businesses in several
different ways
Microsoft teams it is also similar to
slack but it offers unlimited app
integration and unlimited chat messages
there are free plans for both but you
can upgrade if your business need aren't
met
here what you have learned so far
initially we discussed research then
tools to build and host the website next
we discussed content creation and
graphic designing tools after that we
discuss tools that will help in the
promotion and then the email marketing
tools after that we discussed analysis
and optimization tools
next we discussed user behavior and
competitor analysis tools and finally we
discuss the communication tools
greetings everyone this is Rob Sanders
with simply learn thank you for joining
and today we're going to cover digital
marketing interview questions and
answers so thanks for joining again and
here's how it's going to work so we
broke out a few questions and answers uh
in different categories a lot of you are
going to be interviewing for some jobs
out there and some of the jobs maybe an
SEO manager or or search engine
marketing manager or email marketing
manager or content marketing manager or
social media manager so we broke up
those questions into those areas and so
that's what we're going to do we're
going to start with SEO we're going to
go through some questions and I'm going
to explain the answers to those
questions so if you have any questions
to these questions or answers feel free
to just comment right below this video
and we'll get back to as soon as
possible so let's get started we're
going to start with SEO search engine
optimization we're going to go through a
series of questions and I'm going to
answer those questions for you okay so
the first question that you might be
asking interview is differentiate
between do follows and no follows okay
so if you take in or listen to my SEO
courses on YouTube for SEO we we talked
a lot about do follows and no follows
and and simply put I mean do follows are
just signals to the search engines to
follow the link so there's a link on
site a pointing to site B we're going to
basically tell Google Bing and some of
these other search engines hey go ahead
and follow that link now I know file is
just the opposite so no follow link
doesn't allow the search engine crawlers
to follow it so if we have a link on our
site site a pointing to site B we could
put up follow tag in there and what
that's going to do it's going to signal
to the Crawlers hey don't follow this
link so in the end if the Crawlers don't
follow the link then there's not going
to be any link juice passed and so
Google is not going to give you credit
or give that site credit for having a
link pointing to it or pointing to
another site or from another site and so
it's all about linking so we can control
if there's links on our site whether we
want the Crawlers to recognize those or
not simply with no follow tags so just a
reminder link juice is the reputation or
Equity pass from one website to another
so if you have a link on another website
and that website is of high quality
meaning their page Authority their
domain Authority is high they have a lot
of content you know they're not spammy
they're really rich and they're relevant
then you may want to make sure that the
link pointing from that site to your
site isn't a follow so that way that
Google can recognize the link from that
site to your site and basically that
reputation is going to be passed on to
you okay so that's a do follow versus a
no follow and why would we do a no
follow well it just pens it really
depends a lot of social media platforms
like Facebook have no follows if you
have a lot of content you may not want
to be pushing out a lot of do follows it
could actually look bad from an external
linking standpoint and so a lot of sites
are really particular about who they
want to pass link choose onto and give
credit for the link so it's a business
decision at the end of the day there's
really no hard fast rule here except
from an SEO perspective if I have a site
and I have a lot of external links
pointing outward to other sites I'm
going to be particular about who I allow
the search engine to follow and what
links I allow not to follow okay so
here's an example of what they look like
so do follow is simply just the href no
notice the nofollow has the the tag
appended to it the href tag with a
nofollow so if the search engine's
crawling your site and they see that no
file there they're not going to follow
that link and vice versa if there's a
link on another site pointing to yours
and there's a no follow there you're not
going to get credit the search engines
aren't going to pick up that link okay
so question two what is 301 redirect and
how is it different from a 302 redirect
so three one redirects tell users in the
search engine specifically that an
original page has been moved and this is
the keyword here permanently so
permanently moved we're going to explain
that in a minute so it's just moved from
one page to another and so if we don't
have a page anymore we have a new page
let's just say you built a new website
with new URLs you want to make sure the
old page is pointing to the new page
with a 301 redirect so for 301 redirect
is permanent minute than a 302 is
temporary so we want the search engines
to recognize that we have 301 permanent
redirects in place why because if we
have temporary then it might alert
Google to not keep that page in its
search engine rankings because it's
temporary so why would Google want to
keep a temporary page or even a page
that is pointing to another page on a
temporary basis so they may remove both
pages from its index okay but if we have
something permanent in place Google may
say okay this page is permanently
linking to another page or redirecting
to another page therefore it's stable
it's permanent we're going to keep that
new page in the index and eventually
remove the old page so really something
permanent is more stable in the eyes of
the search engine something temporary
may not be as stable in the eyes of say
Google and if they don't see it as
stable then they may remove both pages
from the end X okay so the idea is we
want to be found in Google search index
and we get it sometimes Pages go away
for a variety of reasons and if it does
go away just make sure you have a new
page for it and that new page is a 301
permanent redirect okay so question
three why are backlinks important in SEO
well we kind of hinted on that a bit
with the nofollow because if we have a
link from another website pointing to
ours and that link from that other
website is really relevant and and it
has a high page and domain Authority
then it's going to benefit us and so
backlinks are important because if we
have backlinks from quite quality sites
it's going to improve the credibility of
our site especially if it's a do follow
tag so the search engines are going to
recognize the relationship between the
site that has a link pointing to us okay
so it's just going to build our
credibility it's going to increase
increase our domain Authority and then
the net effect of that that is if we're
credible and we have high domain
Authority then that's going to increase
the rankings of our pages and when the
pages increase in ranking then we're
going to get a more of a Lion's Share of
the traffic for certain keywords that
our pages are found for and if our pages
are found and getting traffic then
because we have increased rankings we're
likely going to have increased traffic
and then it's just a snowball effect so
more traffic leads to more engagement
and conversions so the whole idea for
SEO is remember you have an on-page
strategy and an off-page strategy
building external links is part of an
off-page SEO strategy and we want to
make sure that you know we are relevant
in the form of a link or in the form of
content on other high quality sites
being on a high quality site only
benefits us because again increases or
domain Authority Google sees this is
more relevant therefore pages are going
to benefit by ranking higher and
therefore or when we rank higher we get
more traffic so it's a snowball effect
so having backlinks is important because
it snowballs all the way through to
conversions okay so what are the best
practices to rank your videos on YouTube
this is a great question really great
question given the importance of videos
especially with SEO because videos are
found YouTube in itself is a search
engine so if we have a video how are we
going to get it to rank on YouTube well
first things first you never want to put
a video out there and want it to rank if
it's not engaging or informative so make
sure you go ahead and follow the best
practices of having engaging and
informative content in your video now
once you have that video in place you
want to optimize it and then some of the
key factors for optimizing a video are
you want to choose a title that has high
search volume and low difficulty just as
you would keyword for example for web
page you want to choose is a title with
a keyword in it that has high volume and
low difficulty I.E low competition okay
so you want a nice ratio there and you
know what you want to choose a title
it's going to get people to watch the
video too so it's not all about just
choosing a title just for the sake of
high volume you also have to choose
something that's relevant that's going
to be catchy as well and then with that
title goes the description so you want a
description that's very relevant to your
title okay because most people aren't
going to click on a video just for the
sake of a title they're going to want to
probably get a sneak peek via the
description of what it is so again you
want to optimize that description but
make sure the description is is just as
snazzy as the title okay you also want
to use accurate and relevant video tags
just as you would on Twitter Facebook
tag these videos okay so make sure your
title tag length doesn't exceed 100
characters because it will get chopped
off so again that goes back to just
writing something really sure short and
to the point that's going to grab
somebody's attention Okay you also want
to upload a captivating thumbnail
something that's relevant then that's
going to grab somebody's attention and
then again we set it similar to the
video tags we want to use relevant
hashtags again just as you would with
Twitter and Facebook go ahead and throw
some hashtags in there that people could
see because people search via
hashtagging and then this goes without
saying you did all the work created a
really great video it's engaged and it's
informative you optimized it feel free
to promote your video on other social
media platforms okay don't just stick
with YouTube per se so the benefit here
is if you post it on Facebook or
LinkedIn or whatever platform of your
choice and it gets engagement people
click on the link go to YouTube they're
gonna like it and then other people are
gonna see that engagement they're gonna
see how many people liked it or how many
subscribers you have so promote your
videos to help you with the ranking of
the video on YouTube so that does play
into it so go ahead and promote it so
other people can watch it like it
comment Etc and that's going to engage
other people to want to do the same so
what is mobile first indexing this is a
really important and timely question
mobile first indexing means Google's
just using mobile friendly content for
indexing and ranking websites so in
other words Google for example has two
Bots they have the traditional desktop
bot and they have a smartphone bot and
eventually everybody that has a website
is going to be migrated over to the
smartphone bot and so with that
smartphone bot goes to your website and
starts crawling what do you think
they're looking for their smartphone bot
they're looking for mobile friendly
content if it's not mobile friendly
meaning the page isn't designed for a
smartphone browser or let's just say the
images are way too long large or you
have to expand the text just to read it
you know a lot of these these issues
that somebody would have just simply
trying to read something on a web page
on their mobile device Google's not
going to grab that content so you want
to make sure it's mobile friendly so it
gets indexed and so if your website has
a responsive design Google will rank
your website based on its performance on
mobile devices okay so you want to make
sure that your website is mobile
friendly and if you're in an interview
and somebody asks this question you
could even take it a step further and
say look I'm going to measure how
friendly my wall my website is for
mobile devices and Google search console
because Google search console has a
report that will show you what pages on
your website are not mobile friendly and
it's not a guarantee but I could tell
you if I'm Google and I'm crawling your
site with my smartphone Bob and that
page or one of my pages is not mobile
friendly I'm probably not going to index
it or rank it so you want to leverage
that report in Google search console to
see what pages are mobile friendly so
that's a little bonus for you to really
impress the interviewer who asks you
this question because how are you going
to know if one of your pages is mobile
friendly or not if you don't look at a
report so keep an eye on Google search
consoles mobile usability report okay
number six list down the most important
local SEO ranking factors okay so
organic local ranking is just as
important as anything else in organic
search because if you have a local
business you want to use the likes of
say Google my business to show up when
somebody types in you know looking for a
florist or you're looking for a coffee
shop so what you want to do is you want
to create a web page for every product
and service okay you also want to opt
for your business listings on Google my
business and and there are plenty of
other other local business directories
out there like Yelp for example or Bing
even has one so go ahead and also make
sure you have a business listing as well
but since Google in the United States
has a huge market share you want to
start with Google first you want to
update your nap citations on your
website maintain consistency of your nap
okay so nap is name address phone number
so you want to make sure that that's
current and consistent so if you have a
number on your website make sure it's
the same number on Google my business
okay you can embed a Google map on your
website it could certainly optimize The
Meta tags and content not only on your
web pages but within your Google my
business directory so you can add your
business to other local directories like
I mentioned Yelp and then also just as
important opt for reviews and ratings
okay so the more reviews The Hat you
have the better off you are okay so I
always say this with with local search
three of the main factors in showing up
for local search on say Google is
obviously the keyword the second is the
proximity of where that person is and
then third is the reviews so you can't
really control the proximity but you
can't control the keyword and you can
control the reviews to some degree so
work hard at getting reviews for your
business but at the same time you can
certainly work in some keywords let's
just say for your product and service
pages on your website but also you can
translate that over to Google my
business okay so working in those
keywords making sure your your number
your address your name they're all
consistent and and really just spreading
your the the business out on other
directors that's really all these are
really key factors for local SEO okay so
question number seven how to avoid
duplicate content getting penalized for
do duplicate content so for example if
you have two different versions of a web
page you may result in a duplicate
content issue so it's just SEO 101 you
never want to have two two or more pages
with the same content so what do we do
well we can avoid this in having Google
penalize us by again setting up a 301
redirect remember three or ones are
permanent we can also use what they call
canonical tag and a canonical tag
basically alerts the search engines as
to which page is the original okay so if
we have an original page we want to
point to that page with our canonical
tag and the third option is opt for
preferred domain and Google search
console okay so if you have multiple no
names make sure you set up a primary one
in search console so those are ways to
work around it of this three I would
always go with the canonical tags
because that's just a tag that's going
to sit on the page it's going to alert
Google as to what the original is just
in case they get their hands on the
duplicate so all the pages that have the
same content are going to have the same
canonical tag pointing to one page so
again three ones are permanent you can
simply just redirect one to the other if
you end up having duplication or you
could just tell search engines hey this
is the original page or you can go
through search console okay number eight
what are the tactics to increase a web
page speed okay so what are some of the
tactics well when you build a site
especially for mobile you want to keep
it as simple as possible and what I mean
by simple as possible really I mean hey
use a simple website design don't get
overly creative if you will most
websites all websites have images you're
not going to be able to get around that
but just make sure you optimize your
images made in other words don't have
such a large image size if you don't
need something very large don't have it
okay you want to improve server response
time and what do we mean by that well
your site's sitting on a server
somewhere you can own that server or you
can can be renting it out from say
Amazon web services or let's just say
GoDaddy as your register they also have
web hosting well if you have it on say
GoDaddy server you may be sharing that
server with other businesses and at
certain times of the day other
businesses may get a lot of traffic and
suck up a lot of bandwidth what is that
going to do that's going to reduce the
server response time for your site and
so you want to make sure you have an
idea of you know what server your web
page your website is on and you want to
be able to have some control over that
because if your server response is slow
that's going to slow down everything
else in terms of loading in the browser
and that's not going to be good for SEO
okay optimize your code what do you mean
by optimize minifying when we see
mimifying we mean get rid of some of the
Redundant code if you have CSS you know
get rid of chop some of the get rid of
the JavaScript you're not using so
that's what we mean by optimizing code
release redirects okay ideally you just
want to have one redirect in place you
don't want to create a daisy chain so to
speak of redirecting and redirecting
after that that's never going to bode
well and it's going to slow things down
as well enable browser caching so if you
enable browser caching basically if
somebody comes back to the page they've
been on say two days ago they're
probably gonna see a cache version of
that page and then opt for the content
delivery Network as well so these are
some of the ways to reduce page speed
now if you're curious about the page
speed of your website you can always go
to Google's page speed insights tool and
all you have to do is just Google page
speed insights or even just something
generic like Google page speed and
you're going to get this tool page speed
insights and all you need to do is just
plug in a URL when you plug in the URL
Google is going to analyze the URL for
both mobile and desktop and so here we
we could see Google gives a score so we
could see the score from wall ball and
we could see the score for desktop just
by clicking on desktop and so here I
could see some of the issues that the
site may be having in terms of page load
time for their desktop if I flip over to
mobile you know here I could see some
other issues for example they have a
server static assets with efficient cash
policy now if you're not sure what the
heck that means you can always just
click on it and you can see some
specifics here and where you can just
always Google it as well uh here you got
the reduce the impact of third-party
code okay so that's another thing uh
reduce JavaScript execution time so
again going back to a lot of some of the
comments we made about coding okay some
sometimes too much code or code not
functioning as well as it should we'll
tend to slow down the site okay so you
can use page speed insights you can
always get a glimpse of how pages are
loading simply by also going to for
example Google analytics under Behavior
okay you can go to site speed and if you
click on overview okay Google what
Google does is they do a sampling of
pages over time and in this case based
on 89 Page views they have an average
page load time and so you can get a
sense of how quick specific Pages load
or your site overall simply by looking
at the site speed overview report in
Google analytics to get a sense of how
quick your pages are loading now there
are certain factors that do affect load
time so obviously the way the page is
built with the code the images Etc but
also the browser each browser loads
differently okay so you want to take a
look at it by browser also by country
every country has a different network
you can be in the United States and have
worse network service than you do say in
you know Coast uh Ivory Coast in Africa
okay so it really depends on the network
you're on so and also the page every
page is built differently so you want to
get a sense of what pages are loading
quicker and which pages are not you can
simply just go to page timings and
Google analytics you get a sense of what
pages do not load fast and which ones do
and maybe hone in on the pages that
aren't loading fast and address those
pages first okay so you have two tools
at your disposal one Google analytics
and one page speed insights okay so
let's look at question number nine here
so when should an individual Target
short tail and long tail keywords okay
so remember short tail are usually one
to two keywords very Broad in nature
long tail keywords or maybe three four
keywords in a query or maybe an entire
sentence those are considered long tail
keywords so usually short tail case
words of higher volume but also higher
competition longer tail keywords usually
have lower volume but also lower
competition but the great thing about
long tail keywords the conversion rate
will tend to be a little bit higher than
say a short tail because it's less vague
and more specific so you can use short
tail keywords if you're trying to drive
a lot of visitors because those keywords
are going to be vague or Broad in nature
long tail keywords are used for targeted
Pages such as product pages and articles
so if you have a specific product with a
long name you can certainly optimize
that page for that product name again
the product name may have low volume but
if somebody types in exactly that
product name you show up the chance of
you them converting are going to be very
high so you don't have to always be that
specific at the product name but try and
be as specific as you possibly can in
order to get somebody to click on your
link in the search engine results and
get them over to your site to convert
okay so those are really the big
differences short tail very broad very
vague a lot of volume but also a lot of
competition but hey if you're ranking
for short tail keyword you're probably
going to get a lot of traffic the
conversion rates may not be as high as
something say long tail where hey maybe
you're just honed in on a few setting